Die EM läuft, bist du im Fußballfieber?
Nein, aber ich habe mir die Dreierkette erklären lassen.
Aha, du weißt jetzt Bescheid, du bist jetzt eingeweiht. Was ist denn eine Dreierkette?
Das ist für die Abwehr ganz entscheidend. Also die Abwehr wird als Dreierkette, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, aufgestellt oder Viererkette. Und wie ich hörte, ist Jogi Löw ein Anhänger der Dreierkette. Und viele Fußball-Experten, also das sind ja im Prinzip 80 Millionen in Deutschland, sagen nein, diese Dreierkette ist nicht gut, nicht stark genug. Die Viererkette muss es eigentlich sein. Jogi muss zurücktreten. Und ja, jetzt wird man sehen, ob er recht behält mit der Dreierkette oder der Viererkette.
Ja, ich hab ja dein Tweet gelesen. Du hast ja irgendwie geschrieben zur Einstimmung auf die EM für uns alle. Du hoffst, dass die Dreierkette hält. Und da hab ich schon gedacht, oh nein, nicht mal Wolfgang, der mit Fußball nichts am Hut und vor allem nichts am Fuß hat, kann sich dagegen verwahren, dass, und das nervt mich nämlich ohne Ende, weil ich gucke jetzt auch ein bisschen Fußball, dass alle nur noch so Taktik-Scheiß besprechen. Überall. Ich find's ja super gut, dass es da für Podcasts Ecken gibt. Alle lieben den Rasenfunk und so weiter. Aber wenn ich Fußball gucke, will ich dazu ein paar Chips essen, vielleicht mal ein Zuckergetränk trinken. Und dann will ich Bellarretti hören, wie er Stimmung macht. Und mittlerweile wird ja sogar Bellarretti unterbrochen von irgendeinem Sandro Wagner oder so, den ich nicht kenne, der keine Ahnung, welche Ahnung von Fußball hat, der mir irgendwas erklärt, was auf dem Feld angeblich stattfindet, was ich aber nicht sehe, da ich nicht mit imaginären Linien zwischen denen, die gerne in Halbzeitpausen in der Analyse eingemalt werden, ich habe ja keine imaginierten Linien vor mir sehe, also gar keine Verkettungen und so weiter. Ich will einfach nur Fußball gucken und muss mich mittlerweile die ganze Zeit mit so einem akademischen Scheiß da rumschlagen und das gefällt mir nicht. Ich möchte hier die Rüge an ADOZRF... Willst du noch den echten Fußball wieder haben? Ich will nur Stimmung.
Aber dann willst du ja auch eigentlich die echten Fußballer zurück. Also das sind ja auch eigentlich jetzt nur noch so Sprechpuppen, nett anzusehen. Also da ist ja dann schon jedes menschliche Zeichen irgendwie schon ein Ereignis. Denn eigentlich ist das ja so... Also ich glaube, dass das, was man eigentlich will, ist Philipp Lahm, der wie so ein Pressesprecher in Personalunion und auch noch guter Fußballspieler auftritt und einfach nur ganz sauber spricht und alles ordentlich macht. Also du willst dann vielleicht auch den wilden Fußball zurück.
Also ich will das Beste aus beiden Welten. Ich will, dass die Trainer sich mit dem richtig auskennen, was Sandro Wagner mir als Volkshochschullehrer versucht zu erklären. Ich will, dass die so spielen. Denn diese Franz Beckenbauer herangehensweise an den Fußballball annehmen, schauen und dann spielen, das will ich ja auch nicht. Ich will ja keinen Standfußball mit den alten Hautdegen, die dann nochmal und so geruhsam ein Spiel von hinten aufbauen. Ich will ja, dass es zackig, schnell und so weiter. Nur ich will das nicht erklärt haben die ganze Zeit. Ich will ja auch nicht in einem Film die ganze Zeit erklärt haben, wo jetzt hier Greenscreen ist und was dann doch echt ist und so. Sondern ich will einfach nur das Erlebnis haben. Und das bekomme ich aber nicht mehr. Und ich kann auch nicht stumm gucken. Also ich gehöre wahrscheinlich zu einem der wenigen. Es gibt ja nicht nur 80 Millionen Menschen, die besser Fußball spielen können als die Fußballspieler und besser Taktik machen können als die Trainer. Sondern es gibt ja auch 80 Millionen Menschen in Deutschland, die Bella Reti nicht leiden können. Dazu zähle ich ausdrücklich nicht. Ich liebe Bella Retis Stimme und seine Stimmung, die er damit erzeugt. Und wenn dann irgendwer dazwischen quatscht, nervt mich das ohne Ende. Also es ist keine gute EM, natürlich auch noch mal gedeckelt durch Corona und so weiter, dass ich das auch alles ein bisschen albern fand, auch wie dieses Spiel gegen Ungarn dann überhöht wurde und so.
Ja, ich hab mir bislang gar nichts angesehen und das wird auch so bleiben. Also da kann passieren, was will. Ich hab natürlich diese ganzen Diskurse jetzt mitbekommen, Regenbogenfahne hin und her.
Willst du noch was zur Regenbogenfahne sagen? Ich glaube, es haben noch nicht alle 80 Millionen Deutschen was zur Regenbogenfahne gesagt.
Soll ich noch irgendwas dazu sagen? Ich finde es natürlich ganz amüsant, dass man die plötzlich so haben will. Und eigentlich ist ja die EM rundweg abzulehnen. Man kann im Prinzip nichts Schlimmeres tun als EM gucken. Also selbst Fleisch aus Brasilien nehmen und grillen, auf der Motorhaube eines laufenden SUVs wäre, glaube ich, noch besser. Aber diese Regenbogenfahne erfüllt dann auch primär eigentlich nicht die Funktion, ein Statement gegen Homophobie zu setzen. Ich glaube, es geht eigentlich darum, dass es einem erlaubt, ohne schlechtes Gewissen, dann die UEFA-Europameisterschaft zu konsumieren. Und alles unter der Fahne liegende bleibt ja dann auch unverändert. Also Korruption, Ausbeutung, das Paktieren mit faschistischen Regierungen. Und jetzt auch, ja, sich das so zurecht machen, wie das jetzt gerade geht mit den vollen Stadien. Und da ist man dann immer noch besser als in Mitteleuropa aufgestellt. Und dann geht man halt zu den Rechten hin und macht es dort. Schafft sich aber noch ein paar Awareness-Momente. Das fällt mir dazu ein. Aber es ist natürlich auch so müßig, darüber zu diskutieren. Also ich glaube, man war einfach froh, dass überhaupt noch etwas Ereignishaftes passiert. Weil auf dem Feld dann doch scheinbar nicht mehr so viel stattfindet. Weil das schon alles so durchkalkuliert ist. Weil man eigentlich den Eindruck hat, gut, da wird nur noch mit Schachfiguren gespielt und die wissen eigentlich auch nicht, was ist. Also es gibt ja die kleinsten Momente, die jetzt schon zu Mem werden. Also wenn Ronaldo eine Cola-Flasche wegstellt, der Pressekonferenz, dann bedeutet das schon irgendwas. Dann wird da eine Woche darüber geredet. Weil auf dem Spielfeld, glaube ich, nichts mehr da ist. Aber machen wir uns nichts vor, diese Art von Fußball da, die Leute noch in ihrer Erinnerung haben oder nur noch als Nostalgie mit sich rumtragen, wird es einfach nicht geben in einem so durch rationalisierten System. Da sehe ich auch keinen Rückkehr.
Du hast ja gestern eine Politik-Analyse zu Dieter Nuhr gemacht und hast ja auch noch mal darauf hingewiesen, es gibt ja diese neue Art von Humor. Oder ich mein, er hat es auch beschrieben, aber du hast es dann auch noch mal sozusagen über Bande aufgegriffen, dass man so Themen braucht mit Jaal, bei denen man sagt, Gott sei Dank, ich muss nicht drüber nachdenken, kenne ich aber und ich habe eine Meinung. Ja, so und das deckt ja diese Regenbogenfahne ganz wunderbar ab. Deswegen gibt es ja auch in jedem Podcast stundenlange Gespräche dazu. Ich fand trotzdem, auch wenn ich jetzt auch hart am Zynismus segle, bei solchen Sachen, denn wenn ich die CDUler sehe, wie sie da die Regenbogenfahne und dann gleichzeitig auch Twitter, das Abstimmungsverhalten zu den entsprechenden letzten Gesetzen und so weiter, ja, eher für alle und so, wie sie alle dagegen gestimmt haben, finde ich, hat es doch zu einigen lustigen Sachen geführt, wie zum Beispiel zu der Beobachtung, dass da bei der UEFA natürlich nichts unpolitisch ist. Und wenn die UEFA sagt, das war jetzt aber ein politischer Antrag, der hier an uns herangetragen wurde, ein politischer Wunsch aus München, ja klar, der Bürgermeister hat reingeschrieben, weil in Ungarn dieses Gesetz unterschrieben möchte, möchte ich die Regenbogenbeflaggung, kann man nicht sagen, sondern Beleuchtung des Stadions. Klar ist das dann politisch und die UEFA glaubt dann, sie könnte sagen, ja, dann ist unsere Antwort jetzt mal unpolitisch. Und wir weisen das zurück wegen unpolitisch. Da wünsche ich mir die 90er zurück, als die Love Parade loszog. Eine Million Menschen in Berlin, die alle gesagt haben, unsere politische Botschaft ist, wir sind hier mal unpolitisch. Als ob es ginge, also dieses stilische, wer war es? Watzlawik oder wie auch immer, man kann nicht kommunizieren. Man kann erst recht nicht politisch sein im Politischen. Naja, das fand ich ganz witzig.
Nur frage ich mich, warum man überhaupt in so einer Bittstellerposition von Seiten der Politik immer an die UEFA herantritt. Also das ist ja jetzt nicht eine Besatzungsmacht und wir müssen gehorchen, sondern man kann ja auch einfach mal machen.
Was passiert denn dann?
Schicken die sonst eine Armee oder was kommt dann?
Das frage ich mich bei der FIFA auch immer. Die FIFA ist ein ganz kleiner Club. Alle FIFA-Mitglieder, die nennenswert sind, passen in ein Gebäude und trotzdem dominieren die alles. Als ob man diese Geldströme nicht im Griff hätte. Als ob so viel zu verloren wäre, wenn jetzt so ein Fußballspiel tatsächlich in Budapest statt in London stattfinde oder so. Da frage ich mich auch, das ist am Ende ein Fernsehereignis. Sehr viele Leute sitzen davor und sehen volle Stadion und fragen sich, welche Meinung soll ich jetzt dazu haben? Kann ich jetzt einfach sagen, es ist aber toll, dass Orban das gemacht hat. Ich finde auch, diese ganzen Orban reißt dann doch nicht an, dass man auch die großen und mächtigen in der EU dann doch in so eine, wie Kindergartenkinder, du kriegst heute kein Dessert, ich hatte eh keinen Hunger. Wir machen das hier in Diskussion mit der Regenbogen-Flagge. Ich fand es sehr gut, dass Thomas Hitzelsberger im Fernsehen gesehen hat, dass die UEFA dagegen votiert hatte, war eigentlich ein Glücksfall für die Diskussion. Denn dadurch hatte man überhaupt keine Diskussion. Das hätte wahrscheinlich die echte Beleuchtung da gar nicht gebracht. Also in der Ansicht hat es so viele Effekte, die allerdings auf so einer Theaterbühne irgendwie stattfinden. Man merkt doch, das sind so Ausweichbewegungen, das sind so Verlegenseitsdiskussionen. Eigentlich wollte man über andere Sachen diskutieren und jetzt ist man doch irgendwie ganz froh, dass man sich, dass man den Drang zum Bekenntnis einfach mal ablegen konnte beim Thema, wo es nicht allzu kontrovers ist, weil die Gegenspieler sind dann Orban, die UEFA, also wo es einfach fällt.
Obwohl ich auch wieder ein bisschen verwundert war, als ich sah, wer da so sich hinter dem Tor von Manuel Neuer positioniert hatte, dass das möglich ist, also dass so Leute dann auch durch die Gegend reisen und in Stadien reinkommen, denn die sahen ja nun so faschistisch aus, mehr geht ja nicht mehr und dass die dann alle dort sitzen können, da würde ich sagen, wenn irgendwo zwei Ende-Geländeleute rumlaufen und irgendein Plakat schwingen, dann kommt sofort die Polizei an und die würden nirgends mehr durchgelassen werden. Und hier sagt man ja hier, liebe Hooligans, liebe Faschisten, schönen Abend im Stadion, bitte.
Ja, ich mein, was hatten wir jetzt für einen Stress die letzten 15 Monate, 16, 17, wegen Corona? Und dann plötzlich sind die Stadien einfach voll und es wird so breit hin akzeptiert. Was haben wir für einen Stress mit rechten Terror hier in Deutschland? Die Todeslisten sind ja lang, die Zeit hat sie an dieser Recherche da, mit fast 200 Todesfällen, aufsummiert. Wenn dann aber Fußball ist, geht plötzlich die Corona-Logik, ja dann ist alles egal, dann hast du, das war eine sehr schöne Gegenüberstellung auf Twitter, hab ich gesehen, auf der einen Seite der Typ, der aufs Feld gerannt ist, mit der Regenbogen-Fahne, gegen den wird natürlich ermittelt, dann hast du da einen halben Blog, der irgendwie einen Hitlergruß zeigt, die dürfen natürlich einfach wieder nach Hause fahren. Da geht dann gar nichts auf deutschen Boden, da kann man dann einfach hier herkommen, mal einen Hitlergruß zeigen, Deutschland, Deutschland, Schwule Deutschland oder so, singen, während man da durch die Stadt in München läuft, und dann fährt man wieder nach Hause. Also das ist auch diese interessante Verlogenheit, dass die CDU mit Armin Laschet jetzt am Steuerrad auf der einen Seite Ohrbahn verteidigt, und zwar ganz konkret in der Diskussion. Es war ja, da saß ich ja mit Ischinger zusammen in dieser Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz, Triel-Runde und vorher haben die ja nochmal ein Triel gemacht, eher mit Baerbock und Scholz, wo es um Europa ging. Auch da war die Ohrbahnfrage anhängig und er konnte sich da nicht frei machen von Ohrbahn, sondern hat das noch verteidigt und so weiter. Aber beim Fußball geht plötzlich alles. Da sind so andere Regeln. Da ist dann zwanghaft unpolitisch. Da kann man dann plötzlich die Ohrbahn-Fans da irgendwie vor Ort haben. Na ja, in deren Sicht ist die EM dann doch politisch verseucht. Es ist Politik verseucht einfach, es ist Politikverseuchung. Und mal gucken, wer Europameister wird.
Die Kinos machen jetzt wieder auf und das ist toll. Wenn Deutschland weiterkommen sollte, dann gehe ich natürlich immer dann ins Kino. Wenn die Deutschland-Spiele sind, dann bin ich auf jeden Fall da allein. Na ja, es gibt jetzt schon eine Sehnsucht danach, wieder ins Kino zu gehen.
Ich glaube schon bei einigen Leuten.
Ja, es wird ein bisschen nachholender Konsum sein. Also bei mir wird es so sein, dass ich mir alles ansehe. Ich habe schon die glaubtesten Komödien mir ausgesucht, die ich mir im kommenden Monat ansehe.
Ich warte auf James Bond und ich wundere mich, dass sie es nicht im Sommer jetzt doch eingeplant haben. Also dass sie einfach dem Sommer-Effekt nicht vertraut haben, sondern wieder in den Winter gegangen sind oder Herbst, November. Ich glaube, das wird wieder schwierig, denn die Angst vor Delta ist groß.
Ja, müssen wir dann vor Delta Angst haben?
Hatschi, nein, nicht, wenn man schon mal Schnupfen durchgemacht hat, wie ich das jetzt lese und höre. Drossen und Kikolay waren ja, wenn auch nur spekulierend, aber sich dann doch recht eindeutig, dass es jetzt Richtung Corona 1, 2, 3 geht. Sehr ansteckend, aber den wird nicht weiter gefährdend. Klar, auch über die demografische Zusammensetzung der Patientenopfer in England sieht man jetzt, es sind dann jüngere Betroffenen, die kommen nicht so häufig ins Krankenhaus, aber es scheint doch eine sehr viel weniger gefährliche Krankheit zu sein als andere Corona-Varianten, die wir so haben.
Vorausgesetzt, man ist durchgeimpft?
Vorausgesetzt, man ist durchgeimpft, aber auch wenn die Voraussetzung nicht gegeben ist, würde ich sagen, sieht man jetzt nirgendwo besorgniserregende Zahlen, die wirklich eine höhere Gefährlichkeit sind. Es ist die Ansteckung. Du hast halt einfach eine breitere Refektionsmitteilung.
Ja, wir haben ja in Großbritannien zum Teil 16.000 Fälle, aber dann 10, 15, 20 Tote. Davon sind dann manchmal auch Leute schon einmal geimpft, manchmal sogar zweimal. Da weiß man nicht, warum das dann da nicht gewirkt hat. Aber alles in allem scheinen ja diese Impfungen sehr gut zu wirken. Vor allem die mRNA-Stoffe dann nochmal besser. Das hat man dann auch nochmal in Tabellen sehen können. Insofern habe ich jetzt nicht so nachvollziehen können, warum so viele sagen, naja, jetzt wird das vielleicht noch ein angenehmer Sommer. Aber eigentlich sollte man jetzt schon sich das feiern, lachen und singen verbieten. Denn dann kommt Delta und dann denke ich, na wenn wir dann tatsächlich fast alle geimpft sind, beziehungsweise alle Impfwilligen geimpft sind, dann dürfte das ja eigentlich nicht mehr das große Problem sein. Dann bekommt man vielleicht irgendwann mal was, denkt, ach, ich habe heute einen Schnupfen, weiß aber gar nicht mehr, dass es Corona ist. Aber wir sind ja dann nicht an dem Punkt angelangt, bei dem man sagen kann, jetzt müssen wir wieder in den Lockdown gehen. Jetzt haben wir bald die Intensivbetten voll. Jetzt heißt es aber, die Reißleine ziehen. Das wird ja eher nicht der Fall sein, sondern das große Risiko besteht für die Leute, die gar nicht geimpft sind. Und die werden sich das wahrscheinlich auch noch mal dann im Herbst überlegen, ob sie wirklich bei dieser Linie bleiben wollen. Aber eigentlich kann es doch dann gar nicht mehr so furchtbar, wie das jetzt ausgemalt wird.
Also bei mir ist es so, dass ich mittlerweile meinem Bauch mehr vertraue als nicht einzelnen Wissenschaftlern, sondern der Grundstimmung, die Journalisten daraus stricken. Und ich saß ja im November in Presseklubben, hab der Frau Bernd von der Süddeutschen Zeitung gesagt, doch, die Antigen-Tests werden den Unterschied machen. Und die haben dann auch einen Unterschied gemacht. Und ich war auch immer überzeugt, dass es diesen saisonalen Effekt gibt, für den, um das einzusehen, hat ja Lauterbach wirklich warten müssen, bis die Inzidenz dann unter zehn fiel und irgendeine Studie gesagt hat, ja, da geht doch so mit 40 Prozent in die Rechnung ein. Also auch da wieder Bestätigung. Und ich hab jetzt bei Drosten, auch wenn es ein sehr spekulatives Argument ist, aber es steckt drin in dem letzten Podcast, und bei Kikule erst recht rausgehört, Corona, also saß Kopf zwei, das wurde Corona, entwickelt sich jetzt Richtung Schnupfen. Und deswegen bin ich mir sehr sicher, dass der Drosten nicht ohne Grund, seit mehreren Ausgaben, darauf hinweist, wir können jetzt nicht weiter immer an der Inzidenz hängen, denn die Inzidenz wird's ja geben. Auch er hat ja schon angekündigt, Impfung oder Infektion, aber eben bis Ende 2022, also bis dahin sind 82 Millionen Menschen in Deutschland erreicht. Das Virus ist zu notisch, es springt jetzt zwischen den Lebewesen und Tierarten und so weiter hin und her und bleibt deswegen. Also ich bin da ganz entspannt, aber da kommen wir auch nachher drauf. Es gibt mittlerweile dann doch auch in Deutschland jetzt dieses die ersten bekommen ein Angebot sich impfen zu lassen, lassen sich aber nicht impfen. Also das ist da auch schon, also ich habe es selber hier in meinem Wohnzimmer erlebt, dass Mütter hier standen und meinten, die Kinder setzen jetzt die Masken ab in der Schule. Und ich dachte, ja ist doch gut, es ist Sommer, warum sollte man sie weiter striezen? Nirgendwer setzt mehr Masken auf. Bei der EM sieht man es ja, da ist ja auch Maskenpflicht eigentlich in Deutschland. Und dann auf meinen Hinweis, aber wir sind doch alle geimpft als Eltern.
Nee, ich lass mich nicht impfen.
Ich hab's jetzt anderthalb Jahre geschafft. Und da hab ich auch gedacht, also, Trosten hat uns immer gesagt, die nicht medizinischen Interventionen, die nicht klinischen, die nicht, da links der Bums. Also alle Maßnahmen, die man pandemisch drum herum macht, weil man weder Medikamente noch Impfung hat, sind Ersatz für den Fall, dass man dann mal Medikamente und Impfungen hat. Und jetzt haben wir Medikamente und Impfungen, also zumindest Impfungen, ganz groß geschrieben. Und dadurch müssen die nicht pharmazeutischen Interventionen dann auch wirklich wegfallen. Und ich hoffe, dass das dann auch in den Winter hinein so gilt. Und dass man dann nicht so einen Inzidenzstress macht, der am Ende nicht...
Also wir können dann nicht jedenfalls auf die Rücksicht nehmen, die sich nicht haben impfen lassen. Oder was ich besorgniserregend finde, ist, dass manche jetzt, wie man sagt, impfmüde werden. Das heißt, die haben die erste Impfung, haben den Termin dann sechs Wochen später, gehen dann aber nicht hin, weil ja auch das Wetter so schön ist und man doch mal zwei Bad könnte. Und ach nee, ich hab auch gehört, bei der zweiten Impfung, da kann man dann doch mal Kopfschmerzen bekommen. Das will ich jetzt nicht. Und dann lass ich das einfach mal liegen. Da würde ich sagen, können wir nicht für diese Leute dann im November wieder einen Lockdown machen, weil die zu doof waren.
Also das geht dann nicht.
Ich persönlich kenne keine Impfgegner. Also aus der gesamten Familie, Bekanntenkreis. Ich kenne niemanden. Ich kenne auch ein paar Leute, die noch nicht durchgeimpft sind oder noch nicht die Erstimpfung sogar haben. Jüngere Leute natürlich. All das gibt es. Aber das sind alles Impfwillige, die sich am liebsten im Januar hätten impfen lassen. Aber ich kenne keine, die sich nicht impfen lassen wollen. Offenbar gibt es natürlich Leute, die es nicht machen. Aber wir machen diese Impfmüden, also diese Liturgie, dass man auch ja jetzt ist aber auch doch so niedrig. Jetzt brauche ich das ja gar nicht. Also jetzt auch dieser Satz, ich habe eineinhalb Jahre ohne es geschafft. Ja klar, man kann es vielleicht auch drei Jahre ohne schaffen, aber man wird dann nicht mehr ein normales Leben führen, es sei denn, man sagt dann irgendwann gut dann Corona, komm. Das ist etwas, was mir Sorge bereitet. Aber da würde ich sagen, auf diese Stuhlköpfe kann ich dann keine Rücksicht nehmen. Das machen wir im Übrigen in anderen Feldern auch nicht. Also wenn ich gewisse Dinge nicht mache, gewisse Leistungen nicht erbringe, gewisse Sachen nicht bezahle oder so, dann bekomme ich auch da was abgedreht oder dort eine Leistung nicht und so. Und da muss man auch hier sagen, ja, das ist dann so. Also das Angebot ist dann ja für alle erbracht worden.
Genau, das ist die entscheidende Sache. Irgendwann ist das Impfangebot für alle da. In Sachsen sind wir jetzt schon so weit, habe ich gelesen. Und dann werden die Termine verteilt und dann noch eingehalten. Und wenn die durch sind, sind wir durch. Und das schaffen wir aber bis Oktober. Und in deren Sicht, würde ich sagen, sollten wir uns hier im Winter dann anders aufstellen als vorher. Gut, damit stecken wir aber nicht ein. Corona machen wir nachher nochmal. Das erste Thema, was sie uns ausgesucht haben, ist Hanna. Ich kenne sie nicht, ich kannte sie nicht. Ich habe mich lange gewundert über diesen Hashtag. Bis ich dieses Video sah, es geht um das Wissenschafts-Arbeitszeit-Gesetz, das seit vielen Jahren viele junge Menschen quält. Und für viele dich und mich wahrscheinlich bedeutet, bloß keine Wissenschaft als Beruf. Den Quatsch machen wir nicht mit. Und ich bin ja auch fleißiger Leser des CDU-Programms gewesen, und will deswegen die Pointe gleich mal setzen. Nichts dazu steht im CDU-Programm. Weder was Wissenschafts-Arbeitszeit noch überhaupt Arbeitszeit, noch Befristung, noch sachgrundlose Befristung, außer sie soll bleiben.
Du hast ja gesagt im Presseclub, es ist ein Abschiedsbrief an die jüngere Generation. Es ist jetzt einfach Schluss. Also eigentlich sagt die CDU, ade, wir machen hier unseren Kram und hoffen, dass wir noch gewählt werden.
Genau, nicht ganz. Die CDU versteht das ja nicht als Abschiedsbrief. Der Freitag hat mich angefragt, ob ich dieses nochmal verargumentiere, habe ich natürlich gerne angenommen und den Text gestern geschickt. Weshalb die Woche im Freitag nochmal ein Text von mir kommt mit der Pointe, die kann ich jetzt schon mal verraten. Dieser Text ist nicht als Abschiedsbrief gemeint, aber so sollte er gelesen werden von den jungen Deutschen und den jungen Europäern. Ich habe gar nicht übers Klima oder so geschrieben im Text, sondern wirklich nur über Mietverträge, Arbeitsverträge und die schwarze Null. Denn ich glaube, das mit der Schuldenbremse ist eines der größten Fragestellungen, die noch offen ist. Der Herr Reitz vom Fokus, der mir gegenüber saß, meinte ja, das ist halt der Markenkern der CDU und so ein Argument kann man ihm nicht durchgehen lassen. Die Schuldenbremse ist ja nicht nur ein Markenkern der CDU, sondern die Schuldenbremse ist ja das Mittel, mit dem die CDU Deutschland Ketten anlegt, nur eben auch den Europäern im Euro-Raum. Und das ist der eigentliche Trick, dass man sich da absichert.
In gewisser Weise hat er recht, insofern als Thomas Bibericher ja eine sehr gute Geschichte des Konservatismus in Deutschland geschrieben hat, geistig-moralische Wände. Und Bibericher sagt auch, eigentlich hat die Union ja alles aufgegeben. Der Konservatismus funktioniert ja immer so, man ist die Handbremse und dann irgendwann lässt man aber los, wenn die Entwicklung so weit ist, dass man sie ohnehin nicht mehr aufhalten kann. Also man versucht so lange zu sagen, Mütter müssen bei ihren Kindern bleiben, bis man irgendwann sieht, gut, eine Wirtschaft, bei der alle Mütter zu Hause bleiben, ist nicht mehr möglich und dann sagt man, ja, wir müssen auch sicherlich den Müttern ermöglichen. Und so ist das bei der Ehe für alle und bei was auch immer. Und dann sagt dann Bibericher, was ist denn eigentlich in diesen vergangenen Jahrzehnten heute noch da von konservativen Werten oder wie das dann genannt wird? Gibt es da noch irgendeinen Kern? Und dann sagt er, war das einzige, was noch geblieben ist, ist dieses Schuldenbremse und deswegen ist man da so manisch besessen von und will unbedingt diese Schuldenbremse, weil man dann auch noch das aufgeben würde, dann hat man wirklich gar nichts mehr.
Ja, also ist ein ganz wichtiges Argument, dass noch mal die Dummheit der Konservativen aufzeigt. Aber es gibt eben auch dieses ganz wichtige Funktionale, das ganz wenig beschrieben wird, dass die CDU Deutschland damit so ein bisschen beschränkt, wir können dann die eine oder andere Investition nicht machen, die eigentlich nötig wäre, um beispielsweise Schritt zu halten mit China und Amerika. Aber Italien, Spanien, Portugal und Italien eben noch weniger. Und dadurch sind die angewiesen auf die deutschen Gaben der Anlagen- und Maschinenbauer, der Autoindustrie und wie auch immer. Wir sind Exportweltmeister nicht ohne Grund, weil wir uns über diese Schuldenbremse den europäischen Markt entsprechend aufbereitet haben. In Spanien mangels mittlerweile an allem. Da sind 30 Prozent der Schulabgänger und Universitätsabsolventen quasi für nichts eigentlich zu gebrauchen. Tagelöhntum, Nullqualifikation, ist alles ausgezerrt. Und die CDU schreibt ja schon wieder Strukturreform für die Euroländer in ihr Ereignisprogramm und sagt, wir wünschen uns einen stärkeren EU-Wirtschafts- und Wettbewerbskommissar. Und im nächsten Satz steht dann aber nicht, um Europa zu befähigen, mitzuhalten mit der Welt, sondern um die Maastricht-Kriterien durchsetzen zu können. Ja, also als Polizei mit der Schuldenbremse wünscht man sich eine stärkere EU-Kommission. Und das ist genau dieses ganz perfide, was jetzt auch die jungen Menschen wirklich mal lesen und ernst nehmen müssen. Die CDU tritt den U50 an, komplett in den Arsch, in Deutschland und in Europa. Also da keine falschen Vorstellungen, oder wir spielen es doch mal auf Nummer sicher und nehmen Laschet oder so. Diese Argumente müssen alle ausgeräumt werden. Die Grünen machen es leider nicht selber, deswegen müssen jetzt alle mal so ein bisschen mithelfen. Es ist ganz schlimm, was da passiert. Naja, einer dieser Aspekte ist halt dieses Wissenschafts-Arbeitszeit-Gesetz. Wir fangen mal an, indem wir einfach diesen Ursprungsklip gucken, nachdem dann alle, die das sahen, auf Twitter plötzlich schrieben, ich bin auch Hanna. Denn Hanna ist die Protagonistin eines Filmes des Wissenschaftsministeriums vom Bund, also Karliczek's Land, mit dem sie uns das schönreden will, was da auf Vorsicht geht.
Das ist Hanna. Sie ist Biologin. Sie schreibt an ihrer Doktorarbeit. Ihr Vertrag bei der Universität ist auf drei Jahre befristet. Er wurde jetzt um weitere drei Jahre verlängert. Danach kann sie erst wieder einen befristeten Vertrag unterzeichnen, der eine Qualifizierung zum Ziel hat, wenn ihre Promotion abgeschlossen ist. Hanna gehört zum wissenschaftlichen Personal. Deshalb unterliegt ihr Arbeitsvertrag dem Wissenschaftszeit-Vertragsgesetz. Kurz Wisszeit-VG. Wissenschaftliche Qualifizierung nach dem Wisszeit-VG bedeutet nicht nur Promotion oder Habilitation, sondern jede wissenschaftliche Tätigkeit in Forschung und Lehre, die eine erfolgreiche Karriere in der Wissenschaft oder auch in anderen Bereichen fördert. Damit auch nachrückende Wissenschaftlerinnen und Wissenschaftler die Chance auf den Erwerb dieser Qualifizierungen haben und nicht eine Generation alle Stellen verstopft, dürfen Hochschulen und Forschungseinrichtungen befristete Verträge nach den besonderen Regeln des Wisszeit-VG abschließen. So kommt es zu Fluktuation und die fördert die Innovationskraft.
So, Fluktuation fördert Innovationskraft. Das sind so Sätze, die fallen aus den CDU-Mündern raus und sorgen für Erstaunen.
Ja, das ist eine bodenlose Frechheit. Also, dass man sagt, man baut einen Druck auf, baut ein System auf, das auf Unsicherheit beruht. Und diese Unsicherheit aber, die spornt dann alle an, Top-Leistungen zu erbringen und sich in irgendeiner Weise durchzusetzen. Immer in dem Glauben, dass sich in einem solchen universitären System auch immer die Besten dann durchsetzen. Dass das immer nur daran liegt, wer die genialste Forschung gerade betreibt.
Genau, und wir wissen ja auch gerade in der Wissenschaft, die ja Wert drauf legt, dass man eben nicht weiß, was nach einem Experimenten, was nach einem Laborgang und so weiter rauskommt, wo man einen freien Kopf braucht, auch ein bisschen Mut und Experimentierfreude. Genau da ist es natürlich absolut adäquat, den Leuten zu sagen, heute ist April, im Oktober wirst du gefeuert und jetzt mach mal tolle Wissenschaft. Weil dann hat man den freien Kopf, um genau das zu machen. Auf dieses Video haben dann viele auf Twitter geschrieben, hallo, ich bin so und so und auch Hanna. Und da gibt es ja durchaus auch Wohlenwollende. Ich lese mal zum Beispiel von Jens Südekum, also Ökonomie-Professor in Düsseldorf, der geschrieben, hallo, ich bin Jens, Klammer auf 45, Klammer zu. Ich bin mit 31 Jahren W3-Prof hier VWL geworden. Ich kenne das akademische Up or Out Game, beziehungsweise die Upside, Klammer zu. Also ganz gut, aus eigener Erfahrung. Ich unterstütze das, ich bin Hannah Anliegen und würde es gerne etwas einordnen. Also selbst die Wohlwollen, die sagen, es gibt diese Kritik, aber jetzt auch mal aus Sicht des Professors usw. da wusste sie sozusagen ausgezahlt hat. Und er beschreibt dann, wie er Ende der 90er-Jahre an die Uni kam und dort lauter Leute Anfang 50, unkündbar, null Forschungsausput, keine Lust auf Lehre, tatsächlich, wie im Video gesagt, die Universitäten verstopft haben mit diesen A13- bis A15-Stellen, also noch weit höher angesiedelt als diese neuen Eingliederungen, die es da gibt. Aber auch Jens Südekum weiß noch mal ausdrücklich darauf hin, das Ziel dieser Reform, die dazu führte, dass die Menschen da fluktuativ schnell durchgestellt, das ging allein darum, Geld zu sparen. Da hat einfach die Landesregierung oder die Landesregierung haben gesehen, ah hier, die kosten uns alle zu viel, also machen wir das mal so und so. Und dann haben die Universitäten irgendwann festgestellt, wenn wir den Menschen, und die haben ja klare Stellenzahlen vorgegeben bekommen, wenn wir dann denjenigen, die sich da bewerben, eine 45% Stelle, eine 37, 5% Stelle, also die Mathematik gibt ja bis zur zweiten Komma-Stelle, da mittlerweile irgendwie, wie diese Stellen aufgeteilt werden auf Personen, dann arbeiten die ja trotzdem alle 100%. Also auch wer da zu 30% angestellt wird, den kann man ja trotzdem mal für 100% einplanen, weil es ist ja Windtundrennen und so. Und Südekum hat das dann auch nochmal ausführlich aufgeschrieben in der Fazit, in so einem größeren Text. Er präforiert dieses amerikanische Modell. Das allerdings, und das schreibt er auch in seinem Abschluss-Tweet, die schlechte Nachricht, die Umsetzung dieses Unisystems, also des vor allem amerikanischen, angelsächsischen, dürfte deutlich höhere Personalkosten im Bereich Wissenschaft und Forschung nach sich ziehen. Aber vielleicht ist das ja eine Überlegung wert für ein Land, Zitat, dessen einzige Ressource die Köpfe der Menschen sind. Also da ist aus allen Richtungen jetzt eigentlich dieses Gesetz in Kritik geraten. Und in diesem Video...
In diesem Video haben wir es doch mit einem Image-Video zu tun, das eigentlich jetzt, ich weiß gar nicht, für wen wurde es produziert. Also jemand, der in der Wissenschaft sich auskennt, oder der auch nur mal ein halbes Semester verbracht hat, der weiß, dass das gelogen ist, dass das einfach nicht stimmt. Will man damit nochmal neue Leute anlocken? Oder ist das einfach ein Video, das man für die Kollegen macht? Also macht Cardi Checks ein Video, damit die Kollegen sehen, ach ist ja toll, wurde gut gearbeitet im Ministerium. Ich frage mich wirklich, an wen richtet sich das? Denn das hat natürlich einen solchen Zorn hervorgerufen, dass man sich auch mal vorher fragen könnte, ist das sinnvoll, so ein Video zu machen? Ist das vielleicht gerade klug, das zu tun? Wenn Leute über Armut klagen, erzählt man dann was über Champagner vielleicht nicht. Also jetzt mal ein Beispiel, was mich jetzt ereilt hat über Facebook. Da hat mir eine Userin geschrieben, Katja, zu diesem Wissenschaftszeitgesetz. Ich habe meinen Job in der Wissenschaft gekündigt. Was ich in Bezug auf Arbeitsbedingungen, Vertragsbuch, emotionale Unterdrückung und Erpressung auch der Mitarbeiterinnen, Entsolidarisierung zwischen Kolleginnen, taktische Mitteleinwerbung bis hin zu Dingen, die gegen die gute wissenschaftliche Arbeit verstoßen, erlebt haben, würde ein Buch füllen. Wissenschaftlerinnen forschen beinahe kaum noch, sondern verwalten eher die Projekte, in denen sie angestellt sind. Ich bin Soziologin und war im Bereich Gesundheitswissenschaften tätig. Unsere Projekte hatten überwiegend den Charakter, systemstabilisieren zu sein anstatt innovativ. Das Prinzip aus Einwerbung, Publikation, Durchführung administrativen Aufgaben und neuer Einwerbung hindert am wissenschaftlichen Denken. Die Melange aus ständiger Überbelastung, Entfremdung und Zukunftsängsten führt zuerst zu einer Art Tunnelblick und später zum Burnout. Ich bin froh, dass ich den Absprung geschafft habe.
Und für Katja, also ich frage mich auch, warum haben die das Video überhaupt gemacht? Es könnte durchaus ein Szenario denkbar sein, aber ich glaube, das ist ein Szenario, das wir in den letzten zehn Jahren mit dem ganzen Ministerium unter Merkel doppelt, also wirklich Faktor 2 Budget plötzlich hatten, in den letzten zehn Jahren, die haben immer mehr Geld bekommen, dass sie intern so Projekte hatten, wo dann irgendwer dachte, so ein Video wäre mal irgendwie ganz cool, das ist ja so meine Hoheit auf der Webseite, ich mache jetzt mal so ein Video. Und dass die Ministerin dann selber irgendwann, wieso haben wir denn hier jetzt so ein Ding losgetreten, wie konnte denn das passieren? Aber in diesem Video, das wir nun da haben, wurde genau für Katja, die jetzt geschildert hat, okay, wir kommen eigentlich gar nicht zum Forschen und wir erleiden hier alle Burnout und wir sind hier alle nur noch Konkurrenten untereinander und es funktioniert alles gar nicht. Das ist alles Katjas Schuld, wird in diesem Video behauptet. Ja. Und deswegen macht Katja auch das und das und geht dazu irgendwelchen, ja, so als 43-Jährige nochmal, lässt sich da irgendwie beraten und wie schreibt man jetzt Habilitationsbewerbungsposten, irgendwie blablabla und so. Also in deren Sicht ist dieses Video super interessant, weil es einerseits ganz perfide auf der sachlichen Ebene es verdreht und plötzlich von Fluktuationen und es ist alles verstopft und es muss so sein. Also alles, was wir überall als Flexibilisierung kritisieren, steht jetzt hier plötzlich als, ja, das ist so, also wir wollen das so, mit der Abschlussproante, du bist selber schuld. Also wenn du dich im System nicht zurecht findest, dann, du weißt ja eigentlich, ja, also dieser sukzessive Halbsatz am Anfang, den finde ich eigentlich besonders stark, Hanna weiß, dass sie das früh planen muss. Und dann ist sie jetzt selber schuld.
Wir hören uns mal an von der Philosophin Amrai Ba, worum es eigentlich jetzt denen geht, die da rebellieren.
Verlangt niemand oder fordert niemand, dass für die Promotionsphase jetzt alle entfristet werden. Es geht bei dieser Forderung in erster Linie um diejenigen nach der Promotion, die, wie sie ja eben schon ganz richtig gesagt haben, dann hoch qualifiziert sind, die beispielsweise an der Habilitation arbeiten oder an Vergleichbarem und die dann eben mit Ende 30, Anfang 40 in der freien Wirtschaft auch gar keine guten Chancen mehr haben, weil die Qualifikationen, die sie erworben haben, sind für diese Kontexte ja gar nicht relevant. Und im Übrigen geht auch Expertise in Forschung und Lehre dann natürlich verloren.
Ja, das ist glaube ich super wichtig und auch super interessant, wenn man sich es mal anguckt. Wir haben ja in Deutschland diese Bildungsexpansion gehabt, also mit den ganzen Uni-Gründungen vor 40 Jahren oder vor 50 Jahren, in den 70ern, mit dieser Schwemme an Abiturienten, mehr als die Hälfte der Schüler machen Abitur. Und da liegt es ja irgendwie nahe, dass man sagt, okay, dann setzen wir mal die Promotion als nach Bachelor, Master noch so als dritten Abschluss irgendwie fast. Also gar nicht als Qualifizierung, sondern wirklich so als Abschluss obendrauf. Und da finde ich macht diese Art der Befristung auch Sinn. Denn dann kann man einfach sagen, ja gut, also sechs Jahre, das wird ja wohl reichen. Nur wir verstehen das dann doch als Abschluss hinsichtlich Berufsqualifizierung, keine Ahnung. Irgendwo werden ja auch wirklich mal Doktoranden oder Promovierte gebraucht. Nur dieses System hier zieht sich ja bis zur Professur. Und damit hast du da so einen Flaschenhals drin, der es für alle ungemütlich macht. Und dann ist man eben auch nicht mehr Ende Zwanziger, Anfang 30 alt, sondern dann ist man so fast 50 oder schon darüber hinaus plötzlich. Und das ist eigentlich dieses Problem, dass man die Biografien einfach so hart bricht am Ende, weil einfach Zeit abgelaufen ist.
Und die stehen ja unter einem Druck, auch den Lebenslauf immer schön zu halten. Das heißt, man kann nicht sagen, gut, ich habilitiere jetzt, aber ich arbeite jetzt nebenher in der Werbeagentur und mache das auch mal ein Jahr voll und gehe dann wieder in die Lehre zurück. Man muss ja die ganze Zeit in der Lehre auch gewesen sein, um das zu dokumentieren. Das hat dann zur Folge, dass Leute irgendwo noch einen Leerauftrag annehmen, für den sie dann pro Semester vier, 500 Euro bekommen. Für das ganze Semester manchmal 800 Euro. Das heißt, die geben Seminare, jede Woche ein Seminar, müssen dann noch 30 Hausarbeiten oder Klausuren korrigieren, bekommen für all das zusammen, plus Vorbereitung, so 500 Euro, nur damit sie im Lebenslauf weiterhin sagen können, ja, ich hab dann in diesem Semester noch eine Vorlesung oder was weiß ich gehalten an der Uni in Gelsenkirchen. Gelsenkirchen hat wahrscheinlich keine in Greifswald oder sonst wo.
Ja, die Hälfte der Lehrveranstaltungen, die in deutschen Unis stattfindet, sind quasi unbezahlt. Ja. Nicht nennenswert bezahlt.
Also es ist nicht mal eine Aufwandsentschädigung. Die Leute müssen auch sehen, wo sie dann unterkommen, wenn sie in der Stadt nicht wohnen, dann übernachten die bei Freunden und so ist es katastrophal. Und das Schlüsselwort dann heißt ja Drittmittel einwerben. Damit geht das und da äußert sich auch Amrai Bar zu.
Nicht betroffen sind diejenigen, die rechtzeitig Drittmittel beschaffen für ihre Uni, also wer quasi durch eine sehr gute Forschungsidee seine eigene Stelle finanziert, mit Mitteln der DFG oder anderen. Das ist ja eigentlich eine Wettbewerbsidee, die auch fair ist oder nicht?
Also die Drittmittel sind glaube ich tatsächlich auch wichtig, in den Blick zu nehmen in dieser Diskussion und eher problematisch. Denn es ist in der Tat so, dass sie natürlich Geld einwerben können, um so eine Stelle dann zu haben. Die läuft aber auch wieder nur befristet, denn Drittmittel sind projektförmig. Also das heißt, die laufen über ein paar Jahre. Und wir haben es im Moment mit einer Situation zu tun, in der diese Drittmittel immer stärker aufwachsen, während die sogenannte Grundfinanzierung der Hochschulen nicht mehr so solide ist, dass man da überhaupt die Aufgaben, die Hochschulen haben, noch sicherstellen könnte, indem man eben Geld hat, um das Personal sicher zu finanzieren. Und das ist eine Verschiebung, die glaube ich Teil des Problems ist.
Ja, also diese Kriege um die Drittmittel, das tut mir dann auch immer leid. Da kenne ich auch einige, die nach ihrer Habitulation für sich und ihre drei Mitarbeiter für das Forschungsprojekt usw. dann diese Drittmittel beantragen müssen, was halt wirklich bedeutet, monatelanges Arbeiten bis tief in die Nacht. Dann gibst du diesen Antrag an, weiß, zu 12% kommt er irgendwie durch und es wird dir bewilligt, aber das erfährst du dann erst in einem dreiviertel Jahr.
Ganz genau.
Und damit hängst du nur in der Luft die ganze Zeit.
Und das ist ein bürokratischer Apparat, der so unfassbar ist. Mark Fischer hat das ja ganz gut auch herausgestellt, dass man ja mit dem Neoliberalismus eigentlich die Bürokratie verringern oder geabschaffen wollte. Und das Gegenteil ist passiert. Mittlerweile kommt ja fast auf jeden Lehrenden ein Mensch aus der Verwaltung. Und hinzu kommt noch, dass alle Leute, die eigentlich lehren und forschen sollen, auch die ganze Zeit mit Verwaltungsangelegenheiten beschäftigt sind. Und bei diesen Anträgen handelt es sich ja dann um Anträge von 100, 150 Seiten. Ich habe ja mal in einem Salon über so eine Begehung der DFG berichtet, wie irre das alles ist und dass das natürlich extrem viel Kapazitäten frisst. Das heißt, das sind junge Leute, die, wenn sie das dann irgendwann alles schaffen, zwar noch ihre Position bekommen vielleicht dann, also manche kommen ja dann durch, aber was sich dann oft einstellt, ist eine große Erschöpfung. Die sind dann ausgebrannt. Die haben dann so sehr gekämpft, um endlich diese Professur zu haben. Die kann man aber dann auch schon fast wieder pensionieren.
Oder auch Professur, den er heute manchmal befristet. Also ist ja nicht immer so dieses Reihenrücken ins Wissenschaftssystem. Also in der Ansicht ist das wirklich alles, es ist wirklich ein richtig krankes System.
Ja, es wird aber jetzt noch verrückter, denn es gab eine aktuelle Stunde dazu im Bundestag. Und jetzt hören wir mal Karliczek, was sie so sagt zu den Hannas.
Und was die jungen Männer und Frauen unter dem Hashtag Ich bin Hanna berichten, ist ohne Frage bewegend. Und das sind zum Teil schwierige Situationen, in denen die Autorinnen und Autoren stecken, für die sie ihren Umgang finden müssen, ihren Weg, ihre Form auch, diese Herausforderung zu meistern. Die Frage ist aber, liegt das an dem Gesetz, auf das sie sich gerade alle stürzen? Und da sage ich ganz klar nein.
Nein, sie wiederholt hier nochmal exakt den Spot und sagt, ja dann muss man dann sehen, wie man das so meistert.
Da muss man seinen Weg finden.
Ja, herrlich. Wir hören mal noch mal weiter, was sie dann zu sagen hat.
Liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen, ich glaube, wir sind auf dem richtigen Weg. Und wir als Bundesregierung sind nun wirklich in dieser Zeit sehr, sehr engagiert im gesamten Bildungswesen unterwegs. Das und nicht Wahlkampfgetöse können wir auch von allen anderen erwarten im Interesse der Wissenschaft.
Im gesamten Bildungswesen, 16 Monate nach Corona, mit Homeschooling und anderen Katastrophen, sind wir sehr gut aufgestellt.
Ja, wo wir jetzt gehört haben, dass Homeschooling so effektiv ist wie Sommerferien in dieser einen Studie, wo das schon mal so schön auf den Punkt gebracht wurde. Ich meine, das CDU-Programm besteht, ich übertreibe jetzt, aber gefühlt zur Hälfte aus Deutschland, der Technologie-Standort, die Digitalisierungsoffensive und die Transformative, blablabla und so. Und da geht es um Quantencomputer und da geht es um neue Rechenzentren und dieses ganze Cloud und so weiter und so fort. Und die CDU will aber da kein Geld ausgeben. Und diese Dysbalance zwischen Semantik und Struktur bei der CDU ist wahrscheinlich nirgendwo so groß wie bei diesem Thema. Selbst beim Thema Armut oder so ist es noch... Also da passt es noch so ein bisschen zusammen, da kann man einfach sagen, ja gut, da wollen sie halt mit Absicht das und jenes nicht, aber bei der Karliczek kommt ja auch so eine Art von, wie soll man sagen, Unwissenheit dazu, dass sie es wirklich nicht weiß, dass sie wahrscheinlich so Unis nie von innen gesehen hat, dass sie nicht weiß, was Projekt bedeutet, was Drittmittel bedeutet, was wissenschaftliche Karriere bedeutet und so überhaupt. Und sie steht da einfach da und wiederholt dieses Video. Ja, man wird da schon seinen Weg finden. Und die sind aber alle tapfer.
Es klingt eher nach Baumschule und sie hat dann auch wirklich nochmal für Zorn gesorgt dort im Bundestag, als sie dann nochmal auf diese Evaluation angesprochen wurde. Und das ging dann auch bei Twitter zu recht ab, denn an den Universitäten, da ist eigentlich ja gar nichts passiert, so in den letzten Monaten, glaubt sie.
Und die Ergebnisse der noch laufenden Evaluation liegen im Frühjahr 2022 vor. Das stimmt nicht. Das stimmt, aber sie können eine Evaluation nicht vornehmen, wenn in Hochschulen überhaupt gar nichts im Moment stattfindet.
Ja, an Hochschulen findet nichts statt. Es wurden keine Klausuren ausfallen gelassen. Es werden keine Seminare ausfallen gelassen. Es sind alle am Arbeiten, nur halt zu ganz unglücklichen Bedingungen. Und ich habe jetzt schon gehört, dass einige Universitäten sagen, wollen wir das Risiko überhaupt jetzt eingehen mit Herbst? Lass uns doch das nächste Wintersemester auch nochmal komplett im Homeoffice verbringen. Wo ich denke, wie irre kann man sein?
Ja, das gefällt vielen ziemlich gut. Das finde ich auch erstaunlich.
Es ist ganz entsetzlich. Jedenfalls ist da die Opposition mal auf Zack und argumentiert sehr schön und auch sehr polemisch dagegen. Wir hören jetzt als Ersten den Kai Gehring von den Grünen. Der weist mal darauf hin, was mal im Koalitionsvertrag eigentlich stand. Die heutige Misere war schon 2018 absehbar. Da schrieben Union und SPD ziemlich ambitionslos in den Koalitionsvertrag, Zitat, wir wollen den wichtigen Weg für gute Arbeit fortsetzen und die Evaluationsergebnisse der letzten Novelle des Wissenschaftszeitvertragsgesetzes auswerten, Zitat Ende. Das BMBF hat diese Evaluation dann so lange herausgezögert, dass diese wichtigen Ergebnisse erst 2022 vorliegen. Dann hätten sie auch gleich in den Koalitionsvertrag schreiben können, wir sitzen das aus.
Das wäre zumindest ehrlich gewesen.
Na, immerhin rutscht es rein in den Koalitionsvertrag. Das ist nicht der CDU anzulassen, sondern das ist wahrscheinlich noch danke SPD.
Wahrscheinlich. Jetzt hören wir Thomas Sattelberger von der FDP, der eine ganz interessante Witte hat, wie ich dann gelesen habe. Der war nämlich früher in der APO engagiert, mit dem Maoismus liebäugelte er. Ist dann irgendwann zur FDP gegangen, also eine kleine Kehrtwende. Aber hier ist er dann doch in dieser Rede erstaunlich sozial und argumentiert sehr sinnvoll und spitzt das noch mal zu.
Wenn wir Spitzenforscherinnen und Spitzenforscher haben wollen, dann müssen wir ihnen eine planbare Lebenssituation bieten.
Wichtig vor allem für die Forscherinnen.
Das miserable Deutsche Wissenschaftszeitvertragsgesetz wird noch evaluiert. Das Ergebnis hinterlässt die Forschungsministerin den Nachfolgern als vergiftetes Erbe. Frau Karliczek, das ist kein guter Stil. Das ist wie ein leeres Blatt, das in der Klausur abgegeben wird. Note ungenügend.
Ja, die Karliczek nutzt ja manchmal die Gelegenheit zu sagen, wir verpflichten ja niemanden, das Wissenschaftszeitvertragsgesetz anzuwenden, sondern es ist die Option, die Unis haben, um der Verstopfung vorzubeugen, was ja auch formal stimmt. Die Unis müssen ja nicht. Die können ja auch einfach alle festanstellen, und dann ist es halt. Aber ne, die gehen natürlich alle aus den Gründen, wie zum Beispiel, dass sie es dann auf die Motivationslage der einzelnen verlagern. Lieber eine halbe Stelle als gar keine, auch wenn ich für die zweifach arbeiten muss. Und in der Hinsicht liegt hier auch von der Politik motivierte Ausnutzung vor, die die Universitäten dann aber auch ein bisschen auf ihre Kappe machen müssen. Also es gibt hier so ganz viele Schuldige. Eigentlich müsste man mal so im großen Ganzen da, sich die ganze Landschaft mal anschauen.
Man kann diese Lebensläufe im Übrigen ganz gut vergleichen mit Theaterkarrieren. Also es ist ja auch so, dass es dort gewisse Richtlinien gibt, ab wann jemand fest im Ensemble dann auch unbefristet sein soll. Und das hat zur Folge, dass natürlich bevor diese Grenze überschritten wird, man sofort gekündigt bekommt. Und manchmal sind dann irgendwelche Intendanten, die sagen, na ja, hat so treuer Dienst, der weiß nicht, ich hab da mal die Frist aus Versehen verstreichen lassen, hab das gar nicht mitbekommen. Und hoch, jetzt ist er fest im Ensemble. Aber das liegt ja nur daran, weil man da auch so gespart hat und Ensemble-Strukturen so kaputt gemacht hat, dass man diesen Wettbewerb jetzt haben muss, damit man tatsächlich nicht diese Verstopfung hat, weil man nur noch kleine Ensembles hat. Und wenn man natürlich nur 12 Leute hat und am Ende sind die alle über 50, dann kann man nicht mehr Romeo und Julia spielen. Und da ist das große Problem. Aber das liegt einfach daran, dass man diese Strukturen geschaffen hat, in denen es dann ein solches Regime gibt, das nur noch Verlierer produziert am Ende oder ganz, ganz wenige Gewinner. Und das ist so was von grässlich zu sehen. Und da werden die künstlerischen Leistungen natürlich auch nicht besser. Jetzt kommt noch mal Nicole Golke von der Linkspartei. Und die spricht auch nochmal über einen Aspekt, den wir mal mit einbedenken sollen. Denn wir sehen uns als Deutschland ja immer als das Land, wo alle hinwollen.
Eine Historikerin schreibt auf Twitter, dass sie seit Monaten Schlafstörungen hat, weil das Wissenschaftszeitvertragsgesetz sie ab November arbeitslos machen wird. Eine Veterinärmedizinerin will nach 12, 12 befristeten Arbeitsverträgen in Folge, nach einer Anstellung auf einer Viertelstelle. Und jetzt der Ansage ihres Chefs, wer schwanger wird, bekommt den Vertrag nicht verlängert, die Wissenschaft verlassen. Und viele, viele schreiben, dass sie Deutschland bereits verlassen haben, weil es im Ausland bessere berufliche Perspektiven in der Wissenschaft für sie gibt.
Ja, wir haben ja Adrian Daub gelesen zum Silicon Valley mit der Stanford-Uni und der hat ja auch nochmal darauf hingewiesen, dass es da Gange und Gäbe ist. Einmal in der Uni aufgenommen. Gehört man irgendwie zur Uni, auch wenn man selber berufliche Pausen einlegt. Und das geht ja durch, die Absolventen werden dann immer noch angeschrieben, gehören immer noch zum Club, sollen immer noch mitfinanzieren und so weiter. Und das ist im Grunde das, was hier fehlt. Dass man einfach sagt, es ist ja nicht ohne Grund, dass irgendwie eine einstellige Prozentzahl der deutschen Professoren überhaupt Kinder haben oder verheiratet sind oder Kinder haben und verheiratet sind. Also es kommt ja eigentlich nicht vor, da du das in den wichtigen Lebensjahren, in den 20er- 30er- 40er-Jahren dir nicht erlauben kannst, im Abseits der Wissenschaft noch was zu machen. Du musst dann auf Abruf, je nachdem, wo sich Stellen ergeben, wo Projekte sind, alle halbe Jahre musst du irgendwie umziehbar sein. Du musst dann auch die Städte wechseln. Ich hab mich auch während jetzt dieser Monate zu Leaf und die Diskussion, also die Bundestagswahl habe ich dann nicht geguckt, weil du hast hier vor uns geguckt. Da habe ich mir auch so gedacht, wie interessant eigentlich, dass wir parallel eine Diskussion über Annalena Baerbocks Lebenslauf haben. Also eine junge Frau, die noch was werden will, schreibt über sich selbst. Damit können natürlich 20 Jahre ältere Männer, die schon seit 40 Jahren nichts mehr werden wollen, sondern einfach immer nur sich irgendwo hin befördern lassen, die also sich nie mit ihrem eigenen Lebenslauf mal explizit befassen mussten. Die können das natürlich nicht verstehen. Und ich habe mir dann so gedacht, alle jungen Menschen, die in der Wissenschaft arbeiten in Deutschland, hören diese Diskussion zu Annalena Baerbocks Lebenslauf und denken, ja so schreibt man halt den Lebenslauf. Ist doch total normal. Wo ist denn das Problem? Natürlich waren wir gleich UNHCR Mitglied und haben die Führung beraten, obwohl wir da mal kurz Geld hingespendet haben. Also in der Ansicht ist das eine ganz interessante... Also da müsste man eigentlich mal so erheben, wer sieht hier eigentlich wie Problembewusstsein? Und da nutzt die CDU so dieses rentenrepublikanische, dass sie einfach sagt, ja Lebensläufe, da darf man doch nicht so lügen usw. Und ich glaube, sehr viele jungen Menschen denken sich so, ja so schreibe ich auch meinen Lebenslauf, so schreibt man halt seinen Lebenslauf.
Man muss sich ja nur mal bei Dissertationen ansehen, diese Deintes Worte, wer dort alles so erwähnt wird. Und dann bedankt man sich immer bei sehr berühmten Namen für den inspirationsreichen Austausch und all das. Und das bedeutet dann, dass die irgendwo den berühmten Professor von Harvard mal auf einer Konferenz gesehen haben, auf dem Gang so in zwei Worte gesprochen und gesagt, ja lesen sie auch nochmal bei dem nach, der hat da auch glaube ich was zu ihrem Thema. Und dann bedankt man sich nochmal, um zu suggerieren, ich gehöre zum erlaubten Kreis. Also das wäre jetzt, wenn ich jetzt ein Buch schreibe und dann nochmal reinschreibe, ich danke auch besonders Lavoj Zizek für die vielen Anregungen, weil ich ihn irgendwo mal bei einer Lesung gesehen habe, da hat er mir ein Buch signiert. Und so funktioniert das natürlich heute. Und das ist so verrückt, dass das nicht gesehen wird. Und es ist so tragisch, wenn man einfach sieht, wer dann abwandert. Und ich hab das ja auch nochmal ohne jetzt interne Auszüplaudern erlebt, was das dann bedeutet, auch für Frauen, die den Wunsch haben, Kinder zu bekommen, was das dann für die bedeutet. Und ich hab mich ja hier in einem Feld herumgetrieben, also Kunstgeschichte, Literaturwissenschaften und so, in dem es ja noch relativ viele Frauen gibt. Und habe ja auch mit vielen es zu tun gehabt, die auf Genderstar, dies und so weiter spezialisiert waren. Und dann war aber auch so neben den Konferenzen und so zu hören, ja, also wenn die jetzt schwanger wird, also dann sieht das aber auch schlecht mit der Karriere aus. Gesagt von Professorinnen dann.
Ja, und das ist so irre, denn im Spitzensport klar, da ist das so, weil da braucht man seinen Körper und so weiter. Aber in der Wissenschaft ist es noch mal strenger. Tennis kannst du dir die 18 Monate wirklich frei nehmen, wenn du danach wieder entsprechend einsteigst und dann dadurch nicht über Altersgrenzen, also es fehlen dir halt einfach 18 Monate. Aber es heißt nicht, dass du nicht anknüpfen kannst. In der Wissenschaft ist dann einfach Schluss, wenn du da zwei Jahre nicht dabei warst in dem Projekt.
Ein Spitzensport, auch wirklich jetzt bei einer ganz, ganz kleinen Gruppe. Ich würde auch sagen, dass jetzt Opernsängerinnen erzählen das ja auch. Also es gibt natürlich Opernsängerinnen mit Kindern, aber wenn man jetzt, man wird nicht Opernsängerin und hat vier, fünf Kinder, das wird nicht möglich sein, einfach stimmlich nicht möglich sein, ein sehr sensibles Organ und so. Das ist aber auch etwas, worauf man sich dann sehr, sehr bewusst anscheinend, das betrifft eine sehr kleine Gruppe und nicht alle Menschen wollen Kinder haben. Aber wir haben es ja hier mit einem ganz breiten Spektrum in der Gesellschaft zu tun. Also es sind ja jetzt nicht ein paar Ausnahmeerscheinungen, wo man sagt, gut, die haben sich halt für einen besonderen Lebenslauf entschieden. Und das ist so verrückt. Aber eigentlich hat sich nicht viel verändert, denn ich musste dann an eine Rede denken von Max Weber. Max Weber hat hier eine sehr berühmte Rede gehalten, die heißt Wissenschaft als Beruf. Und da geht er auch so ein bisschen seinem eigenen Werdegang nach und beschreibt die Probleme. Und er macht hier eines ganz deutlich, nämlich das Prinzip Zufall, das schon damals, also vor 100 Jahren, eine wichtige Rolle spielte. Und da hat sich heute wenig dran geändert, wie wir jetzt mal hören. Unser deutsches Universitätsleben amerikanisiert sich wie unser Leben überhaupt. Ich möchte das hier nicht weiter ausführen. Geblieben aber und wesentlich gesteigert ist ein der Universitätslaufbahn eigenes Moment. Ob es einem solchen Privatdozenten vollends einem Assistenten jemals gelingt, in die Stelle eines vollen Ordinarius und gar eines Institutsvorstandes einzurücken, ist eine Angelegenheit, die einfach hasard ist. Gewiss nicht nur der Zufall herrscht, aber er herrscht doch in ungewöhnlich hohem Grade. Ich kenne kaum eine Laufbahn auf Erden, wo er eine solche Rolle spielt. Ich darf das umso mehr sagen, als ich Persönliches einigen absoluten Zufälligkeiten zu verdanken habe, dass ich seinerzeit in sehr jungen Jahren in eine ordentliche Professur eines Faches berufen wurde, in welchem damals Altersgenossen unzweifelhaft mehr als ich geleistet hatten. Und ich bilde mir allerdings ein, aufgrund dieser Erfahrung ein geschärftes Auge für das unverdiente Schicksal der vielen zu haben, bei denen der Zufall gerade umgekehrt gespielt hat, und noch spielt, und die trotz aller Tüchtigkeit innerhalb dieses Ausleseapparates nicht an die Stelle gelangen, die ihnen gebühren würde.
Ja, aber da wünscht man sich dann immer die Sensibilisierung von damals nochmal auf heute sozusagen, wenn man damals schon so sensibilisiert war, dass sich das heute nochmal anzuschauen.
Hier sagt der vielleicht bedeutendste Soziologe, da waren Zufälle mit dem Spiel, dass ich jetzt Max Weber bin. Hätte sein können, dass das schief geht, dann wären diese Werke nie erschienen.
Ja, am Ende ist das auch eine Männerklasse, bei der nochmal entscheidend ist, mit wem sie verheiratet waren und so weiter. Und wer sich dann um die noch nicht publizierten, aber schon irgendwo den Schreibtischen liegenden Sachen dann nochmal kümmert und so, haben wir dann mit Max Weber Doppelglück gehabt. Gut, ich hab mir auch Gedanken gemacht zu diesem Hanna-Komplex und hab bei YouTube gesucht, was wird denn gerade dazu diskutiert. Und da bin ich auf eine Podiumsdiskussion gekommen, die ich kurz angeklickt hab. Da hab ich gesehen, da sitzen in der ersten Reihe so drei Leute und hören sich das an. Und hab ich gedacht, ja, das ist so Corona-Maßnahme, keine Ahnung. Lad ich mir mal runter, hör ich mir an, fertig. Und dann plötzlich nach anderthalb Stunden sagt die Moderatorin, ja, aber das ist ja dann auch erst nächstes Jahr 2016 so angeplant, wo ich gedacht hab, hat mir gerade YouTube beim Thema, wie diskutieren eigentlich die Verantwortlichen, Unirektoren, Politiker und so weiter, haben die mir gerade auf Seite eins eine sechs Jahre alte Veranstaltung vorgeschlagen, weil es nichts Aktuelles gibt. Stellt sich raus, ja, es gibt nichts Aktuelles. Wir müssen jetzt, und deswegen nur zwei Clips, aber die Pointen haben mir dann doch ganz gut gefallen. Zum einen dieses Argument von Jens Südekum, es geht hier nicht darum, Verstopfungen in der Uni oder sowas aufzuhalten, denn man kann sehr gut auch bei festangestellten Kriterien einführen, nach denen es heißt, also drei Jahre lang nichts publiziert, und die Studenten sind auch unzufrieden, eignet sich nicht für die Wissenschaft, da kommt man auch aus einer unbefristeten Stelle einfach mal raus. Also man kann durchaus Kriterien, das ist ja völlig normal, dass man da Kriterien einführt und dann irgendwas, wie sich Wartmahnung oder sowas arbeitet, und dann diese Verstopfung daher wird, ohne dass man alle flächendeckend, weil es schwarze Schafe gibt, in so eine Haltlosigkeit, biografische Haltlosigkeit, da reinstürzt, zwei Jahrzehnte. Es sind die Gelder, die die Länder nicht ausgeben wollen, denn die Unis müssen von den Ländern bezahlt werden. Also als Professor wird man vom Land angestellt, nicht von der Uni. Und daher laufen da sozusagen Personalkosten in so eine Bilanz ein, wo die Ministerpräsidenten schon mal sagen, also ich hab ja noch andere Posten. Und jetzt hören wir Ulrich Rüdiger, der war damals, 2015, bei dieser Diskussion Rektor in Konstanz. Konstanz, eine Exzellenzuni. Heute ist er in Aachen an selber Stelle. Und er beschreibt hier mal, was könnte man tun um junge Frauen, auch dann, wenn sie super exzellent sind, aber noch Reste an Lebensgestaltungswille übrig ist, beispielsweise in Kinderwunsch. Was könnte man tun, um eben nicht nur diejenigen, die völlig aus Verlegenheit sich auf so Posten bewerben, sondern die sagen, die könnten auch als junge Juristen zum Beispiel ist das Einstiegsgehalt in Deutschland jetzt 100.000 Euro, also auf der privaten Seite, wenn in den Kanzleien angestellt wird. Da kann ja eine Uni gar nicht mithalten. Da kann auch der Staat als, wir bräuchten nicht eigentlich, als Richter und so nicht mithalten. Das kostet also Geld, wenn man da mithalten wollte. Und der Ulrich Rüdiger beschreibt hier mal seinen Versuch, exzellente Leute nach Konstanz zu holen, wie er dann die Gelder verteilen musste, also wo so die großen Posten auflaufen. Und das ist eine Veranstaltung der Körberstiftung 2015 gewesen.
Wenn wir Berufungsverhandlungen führen, dann ist, wenn wir das Gehalt verhandeln, also die Zusage für einen Krippenplatz teurer, als das, was ich an Gehalt bieten kann. Da muss man wirklich auch vorher mal investieren in so ein Kinderhaus. Und das rentiert sich dann erst Jahre später. Aber das Zukunftskolleg, das ist bei uns das Zentrum für den wissenschaftlichen Nachwuchs, für die, die in der Postdoc-Phase 2 sind. Wenn wir da sieben Stellen ausschreiben, die fünf Jahre Laufzeit haben, bewerben sich mittlerweile 350 junge Leute aus 50 Nationen.
So, also totale Schwämme an Bewerbern. Und der Vorzug ist, er kann den Leuten sagen, ihr könnt ja auch mit Kindern arbeiten. Vielleicht sind auch gerade in der Sozialwissenschaft Menschen, die so ein bisschen verankert sind in der Gesellschaft, die auch mal Kontakt zu anderen Eltern oder sowas haben und nicht nur an der Uni rumhängen. Vielleicht bringen die auch einen gewissen Wert mit sich. Und dann hat er festgestellt, naja, dann können wir die nicht einfach in die normalen Unis geben, weil die machen dann irgendwann 17 Uhr zu. Wir brauchen ja dann doch mal vielleicht so eine, keine Ahnung, Uni. Also hat die Uni eine eigene Kita aufgemacht. Und dann hat der Ulrich Rüdiger festgestellt, obacke, das kostet ja insgesamt mehr als die Professur, das Kind zu betreuen. Also das Kind, das eigentlich geht teurer in die ganzen Bilanzen ein als die Professur. Also kein Wunder, dass man da rechts und links alles weggespart hat, weil es wegzusparen ging, um da irgendwie zumindest das Personal auf halber Stelle oder so zu haben. Also wir müssten, wenn wir jetzt rechnen, so eine TV-Dingsta-Bums-13-Bla-Bla-Stelle, die dann zur Hälfte irgendwie, keine Ahnung, mit 2000 Euro so abgerechnet wird. Eigentlich müssten wir da Faktor 5 drauflegen oder so pro Nase, um hier mal wirklich auf Augenhöhe mit und dann amerikanischen und vor allem chinesischen Forschungsanliegen zu sein. Also in der Hinsicht ist das wirklich crazy, solche Kalkulationen. Als zweites hören wir Florian Leitner. Der war damals 2015, ja was war er denn? Nachwuchsforscher, ich glaube, auf dem Weg zur Promotion. Er beschreibt hier mal das System Universität.
Die Struktur ist ein bisschen wie die bei Drogengangs. Es gibt diese berühmte Studie von Steven Levitt und Sudia Vekatis, die vor 15 Jahren die Gehaltsstruktur und die Karrierewege in der Drogengang in Chicago untersucht haben. Sie haben darauf gekommen, dass es in diesen Drogengangs einen engen Kreis von sehr gut verdienenden, abgesicherten Drogenhändlern gibt. Während der größte Teil unter extrem prekären Arbeitsverhältnissen arbeitet und extrem wenig verdient, also weit unter Mindestlohn oder so. Das ganze System basiert darauf, dass die Großzahl der Leute, die an der Peripherie sind, hoffen, irgendwann ins Zentrum vorzustoßen. Ganz ähnlich ist die Struktur bei Universitätskarrieren, gerade in den Geisteswissenschaften, wo die Möglichkeit, ähnliche Tätigkeiten außerhalb der Universität auszuführen, sehr beschränkt ist. Ich habe mir das nicht selber ausgedacht mit dem Vergleich von Drogengangs und Universitäten. Vor zwei Jahren erschien von einem Ökonom des King's College in London dazu eine Untersuchung, der das mit Zahlen sowohl aus Deutschland, England und den USA gemacht hat. Und eben auch sehr ähnliche Zahlen, wie bei dieser Drogengang gekommen ist.
Dieses Argument klingt natürlich ein bisschen frech so vorgetragen, aber das kann man ja unendlich ausbauen. Denn in den Drogennetzwerken ist es ja tatsächlich so, dass die jungen Menschen, die da einsteigen, für eine Koryphäe arbeiten, von der sie wissen, die funktioniert ja auch als Schutzheiliger für mich. Also wenn ich hier auftrete auf der Straße und ich sage, ich arbeite für so und so, dann wird man von der anderen Gang schon mal nicht weggeknallt, weil die dann gleich wissen, ne, hier greifen so Angriffspakte. Also dann aktivieren wir sozusagen das ganze Netzwerk und schießen nicht nur einen solchen Typen weg. Und das ist in den Unis natürlich auch so, nur um es ein bisschen perfider noch zu machen, die Professoren, für die man dann stolz ist zu arbeiten mit einer halben Stelle, die schützen einen ja gar nicht. Sondern es ist ja nur die wissenschaftliche Reputation, an die man sich so ein bisschen dran hängt. Dann hat er drei Jahre bei so und so gearbeitet, ne. Nur ja, drei Jahre halt. Dann ist die Zeit vorbei.
Und das ist dann auch jemand, der 200 Promovierende betreut.
Genau, das kommt dann auch dazu. Ich war einer von 60 Promovierenden von Professor so und so. Also in der Ansicht ist das alles, es ist wirklich alles total kaputt in Deutschland. Und man kann nur auf eine neue Regierung hoffen, aber man sollte da auch nicht hoffen. Denn es ist hier einfach ausweglos, glaube ich.
Damit bringst du schon die Überleitung. Denn ich habe mich nochmal gefragt, was ist das eigentlich? Ich habe dich ja im Presseclub auch erlebt. Du hast ja die Zitate da noch zum Teil vorgelesen, auch aus dem Wahlprogramm. Was ist das eigentlich, was die Leute dazu bringt, die CDU zu wählen? Oder was hat sie dazu gebracht, dass wir jetzt seit 16 Jahren in dieser Weise regiert werden? Das können wir auch mal konstatieren. 16 Jahre, das heißt also, ich kenne fast gar nichts anderes. Ich kann mich dann natürlich noch an Gerhard Schröder Jahre ein bisschen erinnern, aber das war es auch eigentlich. Und da frage ich mich schon, was ist das? Wie kann man das charakterisieren? Wie kann man es irgendwie fassen? Und ich würde jetzt gerne zum Einstieg einen Clip hören zum Thema die Masken von Van Laak für Laschet, die seinen Sohn in die Wege geleitet hat. Der Clip ist also schon etwas älter. Das kam ja im Dezember dann raus, dass man diese ganzen unbrauchbaren Masken bestellt hat, dass man Van Laak um viele Millionen reicher gemacht hat. Und es sind jetzt zwei harte Minuten, die vor uns liegen. Aber wir sollten sie uns einmal gönnen, um vielleicht dieses System Laschet schon mal ein bisschen zu begreifen.
Der Vorwurf der SPD ist wirklich schäbig. Außerhalb Nordrhein-Westfalens kennt man vielleicht nicht den Zustand der nordrhein-westfälischen SPD. Der gehört diffamieren immer zum Stilmittel. Aber die neue Qualität jetzt ist, dass es über meine Person hinausgeht, dass es in meine Familie hineingeht, ohne jede Rücksichtnahme. Und ich weise das Entschieden zurück.
Was hier schon mal gemacht wird, ist das konservative Argument. Die böse SPD kommt damit haltlosen Vorwürfen. Und die gehen jetzt nicht mal nur an mich, sondern die betreffen auch meine Familie. Und das konservative Weltbild ist natürlich eines, das die Familie angeblich schützen will. Und jetzt wird doch jeder Zuschauer nachvollziehen, denn sie haben doch auch alle Familien. Sie wollen doch auch nicht, dass die SPD ihre Kinder so attackiert, jetzt sehen sie mal, wie schlimm es mir ergeht. Ich bin das Opfer. Aber sie könnten es auch sein, wenn die SPD zu mächtig wird.
Wir wissen, was da im März war. Jens Spahn hat es ja gerade gesagt. Die erste Welle hatte uns erfasst. Die Infektionszahlen gingen rasant hoch und keiner wusste, wie geht denn diese Sache aus. Wir hatten nicht genügend medizinische Masken. Wir hatten nicht genügend Schutzkittel. Wir hatten keine OP-Handschuhe. Uns haben Ärzte angerufen, Pfleger angerufen, die erzählt haben, zum Teil haben wir die Masken mehrere Tage getragen, weil...
Wer glaubt jetzt, dass irgendein Pfleger mit Laschet telefoniert hat? Wie kann man überhaupt als Pfleger Laschet erreichen? Riecht man dann im Ministerium an und sagt, ich bin Pfleger im Elisabeth-Krankenhaus, ich würde gerne mit Herrn Laschet sprechen, es gibt hier ein Problem mit Masken?
Eigentlich habe ich alle Hände voll zu tun, aber ich versuche jetzt noch mal den Ministerpräsidenten anzurufen.
Das ist so, wie AKK immer gerne sagte, wir haben viele, viele Menschen geschrieben.
Ja, das ist einfach, das ist bürgernahe Politik...
.medizinischen Masken verfügbar waren, und wir waren damals auf der Suche nach seriösen Anbietern, möglichst aus Deutschland, möglichst aus Nordrhein-Westfalen. Wir haben jeden gefragt, den wir kennen. Nicht nur ich, alle die Verantwortung getragen haben in dieser Zeit. Wir haben uns die Hände wundtelefoniert, gefragt, gedrängt, gebettelt. Könnt ihr eure Produktion umstellen? Und natürlich habe ich auch meinen Sohn gefragt, der sich in der Textilindustrie auskennt. Und irgendwann sagt er, du, da ist Van Laag, die könnten hier helfen. Ich sage, gib mir die Kontakte, ich rufe den an. Ich habe den Herrn Vorstandsvorsitzenden an einem Sonntagabend angerufen. Ich habe gesagt, können Sie liefern? Und dann hat er gesagt, ja, wir haben da was. Wir können da unsere Produktion umstellen. Und mein Sohn hat das gemacht, was jeder in dieser Situation gemacht hätte. Helfen ohne jeden Lohn, ohne jeden Vorteil, ohne jeden Cent, einfach einen Kontakt herzustellen, den ich aufgegriffen habe, wie Hunderte andere auch in diesen verzweifelten Tagen. Werde es nicht akzeptieren, dass solches Engagement, was viele Menschen damals gezeigt haben und was auch mein Sohn bewegt hat, dass das jetzt in den Dreck gezogen wird.
Der Sohn hilft seinem Vater. Es ist ein unglaublicher Clip. Aber ich denke, dass man hier schon sich den entsprechenden Film vorstellen kann. Es wird ja auch alles so geschildert. Man sieht den Laschet wieder am Telefon, sitzt wahrscheinlich noch mit Wellenscheibe, sich die Finger wundtelefoniert und dann versucht, irgendwelche Leute zu erreichen. Dann kommt der Sohn, sagt, hier Papa, die haben auch so schöne Hemden, die können vielleicht auch Pasken machen. Also das ist was, was man auch im ZDF noch mal um 20.15 Uhr verballern kann mit Christina Neubauer in der Hauptrolle.
Also wir reden hier über die Textilbranche. Von der wir wissen, die Hälfte eines Textils, das heute in Deutschland verkauft wird, geht für Marketing drauf. Da sind Management-Ebenen und Marketing-Abteilungen auf Augenhöhe, weil die einen den anderen sagen können, wo es ja langgeht, wo was zu kaufen ist. Da sind Management-Ebenen und Marketing-Abteilungen auf Augenhöhe, weil die einen den anderen sagen können, wo es ja langgeht, wo was zu kaufen ist. Da muss niemand anrufen und sagen, wir haben jetzt, vielleicht habt ihr es nicht mitbekommen, so einen neuen Markt entdeckt. Nämlich Schutzkleidung. Ich weiß nicht, wann sie das letzte Mal nach hingeguckt haben, aber vielleicht haben sie es nicht gemerkt. Also wir sind in einer Pandemie. Selbst Milita, die, also die machen Teefilter, Kaffeefilter. Die halt von der Form her irgendwie, und selbst die haben sich gedacht, wir haben doch Anlagen für die, wir müssen das Material austauschen und dann haben wir Masken. Selbst die sind von alleine drauf gekommen, dass man aus einer völlig, das ist ja völlig abwegig eigentlich, einen Teefilter und so weiter, einen Kaffeefilter. Und jedes Textilunternehmen hat sich doch angeschaut, wie sind hier die Möglichkeiten, wie können wir helfen, und die wussten dann auch, wo sie anrufen müssen. Da muss doch nicht der Joe vom Laschet, der Sohn, anrufen. Und ich hatte doch letztens diese Influencer-Kampagne für Van Laag, also die machen auch was mit Stoff. Völlig, also das ist so richtig Märchen erzählen. Und tausendmal schlimmer als die Märchen, die in Lebensläufen drinstehen.
Ganz genau. Und wir switchen jetzt, gehen jetzt in die Gegenwart. Die Union hat ihr Programm vorgestellt, Söder und Laschet gemeinsam. Und jetzt geht es weiter mit den Märchen, nämlich mit den Grünen. Da sagt jetzt Söder Folgendes bei dieser Pressekonferenz.
Grüne haben viele Ideen, aber überhaupt keine Erfahrung. In einer Zeit der Veränderung, des Epochenwechsels, wie du es angesprochen hast, braucht es neben guten Ideen auch Erfahrung. Und zwar solide, seriöse Regierungserfahrung.
Das heißt übersetzt, die können nicht solche idiotischen Geschichten erzählen und die Leute so an der Nase herumführen. Das können die Grünen nicht, deswegen sind die nicht geeignet. Wir haben das viel besser drauf.
Wahlkampf ist vor allem eine Sache des Mutes. Das, was alle wollen und was du nicht liefern kannst, trotzdem zu versprechen. Also so richtig das Vorzeichen umzudrehen. Dass die Partei, und das haben wir ja gesehen, wie das bei Sebastian Kurz in Österreich so funktioniert, dass die Partei, die durchgehend regiert, die auch programmatisch am mutlosesten erscheint, wie wir es ja gerade wieder sehen, in solchen Statements dann immer das Versprechen der großen Wende macht. Mit uns der Wandel und so weiter. Das ist so perfide. Und da fehlt es mir einfach auch an Mut, anderer Wahlkämpfer, also sich wirklich mal hinzustellen und zu sagen, das ist eine Lüge, sie funktioniert so und so. Dann wirklich mal ins Eins-zu-Ein-Zuge gehen, das zu erklären.
Da könnte man doch auch mal Erklärvideos machen. Das ist ja was, was gut läuft bei Instagram, bei YouTube. Da könnte man einen richtig guten digitalen Wahlkampf auch machen. Samira El-Borsil hat das ja in ihrer Kolumne nochmal ganz richtig auf den Punkt gebracht, dass die Grünen gar nicht mal beim Wahlkampf in den Kampfmodus übergehen. Und ich frage mich auch, es liegt doch alles da. Also man muss ja nur nachgreifen. Es ist ja für Memes und alles gesorgt. Also die CDU liefert eigentlich die ganze Zeit. Man greift es nicht auf, dann sucht die Union sich wieder irgendwas aus und sorgt dafür, dass das im Diskurs ganz oben steht, dass man dann die ganze Zeit über Lebensläufe oder was weiß ich redet.
Ja, ich habe da auch einen ganz konkreten Tipp an alle Wahlkäpfer, die uns hier zuhören. Wir Deutsche sind ja jetzt wirklich drauf geeicht, uns Grafen anzugucken. Infektionsinzidenz, alles Mögliche. Wir sehen alles an irgendwelchen Grafenentwicklungen. Und das ist ja nur wirklich die einfachste Form der Visualisierung. Und ich wünsche mir diese Art der Visualisierung für die letzten 16 Jahre Angela Merkel. Zahl der Millionäre in Deutschland, von 600.000 auf 1, 2 Millionen, verdoppelt. Also jeder 80. Deutsche ist Millionär. Kinder in Armut, weniger als eine Million nach Schröder. Jetzt sind wir hier im 20% Bereich. Jedes fünfte Kind ist arm in manchen Stadtteilen in Berlin. 75% der Kinder fallen unter die Armutsgrenze. Das kann man doch alles in wunderbaren, ganz gleichmäßigen Grafen zeigen. Aber wenn die CSU, CDU Wandel verspricht, dann kann man, und das ist ja dann die Modellierung, auch daran sind wir jetzt gewöhnt, sich fragen, was bedeutet das eigentlich? Kinderarmut halbieren. Joe Biden ist jetzt angetreten in Amerika. Ich halbiere die Kinderarmut. Wenn in Deutschland jemand so ein Versprechen macht, oder Söder kommt mit dem großen Wandel und so, reinzeichnen in die Grafen, mit gestrichelter Linie fortsetzen und dann gleich das Preisschild unten dran schreiben und dann das Publikum fragen, traut dir das der CDU zu, dass sie für diesen Wandel jetzt wirklich steht? Also ich glaube, da gibt es noch unglaublich viele Möglichkeiten, ordentlichen Wahlkampf zu machen, aber von dem sehen wir bislang nichts.
Ja, stattdessen machen dann die Grünen irgendwelche Sachen, wo man schon weiß, das wird doch nur gemacht, damit sie auf Twitter nachher durch die Mühle gedreht werden kann. Dann sind die in so einem Elektro-Lasten-Rad, wird dann eine ganze Familie kutschiert und Mutti sitzt vorne drin. Und dann denkt man natürlich, das ist jetzt ein 50er-Jahre-Heimatfilm. Und was kostet eigentlich dieses Lastenrad? Das kostet dann fast so viel wie einen Kleinwagen wohl. Also das ist einfach Dinge, das weiß man doch. Das hat man doch jetzt einmal mal durchgespielt. Da muss man noch ein bisschen professioneller rangehen. Und ich verstehe das allerdings auch bei Baerbock nicht. Also sie ist jetzt keine begnadete Rednerin. Das ist aber ein Schicksal, das sie mit der Kanzlerin teilt. Da muss man aber sich doch mal ein bisschen da von manchen Dingen befreien und dann nicht in dieser Verbissenheit das machen. Ich meine, unter uns, das ist, glaube ich, kein Geheimnis, dass ich es für strategisch klüge gehalten hätte, dass man Habeck aufstellt. Aber nun ist es so, wie es ist. Dennoch ist ja Habeck nach wie vor auch präsent und kann ja auch Wahlkampf weiterhin für die Grünen mitmachen. Aber man müsste halt mal irgendwie aus dem Puschen kommen und auch Linke und SPD, sofern sie sich jetzt nicht ganz unter die Knote der CDU stellt, was ja momentan so aussieht, da man ja nochmal alles durchgewunken hat, was die CDU wollte im Bundestag. Also es ist alles sehr traurig. Und deshalb wundert es dann nicht, wenn wir eigentlich diesen CDU-Wahlkampf nur noch so in so einem Fernsehmodus rezipieren müssen. Du hast ja einen Fernsehpodcast, beschäftigst dich aber da jetzt nicht mit den Tele-Novelas und den Heimatfilmen. Aber eigentlich geht das nur in so einem Modus, wie verstehen die beiden sich dann eigentlich? Und da sagt dann auch Söder was zu?
Sie können sich darauf verlassen. Das sage ich auch an alle Menschen, die der Union Vertrauen schenken wollen, dass Armin Laschet und ich menschlich eine sehr solide und stabile Basis haben.
Das freut uns sehr. Und dann wird Laschet auch nochmal gefragt, was können wir dann noch erwarten jetzt so in den nächsten Monaten?
Werden Sie noch ein Kompetensteam vorstellen? Wenn ja, wann ist damit zu rechnen?
Und wenn nein, werden einzelne Personen noch stärker hervorgehoben.
Lassen Sie sich überraschen. Es wird noch in den nächsten 98 Tagen schöne, anreichende Ideen kommen.
Ja, vielleicht kommt auch nochmal die Uschi Klaas und macht was mit denen zusammen, mit der Sophia Tomalla. Ist er jetzt schon aufgetreten? Schöne Überraschungen.
Also in England gibt es ja die politische Kultur des Schattenkabinetts. Das kennen wir hier in Deutschland ja eigentlich auch von früher, dass die Labour immer bereit steht. Wenn die Regierung Johnson morgen ausfallen würde, könnte Labour mit denen und denen, und das kennt dann auch jeder, das Personal. Und in Deutschland lassen sich ja die Grünen auch sehr einlullen davon. Lanz hat das ja mal schön beschrieben, dass bei der SPD nur noch die Ich-AG antritt. Aber wen sollte auch Scholz noch neben sich stellen? Hubertus Heil. Und ansonsten ist ja auch niemand da, der überhaupt mal bekannt wäre. Und da hat man eben gehört, wenn das Schicksal der Welt daran hängt, dass sich Laschet und Söder gut verstehen, das kennen wir aus der guten Gesellschaft der Vormoder. Krieg bricht aus, wenn Konflikte beim T auftreten zwischen den beiden. Und da hängen wir wieder dran. Wenn es bei denen gut läuft, dann ist Ruhe. Und da würde ich auch sagen, sollten die Grünen, haben ja schon immer so gute Ideen wie keine Bilder auf Wahlplakate und so, sondern nur Sprüche, aber das ganze Prinzip bei der Bundestagswahl, da treten Ideen gegeneinander an, Teams, da geht es um Mannschaftssport usw. Deswegen würde ich auch sagen, sie haben sich halt schon einlullen lassen mit dieser Kanzlerkandidatur. Warum sind sie nicht dabei geblieben zu sagen, wir machen eine Spitzenkandidatur? Das heißt aber nur, wir haben halt Platz 1 bis 10 durchnummeriert, aber trotzdem die ganze Mannschaft steht auf dem Platz. Ich finde, Habeck schlägt sich ganz gut, nimmt die ganzen Termine wahr, bespielt den ganzen Parteitag usw. Aber das müssen die Grünen glaube ich auch stärker noch machen, dass man da einfach sieht, hier geht es um ein bisschen mehr als nur die Kanzlerfrage. Wir wählen ja auch keinen Kanzler in Deutschland.
Ne, und wir können ja mal festhalten, dass wir hier im Podcast eigentlich immer wieder über den Staatskapitalismus reden. So kann man das Marxistisch bezeichnen, als wenn wir nach China blicken, wenn wir jetzt in die USA blicken. Also man will jetzt doch wieder, dass der Staat den Kapitalismus entsprechend lenkt, reguliert und auf Vordermann bringt. Und das ist aber Laschets Sache nicht, wie wir jetzt nochmal hören. Er geht auch hier wieder so in den Modus. Auch ich erzähle euch mal was Lustiges, was ihr vielleicht auch bei Prisant am Abend im ZDF nochmal hören könnt.
Ein Staat, der noch mehr regulieren will, wird scheitern. Das Modernisierungsjahrzehnt wird nur gelingen, wenn wir auch unseren Staat modernisieren. Ich habe letztlich in der Süddeutschen Zeitung gelesen, hier in Berlin Marzahn hat man vor 25 Jahren die Idee gehabt, eine Ampel zu errichten. Und die wird in wenigen Wochen eingeweiht. 25 Jahre für eine Ampel. In der Zeit haben Amazon, Google, Tesla sich zu Tech-Giganten entwickelt. Und wir spielen Behörden-Ping-Pong.
Das ist so dumm, dieser Vergleich.
Aber so steht es im CDU-Wahlprogramm. Die Wirtschaft soll entfesselt werden, beispielsweise über neue Höchststeuersätze, die dann noch nicht überschritten werden sollen. Und das ist auch noch Klimaschutzbedarf. Ja, aber da kann man ja die Wirtschaft mit, Zitat, marktwirtschaftlichen Mitteln, Zitat, unterstützen.
Ich wollte ja das irgendwie vermessen. Was findet da eigentlich statt? Und dann habe ich gedacht, man muss, glaube ich, doch nochmal den Fernseher anmachen. Also ich muss es anders einführen. Ich habe ja eine Zeitlang in einer WG mit zwei Frauen zusammen gewohnt. Das war sehr schön in Trier. Und da gab es auch häufig die Situation, dass man dann abends gegen 19 Uhr, 19.30 Uhr vor dem Fernseher saß, hat ein bisschen zu Abend gegessen, hat sich ein bisschen unterhalten und wollte aber auch irgendwas gucken. Und so war es dann meist, dass die Damen das perfekte Dinner auf Vox sehen wollten, das ja immer noch läuft und wahrscheinlich nie enden wird. Ich sagte auch letztlich mal...
Du hast ja auch nicht auf zu essen.
Ja, ich sagte auch kürzlich mal zu meinem Vater, der das auch guckt und zu meiner Mutter. Ich bin gespannt, wer länger lebt, das perfekte Dinner oder ihr. Also das muss man glaube ich in dieser Trastik mal sagen, weil es so verrückt ist, dass die Leute dort alle abendlich Platz nehmen und sich das ansehen. Und das Schöne, was ich dann bei dieser Sache fand, war, dass ich dort saß und wollte natürlich die Dreisatzkulturzeit sehen, die zeitgleich läuft. Und dann war es aber oft so, dass ich mich zwar durchsetzen konnte, wenn aber dann irgendein langweiliger Beitrag kam, also irgendeine Yoga-Performance-Gruppe kam, was häufig ist, was sehr häufig ist, dann war das immer, ja, aber das interessiert dich doch wirklich nicht. Lass uns mal umschalten. Wir wollen noch wissen, wie es ausgeht. Also wer die acht Punkte für das Dinner bekommt oder die neun Punkte. Und das ist ja so eine Sache, bei der man sagen muss, gut, man vergisst es ja eh wieder. Das kann jetzt niemand sagen. Wer hat eigentlich in dieser ersten Maiwoche das perfekte Dinner gewonnen? Also jeder, der das guckt, könnte das nicht beantworten. Aber es flutscht alles so durch. Nun können wir hier nicht so gut Privatfernsehen vorspielen. Aber es gibt eigentlich eine Sendung, die noch viel grotesker ist. Denn perfektes Dinner bringt ja mehreres zusammen. Man hat so einen Challenge-Charakter. Man sieht Leuten zu, wie sie was anrichten, was kochen. Das ist immer gern gesehen. Und dann hat man noch als dritte Komponente so ein bisschen den Blick durchs Schlüsselloch. Wie lebt der oder die dann? Ach Gott, da sieht es aber aus oder warum ist der eigentlich so tätowiert? Und solche Fragen werden sicher dann die ganze Zeit gestellt.
Da will ich aber kurz, uns ist ja gute Sprache entscheidend. Harald Schmidt hat mal gesagt, dass seine Mutter immer meinte, die Weihnachtsgans wird natürlich nicht hergerichtet oder angerichtet, sondern hingerichtet.
Sehr gut, ja. Schlachtungen finden glaube ich ja nicht statt beim perfekten Dinner.
Nein, da geht man noch einkaufen.
Da geht man noch schön einkaufen. Und ich dachte mir, es gibt aber auch eine eigentlich viel verrücktere Sendung, nämlich Bares für Rares. Im ZDF läuft sie nachmittags, manchmal aber auch abends und abends holt sie dann Rekordquoten. Also das kann dann sein, dass dann ein ganz wichtiger Corona-Brennpunkt im November oder Dezember kommt, aber wenn dann Bares für Rares gleichzeitig stattfinden. Und dieser Brennpunkt wird ja eigentlich für das Publikum gemacht, dass Bares für Rares guckt. Dass nochmal jetzt überredet werden muss, die Maske zu tragen oder so. Nee, die Leute gucken dann Bares für Rares mit Horst Lichter. Und ich hab jetzt einfach mal... Der ja eigentlich Koch ist, genau. Aber dann sich auch mit Trödel und so ein Kram ausgehen. Und ich hab mir jetzt sehr viele Sendungen angesehen bei YouTube. Und habe jetzt einfach mal so zwei Episoden rausgeschnitten. Man hat im 8-9-Minuten-Takt immer wieder Leute, die mit irgendwas ankommen, mit einer Vase, mit Schmuck oder sonst irgendwas. Manchmal kommen auch Paare und präsentieren das dann dort und lassen das schätzen. Und das findet wie folgt dann statt.
Und das hat mit Laschet und so zu tun?
Ich will das verbinden. Wir müssen uns das vorstellen. Wir gucken jetzt... Wir sind jetzt Bares für Rares-Fans. Und gucken das so tagtäglich. Haben wir jetzt so Laschet gehört und wir sind ein starkes Team und all das. Und wir müssen auch mal gucken auf die Preise und so. Und jetzt hören wir das jetzt hier. Wir sind jetzt in diesem Modus. Und stellt man sich dann überhaupt noch die großen Fragen, wenn man sich zum Beispiel mit so einer Menage beschäftigt, auf Silber?
Hallo zusammen.
Freue mich sehr. Grüß dich. Ganz kurz ein bisschen zu deiner Person erklärt. Du fängst einfach an, ich weiß ja nichts.
Ich reise sehr, sehr gerne mit meinem Mann und meinem Hund mit dem Wohnmobil. Wir sind sehr viel unterwegs. Also ist wahrscheinlich auch etwas, woraus auch dieses kleine Teil entstanden ist. Oder warum ich das gekauft habe. Ich habe das damals vor ungefähr 40 Jahren in Alexandria gekauft. In einem kleinen Lädchen. In Ägypten? Genau.
Und jetzt nach 40 Jahren hast du die gedacht?
Ja, nach 40 Jahren habe ich meine Kinder gefragt, ob sie dafür ein Plätzchen haben und ob sie das auch benutzen können. Und beide wollten es nicht. Und dann habe ich gesagt, okay, dann versuche ich mal woanders.
Was hat sie da mitgebracht?
Sie bringt so eine Silberminage mit. Was ist eine Minage nochmal?
Ich bin ein bisschen unaufgeklärt.
Das ist so ein bestimmtes Geschirr, in das man dann auch, glaube ich, Senf oder so reinfüllen kann.
Vielleicht ist eine Genie drin.
Ja, vielleicht auch das. Aber sag doch mal als Soziologe, was passiert da eigentlich auf der kommunikativen Ebene? Was machen die da eigentlich?
Wie soll man sagen, das ist ja die geruhsamste Art der Gesprächsgestaltung überhaupt, die Horst Lichter da macht. Wir kennen natürlich auch alle seinen, so Kölner auch den entsprechenden Bart und so. Da passiert nichts Gefährliches. Da spielt auch die Person wieder eine Rolle. Da kommt man noch mal zur Geltung. Da darf man kurz sein Hobby nennen. Nichts weiter Gefährliches. Und dann verständigt man sich über Sachen, bei denen für alle so ein Kribbeln in der Luft liegt, ob das jetzt was ist oder nicht. Kann ja auch Schrott sein.
Ja, da hören wir mal, was der Experte sagt.
Und hier das Glas von Senf, ja, das ist noch ganz gut erhalten, hat ein paar kleine Absplittungen, aber da kann man locker drüber wegsehen. Dafür stimmt der Deckel aber. Ja, der Deckel stimmt. Und hier, lieber Horst, kann man ganz gut erkennen, hier oben diesen kleinen Katzenkopf. Dette Schach. Und dieser kleine Katzenkopf sagt uns was über das Alter ihrer Menage. Dekor ist Jugendstil. Aber diese Menage wurde gefertigt in der Zeit zwischen 1921 und 1931.
Da weiß man das jetzt mal. Aber es ist ja auch vollkommen egal, ob man es weiß oder nicht. Vielleicht ist das jetzt für die Frau noch interessant. Aber wir müssen uns jetzt einfach vorstellen, drei, vier, fünf Millionen Menschen gucken das jetzt.
Es gibt ja noch so eine soziologische Komponente, die fiel mir gerade auf, aus eigenen. Ich kenne ja die Sendung, auch wenn ich sie nicht gucke. Und es fällt ja schon auf, dass da Leute immer hingehen, die manchmal auch so Kunstwerke dabei haben, Sachen, die gemalt gestaltet wurden irgendwie, oder so hier, die so hergestellt wurden. Und es ist ganz interessant, wie in diesen Momenten die ganze Schicksalshaftigkeit der Person, die das mitgebracht hat, davon abhängig ist, ob das jetzt was ist oder nicht. Also die ganze emotionale, der baut sich aus einem emotionalen Stau auf, bis zur Erlösung ist es jetzt was oder nicht. Und es ist ganz interessant, wie man so eine ganze Persönlichkeit einfach transferiert auf so einen Gegenstand. Und die Güte der Person, die da zu sehen ist, ist das Fernsehen, also ihr Unterhaltungswert, hängt davon ab, ob das jetzt was wert ist oder nicht. Weil wenn der jetzt anfängt zu sagen, geil, das hab ich ja lange nicht mehr gesehen, auf sowas wollte ich immer mal wieder sehen. Dann freut sie sich natürlich total über sich. Und man fragt sich so ein bisschen, warum? Das ist wie dieses, ich sitze in einem starken Auto, also bin ich stark. Und da wundern sich eigentlich auch alle, die da ein bisschen drüber nachdenken. Ja, und deswegen bist du jetzt cool oder was? Weil irgendwer in Süddeutschland ein Auto gebaut hat. Deswegen bist du jetzt cool. Aber ja, so funktioniert das in diesen Sendungen ja auch. Also diese Person, die da immer mitkommt, ist immer ganz entscheidend als emotionaler Anker, so für die Zuschauer auch. Weil es wird sozusagen die Güte der ganzen Person transferiert auf dieses komische Menage-Ding.
Dann wollen wir doch mal gucken, was die Menage wert ist.
Wir sind jetzt alle gespannt, was die Frau wert ist.
Also ich hab mir vorgestellt 150, 180 Euro.
Schätzmeister Albert hat das Wort.
Scherzmeister Albert?
Schatzmeister. Schätzmeister, natürlich.
Meine Schätzung ist ein klein wenig höher, weil solche Gebrauchsartikel sind so sehr gesucht. Und die Firma Christofle steht schon für gute Versilberung. Die müsste man ein bisschen auffrischen oder ein bisschen richten wieder. Aber es ist eine gute Qualität, was die gemacht haben in Frankreich. Und deswegen ist mein Schätzpreis 2 bis 300 Euro.
Jetzt würde ich gerne noch wissen, was du von dir bezahlt hast.
Ich habe damals 30, 40 D-Mark bezahlt.
Dann kann ich nur gratulieren, es war eine vernünftige Wertanlage.
Ja, sehr gut.
Der deutsche Sparer hat das gut gemacht. Der hat 30, 40 Euro investiert und jetzt 250 Euro raus. Das hat sich gelohnt.
Vor allem in dieser Zeit, in der wir uns immer fragen, was ist eigentlich der Preis von? Wir hören das nachher bei der Armut noch mal. Wir wissen nicht mal das Elementarste. Nämlich ist unser Verdienst eigentlich viel oder wenig im Vergleich zu ganz Deutschland, Grundgesamtheit und so. Menschen können das nicht richtig einschätzen. Und jetzt haben wir hier plötzlich so eine, was macht es für einen Unterschied? 150, 200, 300 Euro für eine Menage, die seit 40 Jahren auf einem Dachboden steht. Ich meine, klar, sie hat das damals für einen Preis gekauft, nur Dachboden kostet auch Geld und so weiter. Jetzt hat sie das da. Was müsste man alles in eine Gleichung mit einbeziehen, um hier zu preisen zu kommen? Und wir verhökern hier irgendwie NFTs für 70 Millionen, wo man dann einfach sagt, ist jetzt 70 Millionen wert des Every Days von Beeple? Nur findet derjenige, der das gerade besitzt, jemanden, der ihm 70 Millionen Euro dafür zahlt? Natürlich nicht. Der Wert wurde halt einmal festgelegt, aber es gibt doch jetzt gar keinen Markt dafür und die NFTs trocknen jetzt schon schneller wieder aus, als sie reingeboomt sind in unsere mediale Blase irgendwie. In der Ansicht ist das so richtig Nonsensfernsehen.
Ja, und jetzt geht es aber direkt an den Markt. Jetzt wird geguckt, was gibt denn der Markt?
Okay, das Setting muss man kurz beschreiben, weil das war ich auch überrascht. Wir gehen nämlich von einem Raum in den nächsten und treffen direkt auf mögliche Käufer. Das ist neu irgendwie, das gab es früher noch nicht.
Nee, bei Bar, Führer ist es immer. Also da gibt es dann auch eine Riege und da gibt es auch eine Riege, die ist besonders beliebt. Das sind natürlich immer Leute, die dann sehr ausgefallen aussehen. Einer ist ganz klein und einer ist ganz groß. Und wie das dann so gemacht wird, das ist auch wirklich so nach dem Schema, wie man das Bauerntheater eigentlich aufbaut, dann kreiert und jetzt gehen die in den anderen Raum mit diesem Gegenstand, also dann auch nur die Person mit dem Gegenstand, also Horst Lichter geht da nicht mit.
Die muss jetzt ihr Schicksal alleine verteidigen. Genau. Die muss jetzt ihre ganze Person da in Anklang bringen. Okay, wir sind gespannt.
Ich mach weiter mit 150.
Albert Schätzungen lag bei 200 bis 300 Euro.
Ja, das denke ich auch. Das glaube ich ja. Ich bin bei 150, aber trotzdem nicht mehr dabei.
Ich gehe auch nicht mehr drüber.
Weil es Christoffel ist, kann ich nicht dran vorbeigehen und sage 180. Wollen Sie das Geschäft mit dem Wadi machen?
Vielleicht überlegt der eine oder andere noch.
Der Wadi gibt auch noch.
Ich mache schnack 200 und dann haben wir das doch hier.
Komm her, nett, dass dem Lisa noch was eins hat.
Das waren jetzt 40 Sekunden Clip. Wenn ich mir überlege, in dem, was ich mich immer wundere, zum Beispiel, dass zum Beispiel ein ganz aktuelles Beispiel. Das Bundesverfassungsgericht befindet eine Bulgarin hat recht, ihr steht Mindestlohn zu, wenn sie bei einer Familie privat als Pflegerin für die Oma angestellt ist. Plötzlich gilt dieses Urteil für alle. Alle privat in Deutschland in Familien angestellten Ausländerinnen, vor allem aus Osteuropa, Polen, Ungarn, Bulgarien, steht jetzt plötzlich Mindestlohn zu, was für die Familien bedeutet. Statt 1.000 Euro im Monat müssen wir jetzt plötzlich 5.000 mobilisieren. Also ex orbitant mehr. Auch Bereitschaftszeiten zählen da mit rein. Man braucht also noch einen zweiten. Dann kann man ja gleich einen richtigen Pfleger anstellen, der dann nicht nur in Bereitschaft ist, sondern wirklich pflegt in dem Moment usw. Also alles steht auf dem Kopf. Und jetzt kommt die süddeutsche Zeitung und sagt, wir haben recherchiert, es betrifft 700.000 Fälle in Deutschland.
Wahnsinn.
Und dann kommt die Bundesregierung, antwortet auf eine kleine Anfrage, ja, das sind so 100.000 ungefähr. Wir wissen also nicht mal, ob jetzt für 100.000 oder 700.000 oder irgendwo dazwischen Mindestlohn gilt, wo ansonsten auch das Finanzamt immer so ein bisschen, ja gut, da gucken wir nicht so genau hin, denn es ist auch im Sinne der Regierung, dass wir jetzt nicht vier von fünf Pflegefällen nochmal ins Pflegesystem holen, weil dann wird es richtig teuer. So, und all dieser Komplex, den ich jetzt beschrieben habe, ist bei den Tagesthemen in 27 Sekunden verhandelt worden in der Kurzmeldung und wir haben es hier gerade 39 Sekunden.
Und das geht eigentlich noch länger, das war ja von mir geschnitten. Das sind ja sonst zwei, drei Minuten, wie das so geht. Aber du merkst, in welchem Modus sich der Fernsehzuschauer und damit kann man einfach sagen, der Wähler befindet. Denn Fernsehen ist nach wie vor das Medium, das am meisten konsumieren wird, vier Stunden. Da gibt es mal eine Minute mehr oder weniger, inzwischen ist es ja sogar wieder mehr, obwohl erst alle dachten, ne, ne, die wandern ab. Ne, wandern die nicht ab. Und die gehen auch nicht alle zu Netflix. Und das ist nach wie vor das dominante Medium. Und wir haben jetzt also schon mal so ein bisschen gesehen, so wird über Preise, über Wirtschaft nachgedacht. Also ich hab da mal was gekauft, was kriege ich denn jetzt dafür? Und bekomme ich jemand, der mir das für teurer abkauft, als es geschätzt wurde? Und so könnte man doch auch ein schönes Geschäft, was man mag, hat ja am Anfang des Kapitals, ziemlich am Anfang gibt es da so eine Überlegung, wie dann so eigentlich Wirtschaftswachstum und Wert zustande kommt. Was wäre dann, wenn man sich einfach immer gegenseitig die Waren noch teurer verkauft? Dann haben wir noch mehr Wert. Das ist natürlich Unsinn, sagt er dann. Und das ist aber hier genau der Modus, in dem gedacht wird. Und da kommen wir schon so einem Wirtschaftsprogramm der CDU ziemlich nahe. Ich will noch, weil es so schön ist, noch mal jetzt als Beispiel einen Durchlauf machen. Einfach um auch deutlich zu machen, es ist die ewige Wiederkehr, die wir hier erleben. Jetzt geht es um eine Puppe.
Und ich bin der Thorsten. Also wir können gerne beim Duos sein.
Heike, Thorsten und Horst. Da stellt sich natürlich die Frage, welche Gesellschaft soll das abwenden?
Ich wohne in Nettetal in Kaldenkirchen.
Das ist direkt an der holländischen Grenze.
Mhm, kenn ich.
Ich weiß noch, bei Harald Schmidt damals, wenn da auch irgendwelche Gäste aus dem Publikum, natürlich immer die Standardfrage, wo kommen sie her, aber nur, um sich drüber lustig zu machen. Ah, kenn ich, muss man von der A27 da runterfahren und dann und so. Aber hier wird das ganz ernst durchgekaut. Das ist gut, dass man weiß, wo die Leute herkommen.
Das ist nicht so weit.
Das heißt, ihr seid zwar ein Paar, aber ihr wohnt noch nicht zusammen.
Ich gehe mal ganz schön davon aus, dieses Püppchen ist nicht von dem jungen Mann, sondern von dir.
Richtig, genau. Wunderbar.
Natürlich.
Und auch noch die Genderordnung. Die stimmt natürlich noch im ZDF.
Das wär's ja gewesen.
Okay, wir hören jetzt mal, was wir zu dieser Puppe so sagen müssen. Was wir da erfahren, was ist das für ein Püppchen?
Ja, der Hersteller, der hier hinter steht, das ist die Firma MaxKahl. Der Ursprung, der geht ganz weit zurück ins 19. Jahrhundert. Da gab es einen Gottlieb Wilhelm Döring aus Jugendbach, also im thüringischen Jugendbach. Hat er solche Spielzeuge produziert. Der hat Pappmaschekörper genommen, die wurden mit Plüsch überzogen. Das war damals schon ein Verkaufsschlager. Später hat dann sein Sohn Heinrich die Firma übernommen. Das war Ende des 19. Jahrhunderts. Der hat die dann weitergeführt bis 1924, weil das der verstorben. Dann kam MaxKahl auf einmal ins Spiel. Der hat dann das Unternehmen weitergeführt.
Einmal im Monat gucke ich mit Danny, dem Künstler aus Köln, Kulturzeit und so etwas, diesen ganzen politikfreien Kram. Danny hat mich auch mal hier mit auf eine Kunstmesse genommen. Keine Kunstausstellung, sondern Kunstmesse, wo die Künstler aus Deutschland zusammenkommen und dann dem geneigten Käuferpublikum aus dem Westend in Frankfurt zeigen, was sie so haben. Und das ist ganz interessant, weil da kommen die Leute nicht mit allem, was sie jemals gemacht haben und versuchen, dann möglichst viel davon zu verhökern, sondern sie suchen sich so ein, zwei Dinge aus ihrem Werk aus und mit denen gehen sie dann dahin. Und dann sitzen die vor ihren Kunstwerken, also einfach jeder Künstler hat da so seine drei, vier, fünf Meter, je nachdem, und dann ist das Kunstwerk. Und man guckt so drauf und denkt sich, das ist eine große weiße Fläche und da sind Linien drauf. Das wäre mir irgendwie so und so viel wert. Aber der Künstler ist ja da und erzählt die Geschichte. Und dann sagt er, das sind nicht einfach weiße Linien, sondern das ist eine Glasfeder. Die habe ich anfertigen lassen von so und so. Und die Farbe braucht dann so und so lange, um da runter zu rinnen. Und diese Glasfeder hängt dann an einem Pferdehaar und wird so und so in Schwung gesetzt. Und dadurch kommen die, durch die Bewegung dann die Formeln auf das Papier. Und zack ist das Ding vier-fünfstellig wert. Weil du nämlich dann auch genau diese Geschichte weiter erzählen kannst. Wenn jemand in deinem Wohnzimmer steht und fragt, das ist aber nur einfach Farbe auf weißem Grund oder nein, das ist die Glasfeder, das ist das Pferdehaar, das ist das Schwunggerät und so weiter und so fort. Und natürlich auch noch mein Kauf und die Erzählung, wie ich das bekommen habe und so weiter und so fort. Und so ist das hier auch. Der Typ ist ziemlich clever. Der geht nämlich einfach dahin und sagt, also diese Puppe, hören Sie mal zu, ich bin ja der Experte für die Puppe selber. Die kommt von dem und dem und der hieß so und so. Und das war ein dem und dem Ort. Und dann hat er das so und so gemacht. Und jetzt ist alles ganz toll. Also die Geschichte gleich mitliefern, dann ist, glaube ich, das ganze Ding schon mal doppelt so viel wert.
Storytelling ist alles. Ich habe das ja auch erlebt, wenn ich mir ein Parfum von Tom Ford gekauft habe, dass ich dann auch gefragt wurde, soll ich Ihnen noch die Geschichte dazu erzählen? Als dann Tom Ford in Portofino dies und das gerochen hat und dachte, Mensch, das könnte man doch auch mal in Flaschen gießen und dann als Parfum verkaufen. Also sowas bekommst du dann. Und dann denke ich, ja, was soll man dann noch mit der Geschichte machen? Die erzähl ich dann dem Stefan nochmal oder was.
Aber das ist auch die Laschet Geschichte, ne? Das ist ganz wichtig, nochmal die. Also es war damals so, ich war ja verantwortlich.
Fingern rund telefoniert.
Sie waren ja alle nur Publikum in der Pandemie. Ich war ja Protagonist. Ich hab zum Telefonheuer gegriffen. Ich hab von Lag ein gerufen. Ich, ich, ich, ich und so. Und dann hast du die Geschichte zusammen.
Und es ist aber eine Nonsensgeschichte. Also wir haben sie schon vergessen. Also wir können jetzt schon nicht mehr sagen, was gerade zu dieser Puppe gesagt wurde, obwohl wir aufmerksam zuhören. Also man könnte auch aus dem Telefonbuch vorlesen. Aber man hat dann nicht das Narrativ. Also man braucht diese Geschichte und die gibt es dann hier. Aber tolle Geschichte. Dennoch, Puppe ist wohl nicht so wertvoll, wie wir hören.
Gut, aber ihr wollt ja nicht viel haben, so 800 bis 1000 Euro.
Kommt drauf an, wie stark die Inflation steigt.
Also wir hatten uns gehofft, für ein Eis wird es vielleicht reichen.
Macht in Euro?
Wenn noch die Kids noch einen Milch-Shake haben wollen, so 20 Euro.
20 Euro wären schön.
Ja, Stefan, da hörst du auf. Inflation, was ist denn da?
Inflation, deshalb will ich mit Inflation argumentieren.
Sie brauchen nicht so viel Geld, es sei denn, wenn die Inflation eklatant steigt, dann sind natürlich auch 20 Euro nichts mehr wert. Das ist die Angst des deutschen Sparers hier nochmal. Da wird auch die Union vermutlich aufpassen, dass es diesen Leuten nicht schlechter geht und dass diese Puppe das wert ist, was sie wert ist und dass man mit dem Geld auch dann noch das kaufen kann, was man gestern noch dafür bekommen hat.
Also ich fasse in diesem Moment mal kurz zusammen. Wolfgang hat uns einen Clip mitgebracht von einem Mann, der eine Puppe verkauft im Fernsehen, hofft so viel Geld zu bekommen, dass er mit seinem Kind Eis essen gehen kann, aber die Inflation könnte dem im Wege stehen.
Ja, und das ist jetzt nicht lange gesucht. Also ich hätte jetzt noch 100 andere. Es geht nur in diese Richtung. Also es ist nicht jetzt gezielt gesucht. Es war zufällig ein bisschen rumgeklickt, ein paar Sachen sich angehört. Okay, dann sind wir mal gespannt. Wie wird es jetzt laufen?
Siehst du, wir sind jetzt alle gespannt. Kriegt er jetzt ein Eis oder nicht?
Ich starte mit 40 Euro.
Das ist mal so der erste Preis, den man mal hört.
Dann gehöre ich ja auf die 50 Euro.
Ja, es ist dein Spielzeug.
Meinst du, die Kinder freuen sich, wenn wir...
Ja, wir wollten einen kleinen Ausflug damit auch bezahlen.
Ich glaube so, wenn wir vielleicht so Richtung 55 kommen würden.
Ich gebe mir auch gerne 60 Euro und dann machen wir einfach was.
60 Euro, da würde ich eher sagen, das ist ja inflationär, dass da jetzt plötzlich solche Preise verlangt werden.
Aber die ist natürlich gewollt. Also der Clip, den du uns gerade rausgesucht hast, der war jetzt 33 Sekunden von dir geschnitten. 33 Sekunden sind 33 Sekunden mehr, als sich heute schon All- und Tagesthemen zusammen Zeit genommen haben, um uns zu erklären, dass Kongress im Juni nochmal 250 Milliarden Anschubfinanzierung aus Staatsschulden bewilligt hat, damit die Silicon Valley Technologien, die eigentlich schon ausreichend durchfinanziert sind, nochmal besser auf Augenhöhe bleiben können, mit dem chinesischen Versuch, die Schlüsseltechnologien alle nach China zu holen. Das ist also ein ganzer Bundeshaushalt abzüglich des Rentenreservats, was da drin steht. Aber das ist wichtiger hier.
Man muss Prioritäten setzen. Und wir schalten jetzt zurück zur Pressekonferenz. Laschet wird gefragt, wie das denn nun ist mit den Benzinpreisen. Denn wir wissen ja, Scholz hat geantwortet in der Bildzeitung, ja, ich tank ja gar nicht selbst. Und wie ist denn das jetzt mit Laschet?
Herr Laschet, der SPD-Kanzlerkandidat Olaf Scholz hat bei uns gesagt, er tanke nicht selbst und wisse deshalb nicht, was ein Liter Benzin oder Diesel kostet. Wissen Sie es? Und was halten Sie davon, es nicht zu wissen?
Also ich glaube, er hat ja auch gesagt, er fährt nicht mehr selbst. Ich fahre noch selbst. Und ich verfolge das immer. Ich schätze, ich kann Ihnen jetzt nicht den Tageszent, der schwankt ja auch an vielen Tankstellen. Es ist übrigens ein Phänomen, dass wir es neuerdings sehen, dass manchmal an einem Tag 10 bis 15 Cent Differenz in einer einzigen Stadt sind. Ich denke, der Dieselpreis liegt im Moment so bei 130, 133 und der für Superbenzin entsprechend höher.
Ja, genau, Söder hat dann auch nochmal zwei Minuten ausgeholt. Das habe ich uns jetzt mal erspart, wie denn eigentlich der Preis ist. Also wir müssen uns das jetzt hier vorstellen. Hier wird jetzt das Zukunftsprogramm für Deutschland und Europa vorgestellt. Und die reden minutenlang, also da hat man wieder die Prioritätensetzung, minutenlang darüber, ja ist jetzt Liter Benzin, ist der jetzt 135, 140? Und ich fahre ja noch selbst, was natürlich auch eine Lüge ist. Als Ministerpräsident hat man den Fahrer. Sicherlich wird er auch hin und wieder mal selbst ein Auto besteigen, wenn er zur Tante fährt oder so und wird dann fahren. Aber natürlich wäre es ein Ministerpräsident, sonst nicht selbst Auto. Ein Bürgermeister wird in der Regel schon gefahren. Also das ist einfach Quatsch.
Wenn er ehrlich wäre und da muss man glaube ich mit einklammern, pendeln ist das also eins der gesundheitsgefährdendsten Sachen in Deutschland, da Pendeln unglaublich unglücklich macht. Und da hätte Laschet jetzt mal mutig sagen müssen, ich fahre noch selbst, wenn ich Lust drauf habe.
Ganz genau.
Und das wäre sozusagen die Kicker-Pornte für die ganzen Pendler gewesen, denen er hier die Pendler wahrscheinlich nicht streichen will.
Und wir hören jetzt noch den zweiten Teil dieser Preisdiskussion.
Ich hätte es übrigens auch nicht gewusst, man hat gerade jemand eine SMS dazu geschrieben.
Ich glaube ich hätte es schon gewusst, weil ich das aus Interesse verfolge, wenn ich so durch die Stadt fahre, wie groß die Schwankungen. Früher war der Benzinpreis ein, zwei Cent. Und wenn die Nachbartankstelle runter ging, ging der Nachbar auch runter. Heute haben sie im Laufe eines Tages auf solche Schwankungen, durch das irgendwie spannend finde, erst zu verfolgen.
Ja, das ist ganz typisch CDU, dass man Bürgernähe darüber herstellt, dass man den Bürgern erklärt, was das Problem der Bürger ist, weil man es selber nicht hat.
Ganz genau. Aber wir können uns auch Laschet sehr gut als den idealen Zuschauer von Bares für Rares vorstellen. Er sagt, da sind ja jetzt hier doch noch 10 Euro mehr. Das ist ja, warten wir heute Morgen schon an der Tankstelle, habt ihr da gesehen, da sind wieder 10 Cent mehr. Gestern Abend waren noch niedriger. Das ist ein ganz großes Thema. Ich weiß ja auch, dass die soziale Frage mit Blick auf den Benzin sehr wichtig ist, aber ich möchte auch darauf hinweisen, dass es sehr viele Leute gibt, die so einen Fetisch-Benzin-Preis haben, der überhaupt nicht angebracht ist. Also beispielsweise kenne ich einen etwas entfernt wohnenden Nachbarn, der einen Fuhrpark hat mit Fähton und so weiter, also Autos, die 80.000 Euro kosten. Der mir aber mal erzählte, dass er so eine ganz tolle App auf dem Handy hat, die ihn informiert, wenn an der Tankstelle der Preis niedrig ist, und dann fährt der los, auch wenn er dann nur 20 Liter tanken muss, aber dann hat er was gespart. Und dann denke ich mir, wenn man 80.000 Euro Autos fährt, und dann noch über den Benzinpreis nachdenkt, ob der 5 Cent mehr oder weniger kostet, dann muss man doch vollkommen durchgeknallt sein.
Ja, aber das hast du doch in jedem Garten, in dem gegrillt wird. Hast du zwar den super teuren Grill, aber beim Fleisch muss dann unbedingt das Angebot her, weil es wäre ja blöd, da würde man ja, ne?
Da würde man ja zwei Euro draufschlegen, ja, ja.
Genau, und beim Fleisch dann sparen. Aber in Sicht passt das doch ins deutsche Bild.
Diese Sichtweise auf Welt und Weltwahrnehmung ist, glaube ich, das Erfolgsgeheimnis der CDU. Und das ist so präsent und wird medial auch so oft reproduziert, dass wir uns davon einfach gar nicht lösen können. Und bei diesen Sätzen, die da so eigentlich fallen bei einer Pressekonferenz, musste ich nicht nur an solche schönen Geschichten aus Heimatfilmen und sonst was denken. Ich musste nicht nur an Bares für Rares denken, sondern was bei Bares für Rares wie auch bei solchen Pressekonferenzen eigentlich produziert wird, ist absurdes Theater. Also es sind Nonsensunterhaltungen. Es ist wirklich so eine Selbst-Gewisserung untereinander. Ich bin okay, du bist okay, wir sind okay. Und das hat mich dann tatsächlich an absurdes Theater erinnert, zum Beispiel an UNESCO und das berühmte Stück von ihm, Die kahle Sängerin. Wer ist die kahle Sängerin? Von dieser kahlen Sängerin erfährt man im ganzen Stück nichts. Es gibt nur irgendwann diesen Moment, wenn ein Feuerwehrhauptmann nach dieser kahlen Sängerin fragt. Und danach sind die Ehepaare Smith und Martin dann wieder zusammen allein und unterhalten sich nur noch in Sätzen, die so auch alle abgesondert werden könnten von Laschet oder Söder. Ich habe das mal eingelesen, so eine kleine Szene daraus. Hauptmann wendet sich zum Ausgang, bleibt dann stehen. Ah, dass ich es nicht vergesse, was macht die kahle Sängerin? Allgemeines betretenes Schweigen? Mrs. Miss? Sie trägt immer noch die gleiche Frisur. Hauptmann? Ach, dann auf Wiedersehen, meine Damen und Herren. Mr. Martin?
Viel Glück und viel Feuer.
Hauptmann, hoffen wir es.
Für alle.
Der Feuerwehrhauptmann geht ab, alle begleiten ihn zur Tür, kehren dann auf ihre Plätze zurück. Mrs. Martin? Ich kann ein Taschenmesser kaufen für meinen Bruder. Ihr könnt Ihr Land nicht kaufen für euren Großvater. Mr. Smith? Man geht auf den Füßen, aber man wärmt sich mit Kohle oder Elektrizität. Mr. Martin? Wer heute ein Ei kauft, hat morgen zwei. Mrs. Smith? Man muss im Leben durchs Fenster schauen. Mrs. Martin? Man kann auf dem Stuhl sitzen, auch wenn der Stuhl keine hat. Mr. Smith? Man soll immer an alles denken. Mr. Martin? Die Decke ist oben, der Boden ist unten. Mrs. Smith? Wenn ich Ja sage, so meine ich das nur so. Mrs. Martin? Jedem sein Schicksal. Mr. Smith? Nimm einen Kreis, streichle ihn und er wird zum Zirkelschluss. Mrs. Smith? Der Lehrer lehrt die Kinder lesen. Die Katze gibt Milch den Kleinen, wenn sie klein sind. Mrs. Martin? Die Kuh gibt uns aber ihre Schwänze.
Ja, nachts ist kälter als draußen. Stehen zwei Pferde im Keller, sagt es eine.
UNESCO hat damit diese bürgerliche Gesellschaft wunderbar karikiert in diesem Stück. Das ist so hochaktuell, das könnte man sofort wieder aufführen. Und dann am besten auch alle verkleidet als Laschet, Karliczek und so weiter. Dann hätte man das entsprechende Theater auf dem Theater. Und jetzt gibt es aber doch bei all diesem Spaß, den man dabei haben kann, ja einen ganz ernsten Untergrund. Und das ist der wirtschaftliche. Der Bund der deutschen Industrie hat auch getagt. Und da waren auch die Spitzenpolitiker zu Gast. Das schenken wir uns jetzt mal komplett. Wir hören uns jetzt nur zwei Clips an von dem Präsidenten Siegfried Russwurm. Und dann weiß man eigentlich, welche Stündlein geschlagen hat, für wen die Union Politik machen will. Und hoffentlich nicht dann auch die Grünen, weil die natürlich auch zum Kotau dorthin gegangen sind. Denn was hier nochmal gesagt wird, ist, wir wollen eigentlich, dass der Neoliberalismus mal so richtig weitergeht. Wir haben noch lange nicht genug davon profitiert.
Besteht in Deutschland des Jahres 2021 noch der Grundkonsens, dass dieses Land Industrieland, Exportland und Innovationsland sein muss? Besteht dieser Grundkonsens noch gesellschaftlich und politisch?
Wurden wir da mal gefragt? Klingt so, als würden wir da mal gefragt und hätten alle zustimmt. Aber so ist das wahrscheinlich gemeint.
Schließt dieser Grundkonsens auch noch das Grundverständnis der sozialen Marktwirtschaft ein? Also aktiver sozialer Ausgleich als ausdrückliche Verpflichtung, aber eben auf Basis von Markt, Unternehmertum, Wettbewerb, Handel und Privateigentum. In vielen Kreisen und bis weit in Regierungsparteien hinein wird permanent über Enteignungen, Verstaatlichungen, Verbote, immer neue Regulierungen, zusätzliche Steuerbelastungen gesprochen. Wird Unternehmertum mit Argwohn und Misstrauen begegnet und unternehmerische Lösungskompetenz auf Abstand gehalten. Wenn wir uns nicht mehr einig sind, dass Stabilität und Wohlstand in diesem Land auf diesen Säulen aufbauen, und zwar gesamtgesellschaftlich genauso wie individuell, dann müssen wir über diese fundamentale Frage diskutieren, denn dann sind alle Detaildiskussionen zu kurz gesprungen.
Ja, das ist jetzt eine Drohung, die hier laut wird. Also sind wir jetzt schon kurz vor dem Sozialismus. Ist es schon so weit jetzt mit der Bundesregierung, dass sie uns alle enteignet wird? Wie schlimm kann es noch kommen für uns Unternehmer? Wir haben nur gelitten in den vergangenen Jahren. Ist jetzt bald alles zu Ende mit dem Kapitalismus?
Ja, aber ist der Siegfried neu im Amt? Klingt so, als würde er hier auch so ein paar Pflöcke einschlagen.
Der ist neu im Amt, ja. Sieht nicht so aus, aber er ist neu im Amt.
Also in deren Sicht will er glaube ich auch so einen Punkt machen, den BDI mal, also den Mitglied mal wieder zu zeigen, was der BDI auch eigentlich leisten kann, wenn er mal einen ordentlichen Chef hat.
Ja, und es gibt schon kleine Erfolge, wie wir jetzt hören.
Realität ist übrigens auch, dass Deutschland im OECD-Vergleich bei den Unternehmensteuern an der Spitze liegt. Das dient nicht gerade der Attraktivität und globalen Wettbewerbsfähigkeit des Exportlandes. Es sollte uns schon zu denken gehen, dass die Diskussion um eine globale Mindeststeuer auf den halben Unternehmensteuersatz von Deutschland hinausläuft. Ich weiß, jetzt denken sich einige von Ihnen, jetzt kommt er wieder mit diesem Uralt-Thema. Ja, das Thema ist alt, aber nur deshalb, weil es trotz sehr konkreter Vorschläge des BDI immer noch keinen echten Fortschritt gibt in Richtung eines Level-Playing-Fields auch in der Steuerentlastung. Aber immerhin hat uns das Thema schon als Problemanzeige in einzelne Wahlprogramme gebracht. Wir werden also den Tropfen stetig weiter fallen lassen.
Ja, der Herr Reitz, der mir im Presseklub gegenüber saß, hat ja genau das Argument auch gemacht. Deutschland ist ja im OECD-Vergleich ganz weit vorn. Das stimmt aber nur, wenn man sich den juristischen Text angeschaut. Die nominale Steuerbelastung ist bei weitem unterhalb dieser Durchschnittswerte, die man da mal anleiert. Und in solchen Momenten hätte ich auch gerne den Reiz, aber auch ihn ja, den Roswurm gerne mal gefragt. Ja, wenn Sie sich in Europa anschauen, meinen Sie wirklich, die Unternehmen drohen, nach Bulgarien abzuwandern, nach Ungarn? Es droht doch gar keine bayerische Landesregierung, dass sie sich jetzt plötzlich in Budapest ansiedelt oder so. Also in deren Sicht ist das immer so Banane, eine rein juristisch gefasste, niemals in der Höhe eingetriebene Steuerpflicht, für irgendwas als Argument zu nehmen. Und vor allem als einziges Argument, als ob es den Unternehmen nicht auch noch um was anderes ginge, wie zum Beispiel um eine Infrastruktur, die es den Mitarbeitern erlaubt, auch einfach mal pünktlich bei der Arbeit zu sein und so. Das wird alles komplett ausgeblendet.
Nur sieht man hier, was für ein Druck aufgebaut wird und dass auch das ganz offen noch gesagt wird. Das ist ja Gott sei Dank jetzt mal in einige Wahlprogramme eingeflossen. Also wie vehement genau solche Organisationen arbeiten. Also da ist Fridays for Future oder so gar nichts gegen. Also hier sind diejenigen, die wirkliche Macht haben und diese auch geltend machen. Und was wir hier noch erleben, ist ja, dass einfach so getan wird, als sei es den Unternehmen in den letzten 20 Jahren so schlecht ergangen. Die haben ja extreme Steuererleichterungen gehabt. Und wenn wir uns die Investitionsquote ansehen, dann hat sich da nichts getan. Also es wurde nicht mit diesen Steuererleichterungen, mit diesem zusätzlichen Geld gesagt, wir investieren jetzt, sondern man hat weniger investiert, obwohl man Steuererleichterungen hat. Es gab dann bei den Konzernen Aktienrückkäufe. Es wurden Managergehälter aufgepimpt. Es wurden die Eigentümer dann noch kräftiger entlohnt, bzw. haben die noch mehr Kapital rausgezogen, um es dann in Immobilien zu stecken, um dann Land zu kaufen, und, und, und. Diese ganzen Dinge, also es ist enorm viel Geld da, aber man hat überhaupt gar keine Interesse daran. Das heißt, was hier stattfindet, ist eigentlich, dass man nur sagt, wir wollen noch stärker von unten nach oben umverteilen und suchen jetzt die Parteien, die es mitmachen. Und ich bin sehr gespannt, wie wir da im nächsten Jahr drüber sprechen werden, wenn wir dann eine neue Regierung haben. Nehmen wir mal an, wir haben dann eine grün-schwarze Regierung, also mit einer grünen Kanzlerin, ob sich das dann so ändern wird. Wir werden ja ein bisschen hier eine lustige Konstellation erleben. Ich bin ja der, der nicht mehr enttäuscht werden kann, weil ich ja schon total fatalistisch bin. Du bist ja jemand, der noch eine Hoffnungsträgerin jetzt hat, Annalena Baerbock, und da wird sich dann zeigen, was sich davon einlöst. Man kann jedenfalls aber festhalten, dass man nur hoffen kann, dass SPD, Linke, Grüne stark sind. Denn was da von der CDU kommt, ist einfach grauenhaft. Also da gibt es auch nichts zu reden. Und da können wir jetzt über Performances diskutieren und ob sie die richtige Kandidatin ist oder ob jetzt die Linke eigentlich Fabio Di Masi haben müsste und so. Ja, alles gut und schön. Aber wenn man es mal ganz klar runterrechnet, dann muss man sagen, mit der CDU wird es schlimmer werden.
Genau. Und in der Hinsicht, ja, ich bin voller Hoffnung, dass es mit grüner Beteiligung besser wird. Aber ich bin überhaupt nicht, auch nur in Ansätzen einer Überzeugung, dass es hier für einen Nicht-CDU-Kanzler reicht. Denn der nächste Kanzler kommt auch von der CDU. Also diese Vorstellung sollte man sich, glaube ich, nicht machen, zu glauben, dass es da jetzt noch mal... So viele Hitzewellen kann Deutschland gar nicht. Gut, wir wissen nie genau, wie der Sommer wird. Selbst in Kanada sind mittlerweile schon 50 Grad für die nächsten Tage angesagt. In Spanien rollt jetzt gerade eine Hitzewelle. Also es ist noch Juni und man ist dort schon wieder kurz vor 45 Grad. In Frankreich wurden die 45 Grad letztes Jahr schon geknackt. Vielleicht erleben wir das dieses Jahr, dass wirklich solche historischen Temperaturrekorde aufgestellt werden. In der Ansicht wäre alles möglich bei klugen Wahlkampf, aber die Trägheit ist hoch. Und ich will mal das Thema gar nicht zu weit weg wechseln, über Armut sprechen. Nochmal mit dem Nachtrag, warum Bares für Rares? Warum Armin Laschet? Es ist ja ganz interessant, schon allein wenn wir Fernsehnachrichten gucken, sind ja die Nachrichten eigentlich immer in dem Modus gemacht. Wir Nachrichtensprecher sagen euch jetzt, was Sache ist. Vertraut uns bitte, dass ansonsten nicht viel passiert ist. Und dann fliegt alles raus und man geht zu uns Bett und denkt, die Welt lebt, ist noch da. Kanzlerin lebt noch, Messe wurde eröffnet, alles geht seinen Gang. Und das ist ja auch bei Bares für Rares. Wir gucken Bares für Rares, kriegen dort ein Problem serviert. Und der Subtext ist, es ist nichts Unterhaltsames oder Wichtigeres gerade zu gucken. Das ist unser Angebot und das ist richtig. Und das ist ja auch das Programm von Laschet. Laschet hat ja von Markus Feldenkirchen im Spiegel so ein kleines Porträt bekommen, wo noch mal die Gelassenheit abgefeiert wurde. Armin der Gelassene, er hat Söder überstanden, er hat März überstanden. Es ist eigentlich die Tradition von Merkel, er sitzt sie alle aus. Die Gelassenheit ist sein großes Pfund. Und da gleicht sich ja wirklich sehr. Laschet ist tatsächlich so der Bares für Rares Kandidat. Er wird uns so dargestellt, er redet so ganz locker. Für ihn ist immer alles ganz... Dann muss man auch mal über Sachen nachdenken. Dann haut er auch mal auf den Tisch, lässt die Hand so fallen. Das hört man ja auch immer. Aber ansonsten ist nichts, er kriegt das dann schon hin. Diese Art der Gelassenheit steckt ja da drin. Und damit werden ja immer andere Themen und Probleme verdrängt. Wie zum Beispiel, im Juni kam ja auch der neue Reichstums- und Armutsbericht. Er heißt jetzt immer doppelt, nicht nur der Armutsbericht, sondern es ist auch ein Reichtumsbericht. Und er wurde sowohl im Bundestag als auch im zuständigen Fachausschuss verhandelt. Und das schauen wir uns an. Irrigerweise fand die Sitzung im Bundestag dazu statt, weil die AfD Anträge dazu gestellt hat. Andere Parteien glaube ich auch, aber die AfD konnte das erst mal so als ihren Termin verbuchen, weshalb wir hier mal kurz hören. Und wir können es uns ja hier erlauben, wir sind alle aufgeklärt. Wir wissen, was die AfD für eine Partei ist, deswegen jetzt keine große Vorräte. Das ergibt sich alles durch die Clips selbst. Wir hören René Sprecher. Das ist der Bringer, der für die AfD die Armut der Deutschen beklagt.
Die Bundesregierung will der parlamentarischen Konfrontation aus dem Weg gehen. Das werden wir als AfD-Fraktionen aber nicht durchgehen lassen. Und deswegen haben wir diese Debatte beantragt, denn die Öffentlichkeit hat ein Recht zu erfahren, dass in Deutschland jedes fünfte Kind in...
So jetzt macht ihr so eine kleine Liste und ich lade euch alle ein. Hört euch das an und nickt ruhig mal so ein bisschen dabei. Ich verspreche euch, irgendwann kommt die Liste an den Punkt, da schüttelt man dann mit dem Kopf. Aber solange er die richtigen Punkte nennt, versucht nicht jetzt, ah ist die AfD, ich bin dagegen. Nö, er hat jetzt genannt Armut der Kinder und so weiter. Wir können durch mal Zustimmung, Zustimmung, Zustimmung. Das ist ja die AfD, das kippt dann schon entsprechend um. Keine Angst.
Armut aufwächst, dass 68 Prozent der Alleinerziehenden armutsgefährdet sind. Dass überall der Fachkräftemangel beklagt wird, wie aber 2, 1 Millionen junge Menschen unter 34 haben, die in 30 haben, die keinen Berufsabschluss haben. Dass die Aufstiegschancen in Deutschland schlechter sind als in den 80er Jahren. Dass jeder Fünfte im Niedriglohnsektor arbeitet. Und viele von denen nach Abzug von Miete, Strom, Spritgeld und Zoobesuch für die Kinder weniger in der Tasche haben, als einer der rund zwei Millionen ausländischen Hartz-IV-Bezieher, von denen viele nie auch nur einen Cent in unser Sozialsystem eingezahlt haben.
Also die Problemliste, richtig? Nur, wer hat uns das Geld geklaut? Die Ausländer oder der BDI? Also wenn Unternehmen wie VW die größten Umschwünge im Unternehmen, nämlich hinweg vom Verbrenner zu wir planen jetzt 10 Millionen ID3 oder wie auch immer diese Plattform da heißt pro Jahr machen, und diesen strukturellen Umbau des Unternehmens, nämlich wirklich am Produkt, ein neues Produkt, hinbekommt, während sie gleichzeitig 30 Milliarden Strafzahlungen leisten wegen ihrem Verbrenner, dann ist die deutsche Industrie gut aufgestellt. Hier werden zu viele Gelder als Unternehmensgewinn abgegriffen. Das könnte man auch all den Armen, die er eben genannt hat, zur Verfügung stellen. Das Geld beispielsweise über eine wirklich staatlich organisierte Umverteilung, dass man alleinerziehende Kinder und so weiter mal ordentlich fördert. Dafür brauchen wir keine Ausländer. Das Ausländerargument ist noch mal doppelt falsch, denn hätten wir beispielsweise nicht 2015 eine Million Menschen, von denen heute schon 40 Prozent sozialversicherungspflichtig hier eingestellt sind und noch mal mehrere hunderttausend Abitur gerade gemacht haben, also dann auch künftig für den Arbeitsmarkt zur Verfügung stehen, hätten wir den nicht, wären wir jetzt mit mehreren hunderttausend potenziell nicht mehr, also potenziellen Einzahlern, die da nicht da wären, im Miese, haben aber derzeit noch aussergewöhnlich eine Sozialversicherungskassen. Also das ist Einwanderung in die Sozialsysteme auf der Einzahlerseite gewesen.
Ganz genau, wir werden ja im Salon ein furioses Buch besprechen. Ich bin schon so begeistert, ich habe erst die Hälfte gelesen. Move, das Zeitalter der Migration von Parakanna und der bringt genau solche Argumente. Das ist ein ganz globaler Blick einmal, der sagt, wie Migration eigentlich zu denken ist. Und ich würde sagen, es ist das Handbuch für jeden, der sich links empfindet fühlt. Sonst war es jeder, der sagt, wir brauchen offene Grenzen oder mehr offene Grenzen. Wir brauchen mehr Migration. Wir dürfen keine Abschiebung mehr haben. Also jeder, der mit solchen Argumenten kommt, argumentiert gerne moralisch, argumentiert gerne mit Gefühl und so weiter. Und hier gibt es einfach mal alle Fakten, warum es wirtschaftlich ein Fiasco ist, Länder abzuschotten. Und gerade jetzt, es gibt so eine Stelle, wo er sagt, das Land, das das als erstes begriffen hat, wird Gewinner sein in der Zukunft. Das erste Land, das begriffen hat, dass Migration richtig viel bringt und dass es die einzige Chance noch ist. Er dekliniert das alles durch. Ich glaube, das wird ein tolles Buch, über das wir da sprechen.
Genau, ich meine, selbst Jens Spahn hat es damals, 2018, im Kampf gegen März und AKK schon angemerkt. Es sind 300.000, 400.000 Menschen, die hier in die Sozialkassen einzahlen. Ohne die sähe es echt düster aus. Man stelle sich mal das Land England vor, ohne die Attraktivität über die englische Sprache, die so viele junge Menschen anzieht, die da hinziehen, selbst unter widrigsten Brexit-Bedingungen. Dann hätten wir nämlich so einen Bulgarien da oben. Wenn die in England bulgarisch sprechen würden, wär da aus die Maus. Der wäre einfach zappendust, das Land wär Bankrott. Der AfDler hier, wir hören uns noch seinen Forderungskatalog an, bevor wir dann zu den ernsthaften Parteien umschwenken. Und das ist jetzt gegen die elementare Armut am unteren Rand, alleinerziehende Kinder und so weiter, das ist jetzt ein Forderungskatalog.
Eine verbindliche Steuer- und Abgabenbremse ins Grundgesetz zu schreiben. Wir fordern die Abschaffung der erneuerbaren Energieumlage, damit der Strom wieder bezahlbar ist. Wir fordern die Abschaffung der CO2-Steuer, damit der Sprit wieder bezahlbar ist. Wir fordern die Ermöglichung von Vermögensaufbau, insbesondere durch Immobilieneigentum für Familien. Wir fordern die Unterstützung junger Familien mit einem Ehe-Staat-Kredit und einem steuerlichen Familien-Splitting. Wir fordern einen Stopp des Lohndumpings durch illegale Massenmigration und EU-Freizügigkeit. Und wir fordern ein Ende der vermögensvernichtenden Nullzinspolitik der Europäischen Zentralbank.
Ich hab jetzt für Wohlstand für alle das gesamte Programm gelesen der AfD. Und es ist nur bescheuert. Und wer noch in irgendeiner Weise glaubt, dass die eine soziale Frage positiv beantworten wollen, muss vollkommen knödel sein.
Ja, also die Lösung für alleinerziehenden Armut und Kinderarmut ist, Steuern zu begrenzen und Eigenheime zu fördern. Darauf hat Daniela Kolbe von der SPD die richtige Antwort gegeben.
Also ich glaube, dass die alleinerziehende Einzelhandelskaufrau aus Leipzig hat sicherlich andere Probleme als über Förderung von Immobilienkäufen nachzudenken, wie sie das hier so anklingen lassen.
Das ist wirklich einfach nur absurd.
Ja, es ist absurd und ich finde, es reicht nicht, es so zu sagen. Also die alleinerziehende Leipzig, die Verkäuferin, die spielt Immobilien erstmal keine Rolle. Die braucht Wohngeld und den ganzen Kram, diesen Katalog. Ich finde aber, und das ist jetzt mal beispielhaft dafür, wie ich mir wünsche, dass der Wahlkampf in Deutschland geführt wird. John Oliver, der Komiker aus Amerika. Macht ja immer politisch ernsthafte Themen in der Aufbereitung. Und dann hat er hier zuletzt PACE, was auch immer die Abkürzung heißt. Also da geht es darum, dass Obama damals eingeführt hat, wenn ihr einen klimaneutralen Umbau für euer Haus, euer privates Haus, dann haben wir hier ein Finanzierungsmodell für euch. Und das greift er auf. Also das ist so ein Dauerthema. Und dann macht er einen ganz kleinen Exkurs. Denn es geht ja um Eigenheime.
Wow, das klingt wie ein tolles Programm für Hausbesitzer. Und übrigens, wenn du unter 35 bist, lass mich kurz deine Verwaltungen hier beenden. Ein Hausbesitzer ist eine Person, die ihr Haus besitzt. Du weißt, wie deine Eltern in einem Haus leben, aber sie haben keinen Landwirt, sie müssen keine Leakate signen, sie bezahlen keine Sicherheitsdepotente. Das ist das, was du tun kannst. Wenn du unter 35 bist, kannst du diese Geschichte eigentlich verhaken. Keine Sorge, kämpfe mit einem 15-Jährigen im TikTok über den coolsten Weg, deinen Haar zu färben.
Das ist doch die Situation. Bundestag, wenn die AfD kommt mit, wir fördern das Eigenheime, also hört mal zu, Eigenheime fördern, also den Kaufpreis von 800.000 auf 760.000 irgendwie drücken oder so, das hilft echt niemanden, vor allem nicht den Alleinerziehenden oder den Kindern.
Nur Stefan, ich sag dir, das ist nicht nur bei der AfD virulent. Ich hab das ja beobachtet bei den Influencern jetzt auch nochmal, als diese ganzen Sachen kamen mit Enteignungen und so. Diesen ganzen neuen Debatten der vergangenen Woche, da seh ich dann deutsche Influencer, die dann sagen, jetzt gibt's gute Gelegenheiten, früh in Wohneigentum zu investieren. Und man kann ja mit kleinen Schritten anfangen. Und dann ist da eine Influencerin in Berlin, die dann sagt, sie hätte sich jetzt auch erstmal eine kleine Eigentumswohnung nochmal für 400.000 gekauft. Und das sei auch nachhaltig, weil da noch das und das dann drin gemacht wird. Und das wirkt diesen Leuten, die denen dann folgen, eingeredet, dass das doch eigentlich alles ganz einfach und toll ist. Und dann frage ich mich, wie kann man auch so ein gestörtes Weltverhältnis und Wirklichkeitsverhältnis haben, dass man glaubt, dass diese Follower irgendwelche Studentinnen vielleicht oder Schülerinnen jetzt sagen, ach ja, genau, eine Eigentumswohnung. Man kann ja auch mal klein anfangen mit 400.000.
Jetzt muss ich hier einen Clip von Julienco raussuchen.
Bibi, das ist der Mann von Bibis Beauty Palace. Und die haben sich ja ganz früh kennengelernt und sind ja inzwischen verheiratet, haben Kinder. Sie hat auch ein neues Gesicht jetzt. Und Julienco und Bibi haben ja ein riesen Ferienhaus irgendwo in, weiß ich nicht, wo im Süden. Da sind sie ja kürzlich mit dem Privatstädt mal hingeflogen und geschaut, wie weit das aufgebaut ist.
Okay, wir hören kurz Julienco's Meinung zum Thema Investments. Man stellt sich vor, er sitzt auf dem Bett, sie liest ihm Fragen aus der Community vor. Das ist ja berühmte, also gern gemachte Content, dass man einfach, ja, was haben wir für Fragen gelesen, mal vor, dann beantworten wir die. Hier steht eine Frage im Raum.
Deine Meinung zu Investments?
Find ich ganz schlecht.
Nein, das ist sehr breit gefälsert jetzt.
Ja, also breiter kann ich jetzt gar nicht sagen, super Sache, Geld irgendwo rumliegen zu haben oder so, ist gerade in der jetzigen Zeit nichts Schönes und nichts Gutes und...
Ja, einfach Geld rumliegen zu haben, ist nichts Gutes und nichts Schönes, das muss jetzt investiert werden irgendwo. Das ist die Antwort auf die Frage, was machen wir jetzt mit den Millionen Kindern in Armut und so? Na ja, zurück in den Bundestag, Matthias Zimmer, CDU, er möchte die ganze Sache hier mal ein bisschen verteidigen. Klar, müsste man jetzt eigentlich über Armut sprechen, wo das doch als Tagesordnungspunkt aufgerufen wurde, aber zum Glück hat die AfD die Debatte eröffnet, also kann man erstmal auf den Gegner einschießen.
Also man spürt hier förmlich den Willen, der zum deutschen Mutterkreuz drängt. Deutsche Frauen, deutscher Wein heißt es ja bei Hoffmann von Fallersleben. Und man hat schon ein bisschen den Verdacht, dass vom deutschen Wein ein bisschen zu viel genossen wurde bei der Abfassung dieses Antrages.
Pipapo, und außerdem gilt doch...
Ich will das ein oder andere dann doch vielleicht zu dem Armut, zum Reichtumsbericht der Bundesregierung sagen. Der stellt nämlich der Politik der Bundesregierung insgesamt ein gutes Zeugnis aus.
Ja, hat in dem Fall nur die AfD gelacht, aber den anderen war man ja auch ein bisschen mitgeschmunzelt. Er macht hier noch mal einen Punkt Armut. Das ist wie beim Wissenschaftszeit-Arbeitsvertrags-Pipapo-Gesetz. Hanna weiß doch, wie es geht.
Vielleicht ein Blick in die Zukunft, was bleibt zu tun, weil wir jetzt auch ja die Wahlprogramme formulieren. Bildung weiter ausbauen, das ist glaube ich die zentrale Erkenntnis des Armuts- und Reichtumsberichtes. Das ist zentral im Übrigen auch für die Integration von Zuwanderern. Bildung ist der wirksamste, der sicherste, der wichtigste Motor des Aufstiegs.
Okay, die Bildungsfahrt, also das brauchen wir gar nicht kritisieren, denn wir hören jetzt Gegenargumente zum einen, sogar die FDP weiß mal drauf hin. Also hier Pascal Korba.
In der Zeit der SPD, Sozialminister, Andrea Nahles und Hubertus Heil ist auswärtslich dieses Armuts-
und Reichtumsberichts die Zahl der Abgänger ohne Schulabschluss in Deutschland auf einen Höchststand angewiesen.
Das ist nicht die Schuld der Sozialminister, aber sie haben eine Schuld, wenn sie Anträge der FDP, hier im Bundestag, dass man bildungsbenachteiligte Schülerinnen und Schüler über eine Erhöhung des Bildungs-
und Teilhabepakets besser fördert, damit sie einen Schulabschluss im besten Fall auch erreichen können, wenn sie diese Anträge ablehnen.
Ja, und ich meine, wenn der Rot-Grüne uns an die Pfanne haut, kann man sagen, ja, geschaut das bei der CDU an, wie schlimm es dann da noch ist. Also alle versagen bei dem Thema Bildung. Es führt nicht zu Wohlstand, sondern wir haben allenfalls mit Rekordzahlen an Schulabgängern zu tun, insbesondere jetzt im Corona-Jahr, wie viele Leute einfach nicht zur Prüfung erschienen sind, weil es dann plötzlich hieß, ja, jetzt wird abgerechnet, ich traue mir das nicht zu, zack, geht mir gar nicht aus dem Sinn. Das waren jetzt Wortmeldungen aus dem Bundestag, da dürfen natürlich nur Abgeordnete sprechen, da braucht man das Mandat. Das ist im Ausschuss ja ein bisschen anders, da dürfen ja auch mal Leute sprechen, die Ahnung haben. Also hat man sich im Ausschuss Olaf Groh-Samberg eingeladen, der zum Thema Bildungserfolge in Deutschland Folgendes sagt.
Der Befund ist sowas von eindeutig, die ganze Forschung belegt das. In dem Armut- und Reichtumsbericht auch. Zum Beispiel zeigen wir mit dem Lagenindikator, 12 % der Kinder in der Lage der Armut besuchen das Gymnasium, 67 % in der Lage Wohlhabenheit. Und das sind sozusagen Befunde, auch das Gutachten zur sozialen Mobilität von den Typikern und WZB, zeigt eindeutig diesen Zusammenhang von Einkommen auf den Bildungserfolg oder die besuchte Schulform, übrigens auch, wenn man dabei viele andere Aspekte schon mitkontrolliert. Also wenn man die Bildung der Eltern mit berücksichtigt, wenn man auch die schulischen Kompetenzen der Kinder mit berücksichtigt, auch dann noch besteht ein direkter Effekt des Einkommens und der ist auch unabhängig davon, wie gut die Kinder in der Schule tatsächlich sind. Das heißt, den Kindern werden Lebenschancen in einer gewissen Weise gekauft, unabhängig von ihrer schulischen Kompetenz.
Ja, das ist eigentlich witzig. Es gibt bei der Abhängigkeit des Einkommens der Eltern und des Bildungserfolgs der Kinder gar keine Störware jablem mehr. Kannste kommen, mit was du willst. Dieser Zusammenhang ist einfach wie ein Stein gemeißelt in Deutschland. Und wenn deine Familie gut ausgerüstet und ausgestattet ist und die Lehrer das auch wissen, weil du einfach der Zampanoe bist in der Schule, auf dem Schulhof zum Beispiel, oder sonst, dann ist dein Bildungserfolg sicher.
Und dann ist es ja zum Beispiel auch immer wieder so, dass die Eltern auch entsprechend Druck machen, wenn die Noten nicht stimmen. Und zwar nicht den Kindern, sondern den Lehrern. Also ich weiß auch da Geschichten von Drohungen. Man kann da auch mal den Rechtsanwalt nochmal sich das Diktat ansehen lassen.
Ja, ganz genau. Also der Druck ist da nur eben auf die Lehrer. Das habe ich hier auch schon mitbekommen, wie es so läuft. Naja, rück zum Thema Armut allgemein, also Bildung rettet uns erst mal nicht. Ja, müssen wir hier an Matthias Zimmer von der CDU sagen. Katja Kipping macht einen Vorschlag.
Und der Bericht liefert auch eine erfreuliche Zahlung, denn somit kann ich mit einem optimistischen Ausblick hier enden. 68 Prozent, also zwei Drittel aller Befragten meinen, Steuern auf massiven Reichtum müssen deutlich höher ausfallen. Übrigens, liebe FDP, sogar jeder zweite der reichsten Gruppe ist dieser Meinung.
Ja, da könnte man natürlich sagen, ja klar, wenn man gefragt wird, antwortet man sozial konform, ja, alle sollen sich beteiligen. Wenn es dann zur Abstimmung geht, ruft man doch nochmal seinen Abgeordneten an und sagt, aber es geht jetzt nicht um mein Geld, oder? Also in der Ansicht, aber Verwirkungssteuer klammern wir gleich nochmal aus, denn da gab es eine extra Tagesordnungspunkt im Bundestag dazu, der absolut amüsant war. Ich habe selten sowas im Bundestag gesehen. Beim Thema Armut sind es jetzt die Grünen, die einen ganz interessanten Vorschlag machen. Wir hören Wolfgang Strengmann-Kuhn, der hier mal ein seiner Anträge in einer seiner Reden mit einflächelt, nämlich zu diesem Antrag von dem Tagesordnungspunkt, den die AfD da aufgerufen hat. Und er stellt einen, also er beschreibt einen Antrag, in dem er Wohlstand für alle fordert, was wohl auch geht.
Eigentlich sollte es für ein reiches Land wie Deutschland sollte es der Anspruch sein, dass niemand von Armut betroffen ist, dass alle Menschen an der Gesellschaft teilhaben können. Das muss unser Anspruch sein und dafür haben wir Grünen jetzt einen Antrag vorgelegt, der das auch erreichen kann.
So, und jetzt müssen wir kurz sagen, die Armutsdefinition in Deutschland ist ja wie folgt, man nimmt alle Menschen, die Einkommen beziehen und teilt die in zwei Gruppen. Die einen verdienen mehr und die anderen verdienen weniger als die jeweiligen anderen. Also man nimmt einfach alle Einkommen und macht aber keinen Durchschnittswert, sondern man nimmt den Medien. Man teilt also einfach nur die Person ein, liegen sie über oder unter der Einkommensebene, die genau die Hälfte teilt. Und wer dann nochmal 60% davon nur erreicht, gilt ja als arm. Das hieß ja, wenn man die Leute, die unter 60 sind, auf 60 hebt, bleiben die immer noch unter dem Median. Ist ja immer noch eine Lücke von 40%. Also sie gehören immer noch zur Hälfte derjenigen, die weniger als die andere Hälfte verdienen, die reiche Hälfte. Aber sie fallen nicht mehr unter 60% des Medians, gelten also nicht mehr als arm, also nicht mal von Armut betroffen, sondern nur noch von Armut bedroht plötzlich. Und das haben die Grünen witzigerweise, also witzigerweise, ernsthaft witzigerweise in den Antrag gegossen, das einfach sicherzustellen. Da ist natürlich immer die CDU-Antwort, nee, man braucht ja eine Distanz zwischen denen, die absolut faul sind und denen, die noch arbeiten. Also müssen die Faulen entsprechend unter die 60%-Marke fallen und so weiter und so fort. Aber rein mathematisch lässt sich das tatsächlich so einfach lösen. Also man müsste nur eine ganz kleine Lücke, wie groß die ist, hören wir gleich noch, zumindest in einem inspirativen Einwurf, man müsste einfach nur alle auf, na mindestens, also man darf nicht 40% unter dem Medien liegen und schon wäre keiner mehr arm nach der Definition.
Aber wie kann es denn sein, wenn die Grünen dir ja solche Berechnungen da sogar anstellen, dass sie dann bei dem letzten Parteitag es abgelehnt haben, dass Hartz IV um 200 Euro erhöht wird. Also da haben sie ja eigentlich alle progressiven Vorschläge abgeschmettert. Also das war ja ganz erstaunlich, dass da wird zum Beispiel von der Grünen Jugend hochinteressante Vorschläge kamen und auch keine verrückten, also jetzt die haben ja nicht gesagt, sollen alle so doppelt so viel verdienen, sondern das waren ja Vorschläge, die sich auf Arbeitszeit bezogen, die sich darauf bezogen, dass Hartz IV sanktionsfrei wird und dass man dann 200 Euro mehr hat und dann hat man sich irgendwie zu 50 Euro mehr durchregen können. Also ich war da schon wieder sehr erstaunt, warum man das eigentlich macht. Will man jetzt tatsächlich noch glauben, dass man die CDU-Wähler erreichen kann, indem man noch mal versucht, jetzt sich der CDU anzunähern? Also das ist so eine ganz eigenartige Logik, die da drin steckt, dass man dann auch, auch Baerbock hat ja da noch so eine Rede gehalten, in der sie eigentlich versichert hat, habt keine Angst vor mir, ich bin fast so wie Angela Merkel. Und ich hab wirklich noch auf den Moment gewartet, dass man bei den Grünen sagt, so und wir schieben jetzt auch hier straffällige Flüchtlinge selbst noch mal in einem Flugzeug ab, damit ihr gucken könnt, wir sind auch Arthliner, wenn ihr das wollt.
Mit den Grünen ist es so, den sitzt natürlich Hartz IV auch im Nacken. Und ich hab das nicht verfolgt, 2000 Anträge, also wurde er da richtig abgelehnt mit einer Mehrheit oder für nichtig erklärt oder sonst irgendwo eingeordnet in so einem Bündel und dann abgelehnt. Man muss sich das genau angucken, der Wolfgang Strengmann-Kuhn führt das hier weiter aus. Die Eclipse hab ich jetzt nicht dabei, aber es ist diese Rede, wo er es sozusagen direkt anführt. Es geht um die Armut zu beseitigen, um eine Kindergrundsicherung, um eine Garantiesicherung, also sowas wie Hartz IV, nur absolut ohne Sanktionen. Es gibt einfach einen Mindestwert an Geld, der hier zur Verfügung steht. Also Garantiesicherung ohne Sanktionen, Garantierente und eine Bürgerversicherung für die medizinischen Sachen, also dass man den Kopf pauschalmäßig und so weiter. Und das ist aber ein gesammelter Antrag, der zum Beispiel eine 200-Euro-Erhöhung von Hartz IV nichtig macht, weil er selber schon in der Garantiesicherung eine entsprechend höhere Linie einzieht. Und das ist in dem Fall aber auch kein Antrag, den irgendwer in Parteitag gestellt hat, sondern den haben die Grünen im Bundestag schon vorgelegt. Also in näher Sicht würde ich mir das bei den Grünen, ihr lest ja eh alle Programme, ich werde mir das bei den Grünen auch nochmal genauer angucken, die 200 Euro Erhöhung, also eine 200 Euro Erhöhung auf den gängigen Hartz-IV-Satz von 370 oder so dann auf 570, der ist da glaube ich im Gesamtgefüge des Programms eingepreist, würde ich jetzt mal so vermuten. Ich habe es aber noch nicht gelesen. Ja aber zumindest, also mich wundert nicht, dass sie Hartz-IV-Satz, ich erhebe mal, weil sie Hartz-IV abschaffen wollen. Sie wollen es ja ersetzen mit dieser Garantiesicherung. In der Ansicht muss man sich die Garantiesicherung dann mal genau anschauen. Aber lassen wir mal offen, der Herr Strengmann-Kuhn argumentiert selbst im Bundestag dürftig, sondern nutzt dann selber erst wieder eine Zwischenfrage, die ihm gewährt wird, während jemand anders spricht, um nochmal diese Armuts-Arithmetik hier darzustellen.
Armut nach der Definition ist 60 Prozent des Medianeinkommens. Wenn es eine untere Grenze durch die Garantiesicherung, durch ein Grundeinkommen, wie auch immer, gestaltet, und die liegt über diesen 60 Prozent, dann ist niemand mehr arm. Denn durch ein Grundeinkommen oder eine Garantiesicherung oder durch ein Garantiesystem des Existenzminimums ändert sich das Medianeinkommen nicht, wenn man das richtig gut macht. Denn das hängt davon ab, wie man es finanziert. Und wenn man es gut finanziert, nämlich von oben nach unten umfasst, dann ändert sich das Medianeinkommen nicht. Idealerweise steigt das Medianeinkommen sogar. Und dann sind die Menschen nicht arm. Das heißt, man kann durch so eine Maßnahme tatsächlich Armut auch überwinden.
Ja, und das will ich echt mal festhalten. Wir könnten in Deutschland Armut einfach abschaffen, indem wir gar nicht so viel Geld bewegen, sondern nur diejenigen, die unter 60 Prozent auf über 60 Prozent heben, also an die 70 Prozent annähern, hätten wir dann nicht die CDU, die dann wieder sagt, naja, aber die unter 60 sind halt die Faulen und die über 60, die arbeiten ja zumindest acht Stunden am Tag. Und das wäre dann unfair und so, das ist ja immer das Argument. Na ja, Joachim Rock vom paritätischen Wohlfahrts, wie heißt es nochmal, Linksverband, also hier. Wohlfahrtsverband. Ja, ihr kennt ihn alle. Ist auch zugeschaltet bei dieser Ausschusssitzung und beschreibt ja auch nochmal, dass der Median gleich bleibt. Jetzt hat der Grüne gerade vorgeschlagen, was man unter dem Median machen könnte. Was wäre denn mit über dem Median? Also kann man das überhaupt beeinflussen? Wie ist unsere Armutsdefinition nicht eigentlich ein bisschen merkwürdig?
Wir messen Armut immer mit dem Median. Der Median läuft völlig leer. In dem Punkt, wenn die, die unter der Mitte sind, verlieren und die, die ober der Mitte sind, immer mehr an Einkommen, dann zusätzlich gewinnen. Wenn Bill Gates jetzt in dieser Runde, in der wir uns hier zusammengefunden haben, zu uns stoßen würde, dann würden die Durchschnittseinkommen der Runde sich erheblich verändern. Der Median bliebe nahezu da, wo er ist. Und wir haben die Situation, dass wir gerade diese Scherenentwicklung haben. Wir haben das an verschiedenen Stellen gehört, auch von Herrn Promberger. Und wenn man die Armutslücke dann mit in Betracht nimmt und sieht, dass immer mehr Menschen einen immer größeren Teil unterhalb dieser Armutsschwelle liegen, dann muss einen das wirklich besorgt machen. Fast ein Schirpel beträgt diese Armutslücke. Das heißt, über 200 Euro liegen durchschnittliche Bezieher darunter. Und das Ausmaß an verdeckter Armut muss einen auch aufrufen, dazu zu fragen, was ist denn mit den sozialpolitischen Leistungen, warum werden die so wenig in Anspruch genommen?
Verdeckt der Armut noch mal ein Sonderproblem. Das kommt dann auf, wenn Armut nicht registriert wird, weil Menschen, die eigentlich Ansprüche haben, die gar nicht stellen, also beim Wohngeld zum Beispiel, ganz drängendes Problem. Aber sein Beispiel ist ja noch mal diese Medienkalkulation. Der Median kann die Schere nicht erfassen zwischen Arm und Reich, die immer weiter auseinandergeht, weil diejenigen, die über Median sind, bleiben über Median, auch wenn sie sich von ihm entfernen. Und die, die durch stagnierende Minilöhne und so weiter unterhalb bleiben und sich von Median entfernen, bleiben halt auch drunter. Und solange niemand über den Median drüberspringt oder drunter fällt, ändert sich halt in dem Verhältnis nichts. Nicht mal dann, wenn ein Milliardär irgendwie dazu kommt, weil ja, es ist halt ein Einer mehr über den Median. Aber unabhängig, dass auch wenn der Durchschnitt sich dann extrem verändern würde und allein die Geldmengen, er redet jetzt von dieser Runde. Wenn du jetzt Milliardär da reinsetzt, da sitzen irgendwie fünf Abgeordnete und fünf Experten, also zehn Leute. Wenn du dann Milliardär daneben setzt, haben die plötzlich durchschnittlich ja jeder oder insgesamt Milliarden mehr Geld. Das war ja vorher gar keine Milliarde. Also mehrere Faktoren vergrößert. Überhaupt das Vermögen, das zu verteilen wäre, in welchen Schlüsseln auch immer. Aber am Median würde sich nichts ändern. Also das, was maßgeblich ist für unsere Armutsdefinition. Deshalb brauchen wir einen Experten. Wir gehen zu CSU, Max Straubinger übernimmt das Rednerpult.
Selbst der Niedriglohn ermöglicht ein höheres Einkommen, wie das staatliche Einkommen sein muss. Und das muss auch weiterhin so sein, weil sonst würde sich keiner mehr anstrengen. Also das muss man doch auch mitsehen. Also von daher können wir stolz sein, auf das er reichte.
Das wär's doch, oder? Wenn mal so ein Grüner am Rednerpult... Ja, wir müssen ja auch das Klima schützen. Dann müssen wir auch mal mitsehen, oder? Brauche ich da noch Argumente?
Ne. Das ist so erstaunlich, oder? Dass die das einfach so hinbekommen und sagen, ja, hier, ich hab kein Argument, aber wir wissen es doch eh alle. Das haben wir ja schon immer so gesagt. Das hat schon der Franz Josef Strauß immer schon so gesehen.
Das ist so Audekenpolitik.
Und sonst brauchen wir ja auch gar nicht arbeiten gehen, wenn sich das gar nicht mehr lohnt, gell?
Ne, wir brauchen auch keine Bildung für die Aufstiegschancen. Anstrengung reicht.
Was sagt noch dieser Bericht?
Dass der soziale Aufstieg möglich ist in unserem Land. Und das bedeutet natürlich, sozialer Aufstieg ist auch mit Anstrengung verbunden. Und nicht mit bedienungslosen Grundeinkommen, wie Sie es präferieren in Ihren Anträgen, wie es die Linke präferiert in ihren Anträgen und auch, ja, fast in abgewandelter Form, auch SPD. Sondern wir müssen die Leistungsbereitschaft der Menschen fördern, um sie damit in die Lage zu versetzen, hervorragenden, ausreichendes Einkommen zu erzielen.
Richtig, ist doch alles ganz einfach. Dann macht er natürlich auch das Argument des Hausbaus. Ist doch blöd, dass die Grünen das jetzt so teuer machen wollen. Und da kann man sich echt überlegen, wir wissen ja, Häuser brauchen erst mal Baumaterial, Grundfläche, dann werden ganz viel Steuern gezahlt, Grunderwerbsteuer und der ganze Kram. Und ja, dann kann man auch noch ein bisschen ans Öko ergewichtet, das hier mal ganz, finde ich auch mittlerweile, albern, wie das von CDU und CSU gemacht wird.
Und das bedeutet auch beim Bauen, dass man nicht zusätzlich noch verteuert unser Bauen.
Wir haben es schon sehr maßend verteuert in den vergangenen Jahren.
Aber wenn man jetzt noch zusätzlich noch eine Photovoltaikanlage vorschreibt, dann kann sich überhaupt kein neuer Böderhaus bauen.
Eine Photovoltaikanlage, die das Haus von jeglicher Energiekostenlast später befreit, kostet nichts im Vergleich.
Und damit ja auch einen souveränen Macht. Man ist nicht mehr abhängig von diesen Konzernen. Das ist ja eigentlich etwas, was den Deutschen sehr liegen sollte. Auch das könnte man sehr gut in den Wahlkampf einbringen. Also diese Unabhängigkeit, das ist ja etwas, was für Leute ganz wichtig ist. Das ist ja auch immer ein Grund, warum Leute das Auto gut finden. Und hier könnte man sagen, ja macht euch mal unabhängig von diesen großen Energiekonzernen.
Ja, und ich habe es im Fernsehpodcast auch schon mal angemerkt, ich würde es gerne mal von einem Experten vorgerechnet haben, ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass so Notarkosten, Grunderwerbssteuer viel, viel, viel höher sind am Ende, als eine Photovoltaikanlage aufs Dach zu setzen. Das scheint mir hier so ein bisschen vorgeschobenes Argument zu sein, weil er woanders nicht sparen will. Na ja, zurück in die Ausschusssitzung.
Lass mich noch eines anfügen. Ich hab nämlich mir gerade erlaubt, Wikipedia zu öffnen und hab mir Max Straubinger mal angesehen, weil ich wissen wollte, was hat er denn so geleistet. Also er kommt aus dem Landwirtschaftlichen, also hat mittlere Reife gemacht. Landwirtschaft war dann beim Wehrdienst und ist dann Landwirtschaftsmeister geworden und ist dann von 84 bis 2019 selbstständige Generalvertreter der Allianz Beratungs- und Vertriebs AG in München gewesen. 1970 aber schon schlauerweise in die Junge Union eingetreten, dann noch bald in die CDU und er sitzt seit 27 Jahren im Bundestag und leistet dort vieles vor allem im Bereich Landwirtschaft, Ernährung, Soziales. Also wir können uns vorstellen, wie leistungsfähig er war für seine Leute, aber jetzt vielleicht nicht fürs Land.
Ja, also wir haben ja die Agrarpolitik hier betrachtet. Der Deal ist ja jetzt gemacht worden die Tage gestern glaube ich oder vorgestern. Es ist komplett entkernt, wie das Lieferkettengesetz ist. Nichts übrig geblieben. 25 Prozent sind noch, also fallen auf diese Öko-Förderung nur bei Öko, kann aber auch in der zweiten Säule sein. Also muss nicht direkt Öko sein, sondern so auf Papier nach Öko aussehen und so. Und da haben sich die Bauern wieder durchgesetzt, ohne Ende dank solcher Typen, die sich unglaublich anstrengen im Agrarausschuss, damit die Gelder da weiter fließen. Naja, die Kinder, die AWO war mit vertreten in der Ausschusssitzung. Und Max Strauninger macht natürlich das Argument mit, ja, dann sollen sie doch ein Haus bauen, wenn ihnen das alles zu teuer ist mit der Miete. Nee, wenn Kinder durch... Also wenn sie arm sind, sind sie einfach arm und dann bleiben sie das auch.
In der Tat sehen wir ein konstant hohes Niveau der Kinderarmut. Jedes fünfte Kind ist hierzulande armungsgefährdet oder arm. Und damit liegt die Armuts, das Armutsrisiko von jungen Menschen eben deutlich über dem Durchschnitt. Und wir wissen aus eigener Forschung, dass Kinderarmut ein zentrales Entwicklungsrisiko ist und häufig mit langfristigen Folgen für materielle, soziale, kulturelle und gesundheitliche Lebenslagen verbunden ist. Und insgesamt gilt, je länger Menschen in Armut leben, desto höher ist eben das Risiko auch im weiteren Lebensverlauf mit Armut in Berührung zu kommen.
Ja, also Armut, wir haben es ja mal unter Einsamkeit. Die Alten sind einsam und die Jungen sind arm. Und so wie der Manfred Spitzer meinte, Einsamkeit ist eine echte physiognomische, also eine somatische Erkrankung. Die schlägt sich einfach nieder. So ist das auch mit Armut. Wer in seiner ganzen Schulzeit arm war, der geht einfach gehandicapt aus seiner Schulzeit raus in den Arbeitsmarkt. Er kann einfach Sachen, auch wenn er sich doll anstrengt, wie Straubinger das will, manche Sachen gelingen dann einfach nicht, weil man einfach arm war.
Und man erwirbt nicht diesen Habitus. Also diesen Habitus, eine Straubinger, oder sonst jemanden, der sagt, jetzt werden wir aber mal, also dieses Hemdsärmelige, dieses Aufpolternde, dass man einfach aus die Welt, und das hier, das seht ihr aber auch, das macht niemand, der aus einer Schicht kommt, der nicht viel Geld vorhanden ist. Also Leute aus der Arbeiterklasse müssen sich das ganz, ganz hart antrainieren. Das ist ja fast ein Wunder, dass so ein Käser wie von der Siemens-Chef, dass der das geschafft hat, sich diesen Habitus da ganz anzutrainieren. Aber das ist normalerweise nicht üblich. Und dadurch sind so Leute dann auch, selbst wenn sie alle Qualifikationen dann irgendwie erworben haben, durch Glück, durch vielleicht ein Stipendium, sind sie oft nicht in der Lage, in diesen Positionen überhaupt einen Platz zu finden. Weil die anderen sich sofort schon erkennen. Die wissen schon, die haben schon in diesen Lebensbereichen die ganze Zeit gelebt, die wissen, welche Restaurants, die wissen, welche Freizeitgestaltungen und all das. Die erkennen sich und sorgen dann dafür, dass sich natürlich diese Familie, die man schon kennt, durchsetzt und dass nicht die anderen rankommen.
Genau, also da feine Sensibilisierung bei allen, die das betrifft. Und es gilt, wie in der Schulsoziologie, entscheidend ist, dass das auf dem Schulhof passiert. So gilt es natürlich auch in Unternehmen. Ich kann ja nachher mal spielen, es gibt noch Clips zum Thema Homeoffice. Warum sind Frauen jetzt benachteiligt? Na ja, weil man im Homeoffice eben nicht am Game teilnehmen kann, das im Bürogebäude halt so gespielt wird vor Rekrutierung. Olaf Groh-Samberg, den wir eben schon gehört haben, stellt ja noch mal da, das ist ein ganz wichtiger Punkt, von dem ich schon mal angesprochen habe. Wir kennen unsere eigene politische, wirtschaftliche Situation eigentlich. Also damit auch nicht unseren politischen Ort so ein bisschen kann man dann daraus Schluss folgern.
Es ist für die Menschen in Deutschland immer schwieriger, ihre eigene Lebenssituation tatsächlich im gesamtgesellschaftlichen Kontext zu bewerten.
Man weiß einfach nicht, bin ich jetzt arm, bin ich reich? Wir kennen ja auch diese spielerischen Sachen von März, ich bin Mittelschicht und so, dass man sich da einfach bewusst nicht positioniert oder sich nicht positionieren kann. Und jetzt diese verdeckte Armut, das ist natürlich ein mega Problem in Deutschland. So wie wir auch diese verdeckte Pflege haben, dass Menschen so einen Antrag stellen, dann kriegen sie so 800 Euro im Monat und dafür bezahlen sie dann, liegen noch 200 Euro drauf, so eine Polin, die das dann irgendwie macht, würde man diese Leute, und das betrifft vier von fünf Pflegefällen in Deutschland, ins ordentliche Pflegesystem einpflegen, uiuiui, dann wäre aber alles Faktor drei und vier teurer und dann wüssten diese Familien gar nicht mehr einen noch aus. Also großes Problem. Und da hat sich ja die Politik bisher drum gedrückt und hat einfach gesagt, selbst wenn es Schwarzarbeit ist, macht man das mit der Pflege zuhause, lasst uns damit unbehelligt. Und das ist dieses Phänomen gibt es auch bei Armut. Das nennt sich verdeckte Armut. Hier die AWO-Vertreter, fühlen es noch mal auf.
Aus Sicht der AWO ist der Grundsicherungsbezug nur begrenzt, aussagekräftig um Altersarmut anzuzeigen. Insbesondere haben wir eine hohe nicht in Anspruchnahme bei der Grundsicherung im Alter und damit ein hohes Maß an verdeckter und verschämter Altersarmut. Viele Menschen nehmen aus Unwissenheit, Scham oder bürokratischen Hürden ihnen zustehende Leistungen nicht in Anspruch. Und wenn sie sich die im Bericht ausgegebene Armutsrisikokvote nach Alter anschauen, kommen sie nach Datenquelle bei den Befragten, die 65 oder älter sind, auf Werte zwischen 13, 8 und 18, 4 Prozent. Die Armutsrisikokvote liegt also deutlich über den Werten des Grundsicherungsbezugs. Und aus Sicht der AWO ist damit eine Verbreitung von Altersarmut realistischer dargestellt.
Verschämte Altersarmut, also Leute, die sich schämen, diese Sachen zu beantragen, beziehungsweise auch ein System, das natürlich so gebaut ist, dass viele Leute Scham empfinden, dass viele Leute vor bürokratischen Hürden stehen, bei denen sie sagen, wie soll ich das alleine machen? Und dann sagen, dann lieber nicht.
Dann kann man sich Behördengang, Amtsstube, Antrag stellen. Da kriegt man schon Angst, Schweiß. Wie groß ist jetzt dieses Problem? Irene Becker stellt hier das mal quantitativ dar.
Dass die verdeckte Armut mit keinem Wort erwähnt wird, finde ich auch ein Manko. Es wird auf die positive Entwicklung bei der Zahl der Grundsicherungsbeziehenden verwiesen. Und das als sehr positive Entwicklung, als Erfolg der Politik dargestellt. Aber dass diese Grundsicherungsquote oder Mindestsicherungsquoten ja nur eine sehr begrenzte Aussagefähigkeit haben, wird im Prinzip verschwiegen. Wir wissen zwar nicht genau, wie hoch die verdeckte Armut ist, aber wir wissen, dass es ein erhebliches Ausmaß hat, dieses Problem. Alle vorliegenden Untersuchungen kommen auf Ergebnisse zwischen 30 und 60 Prozent aller Berechtigten, die ihre Ansprüche nicht wahrnehmen. Wir wissen von einer neuen Studie von Professor Hahn, vom DIW und seinem Team, dass gerade bei den älteren Menschen, also bei der Grundsicherung im Alter, die nicht in Anspruchnahmequote aufgrund verschiedener Modellspezifikationen bei 60 Prozent liegt. Das ist alarmierend und deswegen ist die einfache Interpretation der Grundsicherungsquote oder der Mindestsicherungsquote meines Erachtens nicht hinreichend.
60 Prozent, das hieße ja für jeden, der einen echten Antrag auf, was weiß ich, Wohngeld, Unterstützung hier, Unterstützung da stellt, käme noch mal einer, der das gleiche Recht hätte, aber es nicht in Anspruch nimmt. Das sind, und dafür, dass das gar nicht erwähnt wird im Armutsbericht, ist das ganz schön, soll mal mit rein bilanziert werden jetzt in Wahlkampfzeiten, was man hier für ein Problem hinterlässt.
Das müsste skandalisiert werden.
Katja Kipping hat im Armutsbericht auch noch mal einen Punkt rausgelesen, der ist, wie soll man sagen, erschreckend. Aber wir haben es jetzt mit Corona auch ein bisschen mitbekommen.
Der aktuelle Armuts- und Reichtumsbericht liefert, finde ich, sehr viele beeindruckende Erkenntnisse. Auch unter anderem die Erkenntnis, dass Armut nicht nur eine rein statistische Größe ist, sondern auch ganz konkrete Auswirkungen hat. Die sind an einzelnen herausgearbeitet, was Vereinsamung anbelangt, eine stärkere Belastung von Lehr- und Umweltverschmutzung, Zugang zu Bildung, aber eben auch vielleicht am pegnantesten in der Zahl auf den Punkt gebracht, dass Armut auch bedeutet, dass das Leben deutlich kürzer ausfällt bei Männern um 8, 4 Jahre.
Tja, 8, 4 Jahre bei Männern, bei Frauen auch so sieben oder so. Also wirklich erschreckende Effekte.
Ja, insofern auch nochmal das mit reinnehmen in die Diskussion Risikogruppen schützen und sowas. Also wo wir dann gesagt haben, da müssen wir überall sofort hin. Bei den Alten, das ist das Allerwichtigste, die soziale Frage, die blenden wir erstmal aus. Man verkürzt die ganze Zeit schon deren Leben dadurch, dass man sie in Armut hält und versucht jetzt plötzlich so zu tun, als sei man da immer ganz gerecht vorgegangen und hätte da immer richtig gehabt. Also das ist auch so ein Ding, das hätte jetzt ein guter Ethikrat entsprechend stark machen müssen. Das Argument. Den haben wir ja halt leider nicht.
Den guten Ethikrat. Wir bräuchten ja mal noch einen weiteren Ethikrat, der sich mal um die echten Probleme kümmert und nicht nur bei Lanz antanzt im schicken roten Kleid, das muss man auch mal dazu sagen. Ich zumindest. Zu Achim Rock haben wir ja jetzt schon gehört zum Thema Median. Wie verhält sich das? Gibt es Aussagen über die Schere von Arm und Reich? Nein, nicht, denn der Median teilt nur die Anzahl der Menschen in zwei. Die einen verdienen mehr, die anderen verdienen weniger, als jeweils die andere Seite. Und entsprechend erschreckend ist es dann doch, mal die Zahlen inhaltlich zu hören, wenn man dann überlegt, ja, aber was wird denn da getrennt, wenn man nicht Menschen, sondern deren Vermögen mal nimmt? Also, wie viel Geld haben denn die über den Median und wie viel Geld haben die denn unter den Median? Jetzt kursiert ja immer schon so eine Zahl, die Hälfte der Bevölkerung ist so reich wie die drei reichsten Familien. Das hieße ja schon mal, der Median trennt hier 40 Millionen von drei Menschen. Das wäre dann so, das ist die Median-Rechnung. Es geht also jetzt in dem Falle mal nicht um Einkommen, sondern um Vermögen. Und Joachim Rock zeigt nochmal, wie viel der 100% Vermögen liegt denn jetzt oberhalb des Medians und wie viel Prozent der Vermögen von den 100% liegt denn unterhalb des Medians?
Bisher hat der Amazon-Reichtungsbericht den Titel Reichtungsbericht ja gar nicht verdient gehabt. Da ist das wirklich ein Quantensprung, was da an neuen Erkenntnissen da ist. Und man muss sagen, wenn die Vermögensbehälfte über 99, 5% der Vermögen aus sich vereinigt, dann zeigt das, dass viel zu wenig Umverteilung stattfindet. Und das sind ja auch Vermögen, die häufig dann wieder dazu führen, dass weitere Vermögen oben an der Spitze gebildet werden. In Berlin läuft die Kampagne Deutsche Wohnen und Co. enteignen. Das, was wir erst mal jetzt doch haben, ist doch, dass erst mal eine ganze Menge Mieterinnen und Mieter tatsächlich enteignet werden durch viel zu hohe Mieten und das zu einer steigenden Vermögenskonzentration dann schürt.
Ja, es gibt eine Studie, die habe ich in meinem Freitagstext dann zitiert. Der Name fällt mir gerade nicht ein, aber 2, 5 Billionen Euro war die Umverteilung über Mietzahlungen in den letzten zehn Jahren, seit 2011. Und jetzt schlüsselt er hier auf, ja, also der Median teilt 40 Millionen Deutsche hier, 40 Millionen Deutsche da, aber 99, 5 Prozent des Vermögens hier und 0, 5 Prozent des Vermögens da. Und da sieht man ja so richtig Aussage, so richtig cool ist das nicht als aussagekräftiges Ding irgendwie, um dann daran irgendwas abzuleiten, aber tja.
Aber man kann halt nicht so eine Show wie Wahres für Rares daraus machen. Vielleicht ja doch, also das wäre eigentlich das, was ich, ja, das wäre, du hast ja jetzt eben schon das von Jamie Oliver gezeigt, ich glaube, das wäre eigentlich angebracht. Also wir haben ja diese linken Parteien, die alle Social Media Leute beschäftigen, was aber dann, glaube ich, so verwechselt wird, ist, dass es jetzt nicht darum geht, einfach auch mal so doof zu sein wie Influencer bei TikTok und da auch mal noch die Politikerin reinzuschleifen, die das macht, sondern man müsste eigentlich erkennen, wie kann man die sozialen Medien nutzen, um so was offen zu legen, um vielleicht dann in einem Format wie Wahres für Rares, also in diesem Setting, genau so etwas deutlich zu machen. Das wäre glaube ich sehr gut und das würde eben positivsten Sinne Populismus sein, nämlich einer, der aufklärt, aber offenbar werden diese Chancen alle vertan. Ich verstehe das auch nicht, weil man doch jetzt eigentlich Zeit hat und es ist doch ganz wunderbar. Also da werden doch die Karten ganz neu gemischt, eigentlich dadurch, dass diese Merkel-Ära endet. Ich begreife es nicht.
Ja, man könnte so viel machen, aber nichts passiert. Zwei Clips zum Homeoffice, wir hatten es ja eben angesprochen. Frauen werden auf besondere Weise benachteiligt, denn es sind vor allem Mütter, die zum Homeoffice tendieren, weshalb ihnen dann die Karrierewege abgeschnitten sind. Das habe ich in Deutschland noch nicht so gehört. In Amerika ist das gängig. Also da Scott Galloway redet in seinem Podcast darüber oder hier bei den PBS Nachrichten wird das eben auch thematisiert.
Wenn man die Leute mit einem Studium sieht, die 12 oder unter den Kindern sind, haben Frauen fast 50% höher als Männer die Wahl von einem Heim zu arbeiten.
Aber das ist in Bezug auf die Fakten, die wir in den Jahren sehen, dass wenn man in der Office ist, ist man viel mehr möglich, als wenn man von zu Hause arbeitet. Ja, an alle, die natürlich einfach ins Homeoffice gegangen sind, sich noch bei Hornbach oder so den Garten haben aufmöbeln lassen, zahlt doch mal Entschädigung an diejenigen, die nicht den ganzen Tag zu Hause sitzen können, sondern die fortarbeiten müssen. Also hier einfach mal Entschädigung fordert. Die deutsche Diskussion läuft anders. Wir verabschieden jetzt Eckhard Rehberg. Wir haben ihn hier auch im Podcast schon gehört. Er war derjenige, der Olaf Scholz noch mal mahnte, jetzt aber die Schuldenbremse auch mal einzuhalten. Das geht ja nicht, dass man hier nur in Europa und so. Eckhard Rehberg, das ist ja ganz interessant gerade, Bundestag macht letzte Sitzungswoche und dann kommt aber eine Bundestagswahl, nicht nur eine Sommerpause. Das heißt, viele verabschieden sich und nutzen dann, egal welcher Tagesordnungspunkt, einfach ihre Zeit, um irgendwelche versöhnlichen Worte zu sprechen. Also hören wir hier Eckhard Rehberg, auch um ihn so ein bisschen Tschüss zu sagen. Eckhard Rehberg, aus vielen Richtungen bekannt, größter Verteidiger von Philipp Amthor und so weiter, weil gleicher Wahlkreis, Heimat und so weiter, da Mecklenburg-Vorpommern. Also so die ganz dunkle Seite der CDU sagt hier leise Servus und hat sich dieses Thema ausgesucht für die letzten Worte. Warum auch nicht?
Ohne das ist 1990.
Und es ist ganz wichtig, viele Denkabpausen zu machen. Das sind nicht die wichtig letzten Worte.
Ein friedliches, ein geeintes Europa gegeben hätte, wäre die friedliche Revolution und die Wiedervereinigung nicht möglich gewesen. Und ich würde heute nicht nach 31 Jahren Politik, 15 Jahre Landtag, 16 Jahre Bundestag, meine letzte Rede halten können.
Gut, da überlegt man nochmal neu, ob das alles so gut war.
Die formale Tagesordnung war hier die Reform des Europäischen Stabilitätspaktes, also beispielsweise die ganze Verschuldung der EU und so weiter. Da hat er jetzt ein bisschen auf, ja Europa immer super gut, hat mir auch hier Möglichkeiten gegeben durch die Wende. Er fügt dieses an.
Ich habe noch den Geruch meiner Schwerkraftheizung, wo Braunkohle-Gruß reingeschmissen werden musste, war nichts anderes da, war in der Nase im Jahr 1989. Oder Daten aus der Region Leipzig-Bitterfeld, Umweltbelastung. Oder die Frage, wie gehst du mit den Schwächsten der Gesellschaft um? War jemand mal bei Ihnen 1990, 1991 im Pflegeheim, wo 40 Pflegende eine Toilette, einen Waschbecken hatten, auf einem Flur gelegen haben? Heute gänzlich anders.
So, er hat also alles untergebracht. Die Ärmsten der Gesellschaft, wie geht man mit ihnen um? Die Pflegefälle, die Wände überhaupt. Wahrscheinlich das Größte. Wir finanzieren jetzt mal ordentlich durch, auch wenn Staatsschulden bedeutet, die Billiongrenze ist uns nicht zu hoch. Wir gehen mal richtig all in. Der Tagesordnungspunkt ist hier, der europäische Stabilitätsmechanismus. Hinter ihm sitzt als Sitzungsleiter Wolfgang Schäuble, bekannt als Finanzminister aus der Zeit, als wir Griechenland einmal ausgeplündert haben. Und jetzt hören wir, wie Wolfgang Schäuble noch mal Eckhard Rehberg mit letzten Grußworten zu seinem Platz begleitet.
Sie waren eine starke Stimme für eine nachhaltige Finanz- und Haushaltspolitik. Sie waren ein toller Kollege von allen Fraktionen angesehen. Wir werden sie vermissen und sie haben sich, ob dieses Parlament und den Parlamentswarismus wirklich verdient gemacht. Herzlichen Dank und alle guten Wünsche.
Er lobt ihn noch mal für die Haushaltsdisziplin, während er selber gerade als Feierthema genau die Sachen genannt hat, wo man das Geld rausgeauen hat, wie sonst nichts.
Es ist so unglaublich und Wolfgang Schäuble sitzt da mit 78 Jahren und verabschiedet da mal die Kollegen.
Das ging ja Schlag auf Schlag. Schäuble nur, haben Sie viel Spaß, haben Sie viel Spaß. Sie sind ja noch ein junger Mann. Ciao, machen Sie es gut. Auch Ihnen alles Gute. 50.000 Anekdoten aus 50.000 Jahren Parlamentangehörigkeit, aber er sitzt da immer noch und will das auch nächstes Jahr noch machen.
Ja, ja, hat es ja angekündigt, dass er gerne das weitermachen möchte.
Das ist bescheuert.
Er spricht auch immer langsamer. Also du hörst das wahrscheinlich inzwischen in dreifacher Geschwindigkeit.
Also das ist ja sowieso nur im Bundestag, das trägt man ja gar nicht. Naja, das ist die Thema Armut, da ist einiges zu tun, liebe Wahlkämpfer. Hört euch doch noch mal im Bundestag an, was da so gesagt wurde. Da liegt noch Munition begraben, die könnte man jetzt mal heben und abschießen. Naja, verabschieden wir uns aus dem Bundestag mit jemanden, der sich im Bundestag auch vom Bundestag verabschiedet, nämlich Thomas de Maizière, auch einer dieser Ostler wie Eckhard Rehberg, der dann noch meinte im Westen eine große Nummer werden zu müssen. Du hattest uns ja ganz ausführlich darüber aufgeklärt, dass Bürgerräte und so ja gute Einrichtungen sind, um Wissen zusammenzutragen, aber für die funktionale Entscheidung, die Isolierung der Unterlegenen und wie auch immer der formalen Rechtsetzung schwierig.
Ich glaube, ich hatte mich nicht so höflich ausgedrückt, aber ja.
Du fandest das alles nicht gut. Und da stimmst du überein mit Thomas de Maizière. Der findet jetzt nämlich auch alles nicht gut. Um uns nicht lange mit ihm zu striezen, habe ich mir aber gedacht, wir hören ja ihn nachher nochmal zum Thema Vermögenssteuer, wo er nochmal den Vogel abgeschossen hat und der Vogel ist die FDP, zum Thema Bürgerräte. Denn er hat sich nochmal, er hat nicht das Thema Bürgerräte genommen. Ich habe jetzt auch nicht die Sachen, wo er nochmal richtig draufhaut auf, er nennt es nicht beim Namen, Fridays for Future und so weiter, auf der Straße. Was soll denn ja Quatsch? Kümmern euch um euer Mandat, auch wenn es ein bisschen dauert. Habt Geduld und dann setzt euch ein. Widerspricht komplette rentneruplikanischen Logik, dass nicht genug Jugend da ist, um einen Unterschied zu machen. Aber dieses kleine Plädoyer für die Volkspartei, dass er sich rausgesucht hat, diese kleine Feierstunde, die er machen will, hören wir uns zumindest 20 Sekunden an.
Nachhaltigkeit, meine Damen und Herren, braucht verlässliche und verantwortliche Institutionen, um etwas umzusetzen, also Regierung und Parlament. Also verbessern wir die Volksparteien, aber machen wir sie nicht lächerlich oder schwach. Der Schaden für unsere repräsentative Demokratie wäre auf Dauer erheblich. Wir brauchen starke Volksparteien, und zwar mehrere.
Und so ist es gemeint. Bürgerräte machen die Parlamente schwach, hat er gesagt. Diesen Gegensatz hat er aufgemacht. Und in deren Sicht, das finde ich nicht ganz verkehrt, denn wir sind alle jetzt ein bisschen froh auch, dass Söder die CDU nicht in so einen populistischen Führerhaufen umgewandelt hat, wie Sebastian Kurz die ÖVP. Und das gelang überhaupt nur, ist von Robin Alexander, dem Weltjournalisten, überliefert, weil Wolfgang Schäuble im Kreise dieses Argument machte. Wenn wir jetzt die CDU Söder übergeben, dann bekommen wir die 20 Jahre nicht zurück. Und dann verlieren wir sie auch nicht nur an die CSU, sondern dann verlieren wir sie an den neuen Führerkult, der dank Social Media und so weiter Einzug erhalten hat. Beispiel Sebastian Kurz.
Beispiel Donald Trump mit den Republikanern. Also sowas wäre ja dann das Vorbild gewesen. Trump ist ja auch schon wieder auf Tour in diesem Monat, vor ein paar Tagen gestartet in Ohio, verteilt wieder Capis und sagt nochmal, dass er ja eigentlich der Präsident wäre und dass das alles gelogen ist. Und hat aber jetzt auch ganz klar den Kampf angesagt, all jenen Republikanern, die nicht mehr hinter ihm stehen. Und das sind ja doch einige. Aber ich glaube, dass man das jetzt zwar belächeln kann, aber vielleicht werden wir in zwei Jahren sagen, oh, da hat sich schon so eine Welle angebahnt, die jetzt sehr groß geworden ist. Denn da gibt es das und das jetzt bei den Republikanern. Und die haben mal gerade eine Milliarde locker gemacht, um die sozialen Medien richtig zu bespielen. Und denen passiert jetzt nicht nochmal so was wie mit Twitter. Da wird man einfach verbannt und dann ist man weg. Also da wäre ich sehr vorsichtig, was da, auch wenn es dann Trump vielleicht selbst nicht ist, der das dann am Ende ausführt, dass der sich irgendwann zurückzieht oder einfach zu alt ist. Aber möglicherweise stehen da ja andere in den Startlöchern. Ich weiß nicht, wie so ein Josh Harley dann vielleicht auch nochmal sich neu justiert.
Biden muss jetzt liefern und Joe Manchin muss ihm dabei helfen. Aber das ist ein eigenes Drama.
Tja, wir gehen zu einem anderen Drama über, einem Drama, mit dem wir uns in Deutschland extrem wenig beschäftigen, nämlich mit Indien. Und das ist so verrückt, wenn man sich einmal die Zahlen vergegenwärtigt. Indien hat 1, 4 Milliarden Einwohner. Milliarden, Milliarden, 1, 4 Milliarden Einwohner. Und Indien wächst auch noch viel stärker als China. Also in China haben wir ja jetzt schon noch diese Prognosen, dass das mit der Volkswirtschaft doch sehr schlecht ausgehen könnte, wenn tatsächlich so wenig Nachwuchs da ist. In Indien sieht das noch zumindest anders aus. Und Indien hat auch noch ganz großes Wachstumspotenzial, da sehr viele Menschen in Armut leben. Also 200 Millionen Menschen leben absolute Armut. Wir haben jetzt viel über Armut gesprochen. Was heißt absolute Armut? Also die haben weniger als 1, 25 Dollar pro Tag. Und 70 Prozent dieser Armen leben auf dem Land. Und nur 5 Prozent der Bevölkerung verdient mehr als 10 Dollar pro Tag. Also wir sehen, was da noch für Aufstiege möglich wären. Weniger als 10 Prozent der Arbeitskräfte in der Industrie haben eine Ausbildung. Es gibt nur 11.000 Berufsschulen in Indien, obwohl man 1, 4 Milliarden Menschen hat. 11.000 Berufsschulen im Vergleich. In China gibt es 500.000 Berufsschulen. Also da ist man noch bei einem Entwicklungsland, das sich auf dem Techniksektor in der Spitze macht. Aber da ist noch ganz viel, was noch mitgetragen wird. Kinderarmut, 6 Millionen Kinder, Kinderarbeit. 6 Millionen Kinder müssen arbeiten in Indien. Die sind zwischen 5 und 17 Jahren alt. Dazu kommt, dass es ganz viele Kindesentführungen gibt. Das heißt, diese Kinder werden entführt oder in irgendeiner sehr dubiosen Weise von den Eltern verkauft. Und dann arbeiten die Kinder irgendwo in Städten, wo man sie nicht mehr wiederfinden kann. Das sind lange Wege, die dann dort gemacht werden, damit die Familien nicht irgendwann wieder hingehen können und die Kinder suchen können. Sondern die Kinder sind dann einfach weg. Also 6 Millionen Kinder, dann Gewalt gegen Frauen. Riesenthema in Indien. 37 Prozent der Männer haben, umfassend zufolge, gesagt, ja, ich schlage meine Frau regelmäßig. Ganz problematisch sind auch die Schwiegermütter, die das Leid, das sie erfahren haben, von ihrer Schwiegermutter wieder dann an die Schwiegertochter weitergeben. Prostitution, ganz großes Thema. Frauen werden verschleppt, da es einen Männerüberschuss gibt durch diese Geburtenkontrollen, die es da eine Weile gab, hat man sehr viele Mädchen abgetrieben oder auch Kindstötungen vorgenommen. Dann im Alter von ein paar Monaten. Dadurch hat man einen Männerüberhang, wie in China im Übrigen auch. Das ist also immer dann eine besonders prekäre Lage für die Frauen. Also vieles, vieles liegt im Argen. Warum sollten wir uns jetzt mit China, mit Indien beschäftigen? Wir hatten ja jetzt den Besuch von Joe Biden in Europa. Du hast das ja im Fernsehpodcast ein bisschen mal aufbereitet, wie darüber eigentlich berichtet wird. Und das ist ja auch nur so im Modus hat dem und dem die Hand gegeben. Wie gibt man die Hand? Gute Zeiten, schlechte Zeiten.
Jetzt sind wieder gute Zeiten.
Wir wissen aber auch gar nicht, also alle sind so froh. Europa ist endlich wieder entlastet. Muss ich nicht um die Außenpolitik mehr kümmern. Gott sei Dank die Amerikaner sagen wieder, wie wir es machen sollen. Wunderbar. Und was ja doch immer wieder durchschimmert ist, dass man doch so ein Indo-Pazifisches Abkommen braucht. Man muss Indien jetzt als aufstrebende Volkswirtschaft an sich binden als große regionale Macht dann auch gegenüber China in Stellung bringen. Und ich frage mich dann doch, kann das so vereinbar sein mit den westlichen Werten, die wir jetzt zu China so hochhalten und sagen, hier was ihr mit den Uiguren da macht, das geht ja gar nicht. Aber wie ist es denn eigentlich in Indien? Und es stellt sich heraus, dass Indien kein großes Thema in den deutschen Medien ist. Also man sucht auch dann mal so Podcasts durch oder so. Und natürlich findet man hin und wieder was. Aber es ist extrem wenig zu dieser Bedeutung, die das Land nun mal hat. Wir hören jetzt mal zunächst einen Clip, mehrere Clips aus der Sendung Breitengrade vom BR. Das sind aber Clips von 2017. Also ich musste da schon ins Archiv gehen. Und da erfahren wir erstmal was über Indiens Armut.
Trotz des gigantischen Wirtschaftsaufschwungs betreibt Indien bis heute das größte Nahrungsmittelverteilungsprogramm der Welt. Arme, die sich ausweisen können, bekommen in den sogenannten Ration-Shops jede Woche Reis, Weizen, Brennstoff und Zucker zu einem besonders niedrigen Preis. In der Stadt genauso wie auf dem Land.
Trotzdem bleiben die Statistiken. Mehr als 15% der indischen Bevölkerung sind unterernährt, ebenso vier von zehn indischen Kindern. Für die hindonationalistische Regierung von Premierminister Modi steht der Kampf gegen Unterernährung und Armut nicht besonders weit oben auf der Agenda. Der Kampf gegen die Schattenwirtschaft schon.
Diese Zahlen sind immer wieder beeindruckend. Wir haben ja die Millenniumsziele damals formuliert bekommen. Da wird ja in Bonn bei der UN auch sehr hart dran gearbeitet. Aber die ganzen Ergebnisse hinsichtlich wir holen die Menschen aus der Armut. Allein China ist dafür verantwortlich. Alle anderen Regionen auf der Welt und es beginnt bei Indien haben von den letzten 20 Jahren vermeintlich globaler Entwicklung nicht profitiert, weil es eine allein chinesische Angelegenheit war.
Ganz genau. Wir haben es mit Modi, mit der BGP, mit einer populistischen Partei haben wir es dazu tun, die sehr erfolgreich ist. Und wie ist man heutzutage erfolgreich? Das können wir jetzt denke ich einfach global festhalten für alle Länder dieser Welt, indem man über Identität spricht, indem man Fragen der Religion in den Vordergrund stellt, Herkunft in den Vordergrund stellt. Also den ökonomischen Rahmen versucht gar nicht anzutasten, sondern versucht alles über tribalistische, kulturelle, identitäre Argumentationen zu spielen. Und das hat Modi sehr früh erkannt, in den Nuller Jahren schon. Da hat er ja quasi so ein Bundesland geleitet, Gujarat, bzw. hat in den entscheidenden Momenten weggeschaut, wenn da beispielsweise Pokrome verübt wurden an Muslimen. Und wir bekommen hier auch nochmal von Breiten gerade erklärt, was das jetzt für eine Rolle spielt, dieser Hindu-Nationalismus von Modi.
Modi ernannte einen Hindu-Priester zum Regierungschef. Dieser Mann war vorher vor allem durch eines aufgefallen. Extreme Hetze gegen Muslime. Für jeden ermordeten Hindu müssten 100 Muslime sterben. Das ist einer der Sätze, die Yogi Adityanath, so der Name des Priesters, von sich gegeben hat. Sein zweites Fable gilt der Heiligen Kuh. Und so zögerte Yogi nicht lange. Kaum im Amt, ließ er sämtliche Schlachtereien in Lacknau schließen. Angeblich wegen fehlender Lizenzen. Aber bekannt ist auch, die BJP macht im wahren Sinne des Wortes Politik mit der für Hindus Heiligen Kuh.
Das ist die Strategie, die sehr gut ankommt. Modi ist ja dann auch wiedergewählt worden. Das ist jetzt ein Bericht von 2017, er ist wiedergewählt worden. Und dieser harte antimuslimische Kurs hat sich dann auch noch verstärkt. Wir vergessen ja leicht, dass das Indien, von dem wir heute sprechen, ja noch ganz neu ist. Also das ist jetzt mal gerade 73 Jahre alt. Es gab ja diese Abspaltung Pakistan-Indien. Und es ist ja keineswegs so gewesen, dass dann alle Muslimen nach Pakistan sind, sondern viele sind auch aus wirtschaftlichen Gründen, warum auch immer, weil sie das als Heimat empfunden haben, in Indien geblieben. Und das ist also keine geringe Minderheit, sondern eine sehr große. Und ich werde im Salon ein Buch vorstellen über Indien, und zwar über das Indien so der letzten Jahre, Jahrzehnte, das ganz hervorragend ist. Man findet fast nichts auf Deutsch zu Indien. Also wenn jemand irgend ein tolles Buch empfehlen kann, wirklich die indische Geschichte der letzten 30, 40 Jahre, nicht irgendwie das alte Indien oder so. Das gibt es natürlich in Bildbänden und alles. Aber so die letzten 30 Jahre oder die Modi-Regierung, da gibt es so gut wie nichts. Ich habe ein sehr gutes Buch auf Englisch gefunden. Und das einmal zeigt, wie friedfertig eigentlich dieses Zusammenleben war zwischen Hindus, zwischen den verschiedenen anderen Ethnien, die es noch gibt, und Muslimen. Und diese Verschärfung dieses Konflikts, beziehungsweise auch die Konstruktion dieses Konflikts, die ist noch gar nicht so alt und wird aber von Modi immer weiter verstärkt. Und damit ist er sehr erfolgreich. Und damit einher geht auch so eine Militarisierung der Gesellschaft. Das ist ja auch was, was wir in allen autokratisch geführten Ländern erleben können, dass man solche Paramilitärs hat, Bürger wären und und und. Ähnliches dann auch hier in Indien. Also das heißt, wir müssen jetzt immer nach Indien gucken und jetzt auch mal denken, so Trump, was da so war mit dem Pentagon, nicht mit dem Pentagon, mit dem Kapitol, was wir erleben, wenn irgendwelche Rechtsextremen aufmarschieren und so. Also all diese ganzen westlichen Phänomene können wir jetzt auch immer in Indien sehen.
Das Hindu-nationalistische Programm nennt sich Hindutva, die Vorherrschaft der Hindus. Dieser Begriff fällt immer wieder im Zusammenhang mit Narendra Modi und der BJP. Die Trillerpfeife ertönt, die saffranfarbene Fahne ist gehisst, die jungen Männer nehmen Haltung an, Bambusstöcke wie Gewehre über die Schultern gelegt. Saffran, das ist die Farbe der Hindu-Nationalisten. Ein drahtiger, älterer Herr brüllt Kommandos, dann beginnt die Gruppe mit einer Mischung aus Schattenboxen, militärischem Drill und Aufwärmgymnastik. Das alles mitten in einem öffentlichen Park in Lacknau, der Hauptstadt des Bundesstaats Uttar Pradesh. Die Gruppe gehört dem Rashtriya Swayamsevak Sang-An, kurz RSS. Der Name heißt übersetzt Nationale Freiwilligen Organisation. Der RSS ist der ideologische Überbau von Narendra Modi's BJP.
Ich finde solche Geschichten auch aus China immer wieder interessant. Wir haben uns ja in dieser westlichen Welt, in der wir leben, so eingerichtet, dass wir irgendwie sagen, naja, die Soziologie kam irgendwann auf den Begriff funktionale Differenzierung und so ist es dann halt. Es gibt die Wirtschaft, die Wissenschaft und ein bisschen Politik. Diese Differenzierung dominiert dann aber auch das Geschehen. Damals in Biedelfeld hatten wir einen Soziologielehrer, Rainer Schützeichel, der mittlerweile auch irgendwo Professor geworden ist, der mal das Argument machte, naja, sagt ja keiner, dass funktionale Differenzierung die letzte ist. Wir hatten halt in der vormodernen Zentrum und Peripherie, es gab den Hof und dann rundherum die Ländereien und so weiter. Und vorher die einfach in Segmenten eingeteilt. Also kein Kontakt zwischen, was weiß ich, Eingeborenen in Amerika und Himalaya. Also da gab es keine Weltgesellschaften, nichts. Jetzt haben wir eine Weltgesellschaft, die es eigentlich funktional differenziert. Aber was wäre, wenn noch eine ethnische Differenzierung drüber liegt? Also dass einfach wirklich dann gesagt wird, Muslime kaufen nur bei Muslim. Und da gilt auch die Logik des Geldes und des Profites dann nicht. Man kann keinen Profit mit, in dem Fall dann Chinesen machen. Oder Chinesen sagen, wir sperren die lieber alle weg. Wir brauchen die nicht mal als Konsumenten. Klar, das ist ein Arbeitslager. Da werden sie immer noch als Produzenten so dann eingesetzt. Aber wir verzichten einfach auf Millionen von Menschen. Wir brauchen sie nicht mal als diejenigen, die uns Profit bringen, so irgendwie. Ob das mal irgendwann, also in China, aber jetzt in Indien noch mal umso krasser irgendwie als in China.
Ja, um das mal schon vorweg zu nehmen, der Parakana ist skeptisch, ob man das auf Dauer noch so halten wird können, was Modi vorhat, was andere auch vorhaben. Er wird sagen, am Ende ist die Wirtschaft entscheidend und da muss man dann einfach mit der Zeit gehen. Da kann man mit diesem Ethnischen nicht mehr kommen. Aber momentan ist das erfolgreich und das reicht ja dann auch erstmal, wenn man das noch 10, 15 Jahre vielleicht spielen kann. Nochmal was zu dieser Armee. Wie lange da auch dieser Arm in unsere Geschichte hin zurückreicht?
Der RSS wurde schon in Kolonialzeiten gegründet. Die Organisation hat sich damals an den rechtsextremen Bewegungen in Europa orientiert. Obwohl der RSS dies bestreitet, es war ein Anhänger der Organisation, der den indischen Freiheitshelden Mahatma Gandhi erschossen hat. Die Mitglieder des RSS marschieren durch indische Städte. Sie engagieren sich nach eigenen Angaben als Sozialarbeiter in 50.000 Dörfern. Neulich machten RSS-Mediziner Schlagzeilen, weil sie behaupteten, durch die alte Heilkunst des Ayurveda hellhäutige große Menschen züchten zu können.
Oh man, Riesenphänomen. Und das ist ja etwas, was wir hier in Deutschland auch erleben, dass Rechtsextreme immer stärker erkennen, ja, es ist ja alles so zerrüttet. Es funktionieren die Institutionen nicht mehr. Es sind viele Familien, Kinder und alles allein gelassen. Lass uns doch mal aufs Land gehen, in die Städte gehen, die so halb verwaist sind. Wenn wir uns da ansiedeln, wenn wir dort Freizeitgestaltung bieten und alles, dann können wir die sehr gut auf unsere Seite ziehen und die Leute erkennen dann auch, dass wir gar nicht nur böse sind, sondern wir sorgen dafür, dass endlich wieder ein Leben in der Gemeinschaft, im Dorf möglich ist. Und das wird hier auch gemacht. Bis hin dann dazu, dass ja auch man in rechtsextremen Kreisen in Deutschland beobachten kann, dass man wieder alte Rassen züchten will, dann nicht Menschenrassen, sondern man sagt, irgendein besonderes Wildschwein oder so, das gibt es ja eigentlich gar nicht mehr. Und das sorgen wir jetzt mal dafür, dass da wieder das im Wald stattfinden kann. Und irgendwelche Pflanzen werden gezüchtet, die man noch aus alten Handbüchern des 19. Jahrhunderts hat. All solche Dinge, also wir sehen hier, wie parallel hier auch unsere Geschichten verlaufen.
Ja, wenn du keinen sich kümmernden Staat im Max-Weber-Sinn hast, springt irgendwer in die Lücke rein. Und das ist dann egal, ob das die Hamas dort oder die DVU oder die Republikaner hier sind. Oder eben da in Indien, die jeweiligen Gruppen.
Ja, die Filmwirtschaft spielt ja eine enorme Rolle in Indien. Das wird niemanden wundern, der schon mal von Bollywood gehört hat. In Bollywood werden 800 Filme pro Jahr produziert. Kino ist das Freizeitvergnügen Nummer eins. Und jeden Tag gibt es 15 Millionen Kinobesucher. Das heißt, das ist auch noch tendenzsteigend. Denn wir haben ja gerade gehört, wie viele Leute noch in Armut leben. Das heißt, da sind viele, die können sich gar nicht den Kinobesuch leisten. Aber vielleicht sehr bald schon. Das heißt, das ist ein ganz wichtiger Filmmarkt, der aber auch ganz stark von den Eigenerzeugnissen geprägt ist. Nicht so stark von Hollywood. Und deshalb ist natürlich auch die Frage, was darf denn da eigentlich im Kino gezeigt werden? Und dann habe ich einen Podcast gehört von Indian Express. Das ist die englischsprachige große Zeitung in Indien. Die haben auch einen Podcast und haben sich darüber unterhalten, dass es jetzt vor wenigen Tagen, Wochen ein neues Zensurgesetz gibt zum Film. Und da erfahren wir jetzt, was damit möglich ist.
Okay, so es gibt ein paar Dinge, die man verstehen kann. Wie es jetzt ist, braucht nicht jeder Film, der in diesem Land gemacht wird, eine Filmzertifizierung. Okay, jetzt sprechen wir über das Cinematograph-Ammendement-Bild 2021. Aber wieder, durch die Vorbereitung des Zentrales, hat die Zertifikation in den vergangenen Jahren bereits Kuts gesucht. Wenn ein Film zertifiziert wird, gibt es meist keine Änderungen, aber die Regierung will das jetzt ändern. Jetzt kann die Regierung es durch quasi-legale Kräfte.
Auf die Filme zeigen. Dann kann nachträglich Film zensiert werden, was natürlich im Digitalen auch sehr gut möglich ist, dass einfach Dinge nachträglich rausgenommen werden. Also man versucht auch damit jetzt der Regierung nochmal ganz viel Zensurkraft zu geben. Denn man weiß ja gar nicht, ob man dem Zensor da, haben die das richtig entschieden und dann haben plötzlich Politiker oder irgendwelche Verbände nochmal bedenken und dann wird nochmal nachzensiert. Und so kann man vielleicht auch nochmal durch die Filmgeschichte durchmarschieren. Also schon immer hat man Indien stark zensiert. Zum Beispiel sind auch Woody Allen-Filme schon nicht dort gelaufen, weil Woody Allen sich weigerte, alle Szenen rauszuschneiden, in denen geraucht wird oder so. Aber das ist jetzt nochmal eine neue Dimension. Also liebe Journalisten der Welt, wenn ihr mal über Cancel Culture schreiben wollt, dann guckt doch mal nach Indien, macht das da mal und guckt nicht, ob irgendwo in einem Uniseminar mal jemand was gesagt hat, sondern hier ist tatsächlich was zu beobachten.
Vor allem unter der Maßgabe, sich schon den bestehenden Katalog sich noch mal anzugucken. Mir fiel das auch letztens auf bei Spotify z.B. wird ja in deiner Liste, wenn man das Hälkchen entsprechend setzt, Lieder, die aus dem Katalog wieder rausfallen, ausgekraut. Als würde jemand, also da ist dann irgendein Vertrag ausgelaufen mit irgendeinem Label oder so und plötzlich sind die nicht mehr über Spotify verfügbar, stehen aber noch in deiner Liste. Und es ist ja so, also bei meiner Elterngeneration wäre das ja nicht möglich gewesen einfach nach Hause zu gehen und neu zu sortieren. Aber ich kriege ja auch immer diese E-Mails, wo drin steht, was neu auf Netflix kommt. In diesem Monat stehen da mal so 80 Filme. Und es wird ja auch aussortiert wieder durch irgendwas lief aus, dann gibt es doch plötzlich Disney plus und jetzt laufen da keine Disney Filme mehr und so. Nur darüber kriege ich ja nicht so richtig Aufklärung. Da muss ich dann in irgendwelchen Blogs lesen, welche Serien jetzt nicht mehr bei Netflix kommen. Und so kann man natürlich ganz graduell auch in die Filme eingreifen. Also du kannst ja wirklich im Nachhinein einfach den Katalog anschauen und sagen, ja, hier diese Szenen, dieses und jenes, Sprichwörter oder so. Da fliegen einfach die Dialoge raus und zack hat man für alle das sortiert, weil die Filme hat ja keiner mehr zu Hause. Wir rufen die alle nur noch ab.
Ist jetzt zum Teil auch schon passiert. Also es gab ja das auch schon in Amerika, dass man Sachen rausgeschnitten hat oder dass man sagte, da muss dann gekürzt werden. Da gab es auch ein paar erbitterte Diskussionen. Also ich kann nur jedem empfehlen, DVDs sind immer noch die sicherste Variante, also den Datenträger zu besitzen. Denn ich bin mir da nicht so sicher, wohin das da manchmal noch, es gibt da schon ein paar verrückte Kulturkämpfer, die unterwegs sind. Aber jetzt muss ich dich erst mal fragen, was hast du dann am 21. dieses Monats gemacht?
Am 21. Juni?
Ja.
Also das war ein Montag, das weiß ich, weil Boris Johnson da Freedom Day feiern wollte, was dann ausgefallen ist.
Du bist, du müsstest doch einen anderen Tag feiern, den Yoga-Tag, den Internationalen Yoga-Tag. Der war am 21. Da hättest du mit Modi zusammen das feiern können, denn Modi hat das etabliert, diesen Tag, um auch das internationale Ansehen Indiens voranzubringen. Und Indien feiert diesen Yoga-Tag dann mit Zehntausenden jetzt natürlich alles ein bisschen eingeschränkt durch das Wüten der Delta-Variante. Aber Modi hat es sich nicht nehmen lassen, dann auch eine Ansprache zu halten. Das gibt dann in den Fernsehsendern, kann man dann bei YouTube auch sehen, große Szenarien, in denen irgendwelche Yoga-Lehrer, was weiß ich, alles vollführen. Aber auch Modi hat dann eine Ansprache gehalten. Und das sollten wir uns jetzt mal ideologiekritisch genau anhören, was er da sagt. Er spricht dann immer einen Teil auch auf Englisch. Und wir starten mal mit einem Clip.
Ja, Hanna weiß doch, dass sie früh anfangen muss zu planen. Es steckt doch alles in ihr drin.
Exakt. Es ist exakt diese Ideologie, die natürlich hier im Westen auch wahnsinnig gut ankommt und normalerweise, wenn nicht gerade Corona ist, gibt es dann auch überall Events in New York, in Berlin und sonst wo und das wird hier adressiert und das ist auch das besonders perfide eigentlich an dieser Regierung, dass sie total auf diesem Trip ist. Jeder soll mal Verantwortung übernehmen. Wir zerschlagen den Sozialstand. Wir kümmern uns nicht um Impfungen, kümmern uns nicht um Masken und all diese Dinge, aber jeder hat doch die Kraft in sich und kann das auch aus sich heraus schöpfen.
Also ich finde das auch erstaunlich, wie Yoga hier in Europa, in Deutschland, hier in Frankfurt, wo ich es mitbekomme, ein bisschen überhöht wird. Es gibt zum einen einfach Apps, in denen wird dir so Yoga vorgemacht, dann machst du es halt nach. Nudelt dann irgendeine Musik und gut ist. Diese Yogakurse, auch wenn was so in Fitnessstudios angeboten wird, die gehen doch immer einher mit so gewissen Predigten. Also da muss immer gelabert werden. Die Trainer, die labert immer die ganze Zeit und die machen genau diesen Scheiß, wo du immer denkst, naja, ich dachte Yoga ist gut für den Rücken und ein bisschen für die Beine und den so ein bisschen die Arme. Nee, das ist dann immer gleich so eine psychisch-kognativ-seelische Veranstaltung da, wo du echt denkst die ganze Zeit, können wir es auch ohne das Gequatsche machen? Also es ist wirklich verrückt inwieweit Yoga da ist.
Ja und Modi setzt noch einen drauf. Also wir haben jetzt noch mal vor Augen, das ist ein medizinisches Desaster. Hunderttausende sterben, bekommen keine Lungengeräte, die sie jetzt eigentlich brauchen, keine Beatmungsgeräte. Wir haben jetzt eine Katastrophe in diesem Land und Modi sagt folgendes.
Wir alle beten für einanderes Wohl. Ich bin mir sicher, dass Yoga weiter spielen wird.
Ja, man denkt immer, in Deutschland läuft Corona-Politik schlecht. Dann guckt man nach England und sieht, es läuft hier nicht schlecht. Dann guckt man nach Amerika und denkt, in England ging es ja auch noch so einigermaßen. Dann guckt man nach China, nach Indien und denkt sich, ne, auch in Amerika lief es nicht wirklich schlecht. Denn das ist wirklich eine Katastrophe, und dass sich der Chefin da noch so hinstellt und irgendwas von Yoga erzählt, ist wirklich absurd.
Öffentliche Gesundheitsvorsorge braucht man eigentlich nicht, wenn man Yoga hat, genauso gut, es ist skandalös. Arte hat ein Porträt herausgebracht, eine Doku über Modi, 80 Minuten lang, sehr sehenswert. Und wir hören mal hier einen Ausschnitt zum Thema Yoga.
Während die politischen Gegner zu Hause seine teure hinduistische Bekehrungskampagne anprangern, inszeniert sich Modi im Ausland als globaler Guru mit Millionen Anhängern, die sich praktisch gleichzeitig überall auf der Welt versammeln. In Berlin, Kabul, New York, Paris, Sydney. Eine gigantische Werbeaktion mit internationaler Strahlkraft.
Wenn er im Ausland ist, besonders im westlichen Ausland, gibt er sich gern als demokratischer Führer, der die Last der Welt auf seinen Schultern trägt.
Yoga ist Teil eines Gesamtprojekts. Indem wir es in die Welt tragen, stärken wir Indiens Selbstbewusstsein. Das ist die Idee dahinter.
Verstehe ich ehrlich gesagt, wenn du eine Bewegung hast, setze ich doch an ihre Spitze und diese Yoga-Bewegung bietet sich ja wirklich an, da sie guru-mäßig einfach anzuführen.
Ja, er hat ja selbst zurückgezogen gelebt, er hat ja früh seine Eltern dann verlassen, hat dann im Gebirge gelebt, meditiert, hat sich dann auch auf diesem Weg dann so hapekerkelingmäßig, ich bin dann mal weg, nochmal begleiten lassen von den Kameras, sitzt dann da meditierend in irgendeiner Höhle. Also er hat dieses Gurehafte ganz stark, hat ja auch keine Frau, also er dient nur dem Land, will er uns damit sagen. Und das ist etwas, was extrem wirkt, das ist diese charismatische Herrschaft, wo wir ja schon bei Max Weber sind, kann man das auch nochmal hier mit ins Spiel bringen. Und es wundert dann auch nicht, dass es da auch eine gewisse Parallele zum Nationalsozialismus gibt. Und zwar ist da ein Buch erschienen mit dem provokanten Titel Jogi Hitler. Und das wurde vorgestellt, ich habe es nicht gelesen, aber es wurde vorgestellt im Deutschlandfunk. Und da hören wir mal ganz kurz rein.
Der Titel des neuen Buches von Matthias Tietke irritiert Jogi Hitler. Und das soll er auch. Tietke ist selbst Yoga-Lehrer. Er will aufzeigen, wie es nationalsozialistischen Ideologen gelungen ist, die zentralen, einfühlsamen wie friedliebenden Seiten der Yoga-Lehre einfach zu ignorieren. Der Yoga wurde der NS-Ideologie einseitig einverleibt. Und weil es dazu kaum Widerspruch gab, wurde selbst Adolf Hitler zum Yogi.
Durchaus ist er als Yogi stilisiert worden. Nicht von Yogakreisen, sondern im völkischen Beobachter.
Hm, dann müssen wir alle noch mal bei Joachim Fest nachlesen, ob das da auch noch drin steht. Das ist ja erstaunlich. Ich hätte jetzt gedacht, das ist jetzt eine Hitler-Anlehnung, aber es geht schon um das aktuelle Indien.
Nee, nee.
Also es ist um Bodhi geht, aber dass wirklich Hitler selbst nochmal auch...
Eva Braun hat auch Yoga gemacht. Gibt es auch Videoaufnahmen? Wird in diesem Beitrag die zehn Minuten, kann man sich gut anhören, mal ansehen und vielleicht auch das Buch lesen.
Die eine Nähe zum Himalaya und diese ganzen Expeditionen, die die gemacht haben, um den Ursprungsaria irgendwo da zu finden und so.
Was ist denn eigentlich Bodhis Ziel in dieser Artedoku, versucht man das mal auf den Punkt zu bringen?
Das Ziel ist die Erschaffung einer indischen Nation, in der die Hindus dominieren und alle Minderheiten bestenfalls Bürger zweiter Klasse sind. Oder besser noch, aus der Politik ausgeschlossen werden. Das ist die Ideologie, an die auch Premierminister Modi glaubt und der er angehört.
Und diese Ideologie setzt Modi seit seiner Wiederwahl im Mai 2019 in die Tat um. Eine Art nationaler Rachefeldzug, um Indien den Hindus zurückzugeben. Dafür marschiert er zunächst in den autonomen Teil von Kashmir ein, einer vorwiegend muslimischen Region, um die sich Indien und Pakistan seit Jahren streiten.
Ja, da gab es ja dann Schlägerei, weil keiner sich getraut hat, zur Waffe zu greifen und sich geprügelt hat irgendwie.
Ja, mit Hacke und Beil, das ist ganz archaisch, was da vor sich geht. Und diese Politik gegen Muslime und auch die Gewalt gegen Muslime, die hat jetzt in den vergangenen 20 Jahren ganz stark zugenommen. Das ist auch Thema dieses Indian-Buchs, das ich vorstellen will, dass es eigentlich mal so ein friedliches Zusammenleben gab und dann aber diese Leute, von denen da die Rede ist, sich dann auch in gewisser Weise radikalisieren und dann auch plötzlich diese Bedrohungen merken, also die Muslime, die die Bedrohungen merken, die einfach angegriffen werden, die ermordet werden. Und Modi hat sich da immer so verhalten, dass er nicht genau zu so Gewalttaten aufgerufen hat, hat aber immer wieder mit so Leuten faktiert und hat auch in den rechten Momenten immer solche Reden gehalten, die eine gewisse Offenheit dann zulassen, sodass die das schon so verstehen, wie wir das bei Trump auch erlebt haben. Natürlich sagt er nicht jetzt los zum Kapitol, macht sie platt, aber man hält halt eine Rede, bei der eigentlich jedem klar ist, okay, wir können also los.
Genau, Trump und die Proud Boys und Putin hat das auch, das ist auch so eine Rocker-Gang, die grauen Wölfe oder sowas, die eben da immer sozusagen über Bande gespielt unterstützen bei irgendwelchen Auftritten und so.
Ja, und das interessante ist jetzt, wir sollen als Indien, Indien als großen Partner begreifen. Das sind jetzt die, die uns schützen vor China und wir müssten uns mal fragen, wollen wir das wirklich? Aber offenbar ist das so. Also hier wird auch nochmal in der Art Doku darauf hingewiesen, dass es dann in Nullerjahren schon solche Auswüchse gab und dass es dann auch später diesen Hass gegen Muslime gab und wie reagiert eigentlich dann die internationale Gemeinschaft darauf? Da gab es ja dann auch ganz, ganz klare Reden, die gesagt haben, hier müsst ihr eingreifen, das geht nicht mehr, was hier eigentlich passiert. Hier wird ganz großes Leid angetan, aber, so heißt es dann der Doku.
Doch die internationale Gemeinschaft schweigt. Sie hat andere Pläne für Modi's Indien. Im August 2019, mitten in der Kashmir-Krise, treffen sich die führenden Industrienationen im französischen Biarritz zum G7-Gipfel und rollen dem indischen Staatschef den roten Teppich aus. Die Gelegenheit für Modi, sein pazifistisches Image, das er auf der Weltbühne pflegt und seine Umarmungs-Diplomatie zu perfektionieren.
Bei Auslandsbesuchen spielt er den neuen Gandhi.
Ja, da kommt er immer ganz in weiß gekleidet, lässt sich da irgendwelche Blumen hinwerfen und so. Es gibt ja auch diesen Image-Film, der dann selbst in Indern zu blöd war, der dann selbst in Indien verboten wurde, weil er dieses Bild des Modi, der Einsamen und so weiter durch die Berge zieht, um Indien zu befreien, dann doch irgendwie nicht so richtig passte zur Realität.
Wenn wir nochmal nach den Parallelen suchen, Trump und Modi, wir wissen, Trump war der Social-Media-Star. Eigentlich muss man sagen, er hat es Modi nur nachgemacht.
Er ist jemand, der sehr früh verstanden hat, dass Wahlen in den Medien, den sozialen Medien gewonnen werden.
Daher besetzte er den öffentlichen Raum.
Modi begeistert sich für neue Technologien, die es ihm ermöglichen, direkt mit den Bürgern zu kommunizieren. So tritt er als erster Politiker der Welt per Hologramm auf.
Er ließ Holographietechnik aus England importieren, zu einem horrenden Preis. Und die Leute waren wie verzaubert.
Und bemerkenswert war, mit welcher Leichtigkeit er das machte.
Er sagte, ihr da im Süden, am Indischen Ozean, ich sehe euch winken, hallo, wie geht's euch?
Und dann sagte er was in ihrer Sprache. Ich kann sogar die Menschen in Kashmir sehen.
Und er tat so, als winke er den Leuten in Kashmir zu.
Er ist ein brillanter Performer. Ich bin sicher, Modi hat Schauspielunterricht genommen.
Na, warum nicht? Wir denken an unser Buch, das wir besprochen haben von Bruno Marquez. Da geht es ja um diese Showrepublik, oder eine Shownation. Die finden wir offenbar nicht nur in den USA, sondern die finden wir gleichermaßen in Indien. Und Modi ist da der perfekte Schauspieler, der das auch seit Jahr und Tage eintrainiert hat, wie Trump eigentlich seine Ausbildung durch Reality-TV genossen hat.
Also dieser Hologramm hat ja Mélenchon, der in Frankreich beim letzten Präsidentschaftswahl der Mitmischung wollte, auch schon genutzt, nur eben wirklich um eine Rede zu amplifizieren, nicht um dann wieder so eine Schose, ich bin wirklich hier und so, das klang ja eben so anders. Ja, ja, genau. Ich bin echt hier bei euch und so, ich sehe euch. Und da sieht man wieder, wie krass die Inder da immer übertreiben. Aber das ist halt auch so Bollywood, das scheint da so Sehgewohnheit zu sein. Wenn man so Bollywood-Filmen guckt, ist es ja doch irgendwie so ein bisschen, man merkt dann, das ist nicht Hollywood, das passt auch irgendwie nicht zu uns, zu unseren Sehgewohnheiten.
Genau, das ist auch ganz schlecht adaptierbar. Also es gibt zwar auch Fan-Clubs hier für Bollywood, aber nie sieht man wirklich einen Bollywood-Film, der einen normalen Kinostart hat. Also diese ganzen Bollywood-Stars kennen wir alle nicht. Und das ist mal dann ein bisschen auf RTL 2 gelaufen. Man hat das, glaube ich, versucht, hier auch diese Bollywood-Welle in Gang zu setzen. Aber das ist nicht wirklich gelungen. Also das ist einfach nur ein ganz kleiner Teil, der sich dafür interessiert.
Das ist ganz interessant. Nach unseren Sehgewohnheiten war mein Eindruck immer, kennste einen Film, kennste alle. So wie man immer sagt, die Chinesen sehen alle gleich aus. So war das bei den Filmen auch. Das war halt immer dieses Zeitlupen musikalisch übertriebene irgendwie. Und dann war völlig egal, was da passiert. Es ging halt immer um Mann und Frau und schöne Kleider.
Aber wie wir wissen, wenn man dann alle deutschen Gesichter mal so nebeneinander hält, dann kann man das genauso sagen. Und wenn man die deutschen Komödien nebeneinander hält, dann kann man die auch nicht auseinanderhalten. Also das ist tatsächlich so. Das sind halt eigene Klischees, die sich da etabliert haben, während Hollywood Klischees andere sind. Und das sind Fragen der Sehgewohnheiten und sicherlich auch der Ausdauer, da diese Filme ja auch extrem lang dauern. Und sehr, sehr viel gesungen wird, auch viel getanzt wird, weil man kein Sex zeigen darf. Na ja, noch mal zu den sozialen Medien. Was hat Modi da gemacht?
2014 mitten im Wahlkampf um das höchste Amt in Indien nutzt Modi verstärkt die sozialen Netzwerke. Da ihm die Massenmedien zu kritisch sind, scharrt er eine Armee von Trollen hinter sich, die über sein Image im Internet wachen.
Ja, fast schon alte Schule, ne?
2014 hat er das gemacht. 2014 hat er das gemacht.
Ah ja, dann ist er der Pionier.
Da ist er der Pionier.
Jetzt ist es alte Schule.
Und dann hat er was gemacht, was er aber eigentlich so Obama jetzt nachgemacht hat. Nämlich, wir haben ja schon mal über diese Granularisierung, wie Kuklik das nennt, der Wähler gesprochen, dass man versucht, die Wähler direkt zu erreichen. Was ähnliches hat auch Modi gemacht.
Er beschäftigte ein Heer extrem talentierter und technologisch versierter Leute im ganzen Land, die eine Datenbank aufbauten und wussten, wie man Wähler erreichte.
Hm, das auch 2014 im Wahlkampf?
Also er hat das echt extrem begriffen. Das hat er so, wenn man ihn ja so sieht und auch reden hört und diesen ganzen Habitus bemerkt, dann denkt man eigentlich gut, das ist ja, da weiß er, da ist jemand nicht in der Gegenwart angekommen, aber der ist zehnmal mehr in der Gegenwart angekommen als Armin Laschet oder so. Davon kann man ausgehen, der hat schon verstanden, wie es läuft. Warum ist der eigentlich so? Ist es überhaupt noch so ideologisch eigentlich begründet? Kann man das wirklich glauben mit dem Yoga? Ist der also ein überzeugter Ideologe? Und da zweifelt die Arte Doku dran.
Er ist ein Ideologe, aber noch wichtiger, er ist ein Narzisst. Er stellt sich gerne dar, glaubt an sich, sieht sich selbst als Erfüller des Schicksals.
Eine typische Wahlkampagne von Narendra Modi setzt auf Emotionen, auf Bilder und vermeidet jede konkrete politische Aussage.
Ja, das muss man echt in diesem Bollywood-Sägewohnheitsding alles mal, für uns natürlich mega übertrieben und so.
Ja, obwohl wir ja diese Emotionalisierung bei der Wahl eben ja auch vertreten haben. Also das haben wir auch, das wird dann nur mit anderen stilistischen Mitteln gemacht. Ja, wir setzen halt andere Punkte, erzählen Geschichten ein bisschen anders, nehmen ein bisschen Farbe raus, ein bisschen gedämpftere Musik vielleicht, nicht ganz so schrill, aber eigentlich sehr ähnlich. Und dann auch die Tatsache, dass wir es eigentlich mit einem Narzisten zu tun haben, der eigentlich für gar nichts steht, nur hat sich jetzt für ihn dieses Rezept als erfolgreich erwiesen. Das ist was, was wir bei Putin oder Trump gleichermaßen sehen können. Also Putin hat ja auch in dem Sinne keine wirkliche Agende. Also man hat nicht den Eindruck, man hat es mit diesem Ideologen zu tun, der diese Idee von Russland hat, sondern das hat sich mit ihm glaube ich herausgebildet, dass das ganz gut funktioniert, wenn er es auf diese Weise spielt und wenn er von anderen Dingen dann einfach mal absieht bzw. diese ausblendet. Also z.B. die extreme ethnische Pluralität von Russland. Also wenn er die einmal einbedenken würde, dann würde er vielleicht auch ins Krübeln kommen, was seinen Nationalismus anbelangt.
Gerhard Schröder war ja ein Kanzler, der sich auch so Filme hat machen lassen oder so Fotos. Ich weiß nicht, Harald Schmidt hat sich mal über ein Bild nicht nur lustig gemacht, sondern er fand es auch wirklich faszinierend, wie Schröder im Abendlicht seiner Schreibtischlampe so auf dem Kopfstützen grübelte und dann irgendwelche Dokumente arbeitete. Und Harald Schmidt hat das interpretiert. Hier lastet das deutsche Schicksal auf den Schultern eines Mannes und für uns macht er das. Und gleichzeitig hat man ja Gerd Schröder immer so als Acker, Mann vom Volke, spielte Fußball, kam dann irgendwie die Politik über Engagement, hat sich dann als Juso und so weiter da verdient gemacht und dann zack, war plötzlich da und wir haben ihn als Staatsmann ja auch lange gebraucht. Und mit Helmut Kohl, das war ja eher alles nichts. Und damals auch vielleicht noch zu den Wahlkampf davor mit Rudolf Scharping und so. Dieses in Zeitlupe gehen wir den Säulengang entlang, links der eine und Lafontaine rechts und so. Und das ist ja komplett verschwunden aus unserer Wahlkampfzeit jetzt. Und Putin kommt ja auch noch aus dieser Zeit. Also Putin hat ja mit Gerhard Schröder damals sozusagen die Macht übernommen. Und da könnte man ja auch so Vermutungen anstellen, angenommen Gerhard Schröder wäre nicht von Angela Merkel abgelöst worden, sondern hätte das dieses Prinzip, so macht man Wahlkampf, so stellt man seine Regierungstätigkeit da einfach fortgeführt und uns in so eine Sehgewohnheit reingedrängt, die Merkel jetzt wieder rausgedrängt hat. Was wäre dann hier in Deutschland jetzt los? Was würden wir jetzt für einen Wahlkampf führen, wenn wir uns umgewöhnt hätten, was diese Herangehensweise, dann wäre uns das vielleicht wieder näher. Aber jetzt sind wir wirklich meilenweit weg von so einem Modi-Wahlkampf.
Ganz klar, Schröder war bei GZSZ, hatte dort einen Auftritt. Ja, er war sehr, sehr stark unterwegs, in der Bund permanent präsent, mit den Zigarren, mit den Brioni-Anzügen. Das ist gut möglich, also Merkel war Antishow. Mehr geht gar nicht. Und da ist die Frage, wie das jetzt sich nochmal neu verhalten wird mit Armin Laschet. Also er wird so eine Show nicht machen können. Das wird auf eine andere Weise laufen. Ja, ganz klar. Wir hören zum Schluss noch einen Clip aus dem SWR 2 Forum. Da wurde über den beiden Besuch diskutiert. Darum soll es aber gar nicht gehen, sondern Christoph von Marschall vom Tagesspiegel macht hier noch eine Äußerung zu Indien und dieser Frage. Sind das jetzt unsere strategischen Partner?
Um nur noch mal auf diese Frage vorhin zu die Zehn zurückzukommen. Indien mit seinem Hindu-Nationalismus, das ist ja ein fast faschistisches Regime heute. Und die sollen sozusagen an unserer Seite Demokratie und Grundwerte repräsentieren. Brasilien mit seinem jetzigen Präsidenten. Diese Konzepte funktionieren nicht. Wir können überlegen, wo wir Interessenskoalitionen mit denen schmieden können. Aber letzten Endes geht es im Moment um wirklich eine ganz grundsätzliche Frage. Wir müssen uns überlegen, brauchen wir eine Wiederbelebung des Westens?
Hm, brauchen wir die?
Die sowieso.
Gelingt uns die.
Genau.
Gelingt sie uns. Eine Wiederbelebung wäre nicht schlecht.
Wir lassen das einfach mal so offen. Also fest steht, glaube ich, dass man in eine kalte Kriegslogik nicht umschwenken kann, weil die Verhältnisse anders sind, weil alles einfach viel zu sehr voneinander abhängt. Man kann nicht mehr irgendwas richtig isolieren. Man sieht das schon, wenn es nur mal darum geht, TikTok aus dem Land zu verdrängen, was das dann eigentlich alles bedeutet. Da hängt ein Riesens Ratten Schwanz mit dran. Das war mit Russland einfacher, mit der Sowjetunion einfacher. Das ist einfach nicht mehr denkbar. Und wahrscheinlich muss man bei diesem Multilateralismus sicherlich in höherem Maße auch tatsächlich westliche Werte vertreten bzw. aufpassen, dass man sich nicht schuldig macht oder nicht noch mehr schuldig macht. Das heißt, man kann nicht den diktieren, wie die jetzt zu regieren haben bzw. die sind ja auch sehr häufig gewählt. Also bei Indien haben wir es schon mit einer funktionierenden Demokratie zu tun. Also das ist ja jetzt nicht vergleichbar mit China, aber der ist nun mal jetzt gewählt. In Brasilien ist auch jemand gewählt worden, aus Gründen, die wir nicht nachvollziehen können, aber es ist nun mal so. Insofern können wir aber da nicht in, wie Karl Schmid sagen würde, raumfremde Mächte einschreiten. Wollen wir jetzt überall Krieg anzetteln. Ich glaube, man sollte sich ein bisschen frei machen, auch von diesem Menschenrechtssprech, den Grüne sehr oft haben. Denn dann wird nämlich genau so ein Doppelstandard aufgemacht. Dann ist jetzt plötzlich Indien verbündeter, obwohl es eigentlich gar keinen Grund gibt, warum die Verbündeter sein sollen. Ich glaube, was man machen sollte, und leider ist es ja jetzt durch das Lieferkettengesetz oder Agrarreform und so nicht dazu gekommen. Eigentlich, was man machen müsste, ist bei allen europäischen und deutschen Gesetzen muss man für gewisse Standards sorgen und sagen, das machen wir nicht mit. Also wir machen keine Importe aus Regionen, wo Kinderarbeit, wo Uiguren eingesperrt sind oder sonst irgendwas. Das kann man machen. Und dann setzt man damit schon enorm viel Druck frei und die müssen dann mal schauen, wie sie damit umgehen, ob sie nicht das doch verbessern. Und so kann man Standards aufs Ganze erhöhen. Aber konfrontative Kurse bringen da meinserachtens überhaupt nicht weiter.
Ja, das muss man sich jetzt eben mal anschauen. Wir blicken jetzt auf 30 Jahre Globalisierung sozusagen zurück nach dem Kalten Krieg. Und es stehen noch sozusagen 70 Jahre offen irgendwie. Und jetzt hat man zuerst Osteuropa erobert als billig arbeitslohn Land. Das hat ganz gut funktioniert für den Westen. Da hat auch Wandel durch Annäherungen in so weit funktioniert, dass man dann auch so ein paar EU-Mitgliedschaften ausgesprochen hat. Russland war in der Bevölkerung zu klein, um da wirklich zu große Nähe herzustellen. Also ist man gleich nach China gegangen. In China hat das ja alles nicht funktioniert. Also wir haben China als Absatzmarkt gewonnen und als Produktionsstätte. Aber so eine Angleichung der Systeme hat es ja gerade nicht gegeben. Sondern jetzt stehen ja auch die deutschen Wahlkämpfe alle da. Also März vor allem und macht so dieses Systemargument. Aber auch Baerbock weist immer mal wieder drauf hin, man sollte jetzt ruhig mal einpreisen, dass in China auch Zwangsarbeit stattfindet. Beispielsweise VW und so weiter. Die profitieren ja alle so ein bisschen davon, von dieser Nordwestregion. Und dass Joe Biden hier in Europa vom, wie war die Reihenfolge, EU-Gipfel, dann NATO, nee, G7, NATO, dann noch mal so ein neues Format, EU-Kommission, Amerika. Hat man so als drei Stunden Tagesordnung irgendwie eingeräumt. Und dann gab es ja zum Abschluss, was gab es noch, das Gespräch mit Putin dann. Und das lief ja auch, die ersten drei Termine alle, und dass da so ein Maxime, Joe Biden kommt und sagt, wir müssen ja mal ein bisschen härter mit Russland, mit China und so weiter. Und dann sagt Merkel, nee, wir brauchen die auch als strategische Partner. Also da sieht man schon so eine gewisse ungleichartige Herangehensweise. Die Amerikaner wollen es eigentlich ein bisschen anders machen. Und die Europäer hoffen immer noch so ein bisschen. Und eine der Hoffnung ist ja auch, dass man die Fehler, die man mit China gemacht hat, weil so langsam sind die ja im Wohlstand angekommen und nützen uns nichts mehr als Wachstumsmotor, dass man dann nach Indien geht und dann final nach Afrika. Und dann zum Ende des Jahrhunderts hat man irgendwie die Welt einmal abgeklappert, was so kapitalistische Kolonialisierung angeht. Und dass man in Indien nicht noch mal die gleichen Fehler macht wie in China, beispielsweise wenn Indien kommt und sagt, wir wollen aber hier nur strategische Partnerschaften werden, unserem Land investiert, muss auch gleichzeitig Teile seines Unternehmens und da muss auch Forschung hier stattfinden und so. Und da hat ja China das immer durchgedrückt bis jetzt und selbst mit diesem Investitionsabkommen sind ja alle ein bisschen unzufrieden. Aber wir sehen ja, wie aufzack die Inder dann tatsächlich sind, dass sie auch wirklich mal Facebook rausschmeißen und so. Und wenn die Facebook rausschmeißen, ja dann lassen die sich von irgendeinem deutschen Autohersteller nicht allzu viel sagen. Also in der Hinsicht ist das eh eine ganz schwierige Angehensweise jetzt von der deutschen oder europäischen und amerikanischen Wirtschaft nach Indien, obwohl sie natürlich alle davor stehen und diese Wachstumspotenziale, die du ja genannt hast, sehen und denken, oh geil, da könnten in 30 Jahren 500 Millionen Leute Mercedes kaufen.
Jedoch nicht unbedingt ein verlässlicher Partner, denn Indien ist zwar momentan ein bisschen auf Konfrontationskurs zu China, aber man wird auch nicht mit China den Kontakt abbrechen, weil die so stark voneinander abhängen, das wäre total verrückt, wenn man das tun würde. Ich wüsste gar nicht, wie das gehen soll. Insofern ist da so eine Allianz zu schmieden doch sehr begrenzt, also was da mit dieser Allianz dann möglich ist, beziehungsweise Indien wird die Allianz vielleicht machen, wird aber im gleichen Maße auch im asiatischen Raum Allianzen schmieden. Und wir werden ja über Move sprechen im Salon. Da muss man sich auch nochmal die Zahlen vergegenwärtigen, wie viel Europäer, wie viel US-Amerikaner es gibt. Und dann gucken wir mal so in den asiatischen Raum und denken nochmal ganz neu über die Welt nach.
Genau, es gibt ein ganz virulentes Bild der Weltkarte, wir mit unserem eurozentrischen Weltbild und so. Aber wenn man um Nordindien und Südost-China so einen kleinen, wirklich kleinen Kreis zieht, mit ein bisschen Philippinen drin, hat man die Hälfte der Weltbevölkerung in so einem ganz unscheinbaren Fleckchen. Und der Rest der Welt ist eigentlich entvölkert. Also wir Europäer spielen eigentlich keine Rolle. Das spielt sich alles dort ab. Und da muss man dann auch mal ein bisschen umdenken, je nachdem, welche Ziele man verfolgt. Es gibt natürlich auch andere Angehensweisen, das wird für die Rentnerrepublik super interessant, dass man vor allem Europa jetzt mal empfiehlt, ihr seid jetzt reich, ihr habt genug Auskommen und ihr wisst auch, wie eine Kreislaufwirtschaft und eine stagnierende Wirtschaft funktioniert. Ihr könnt jetzt ablassen von dem großen Spiel. Ihr müsst nicht mit Amerika auf Augenhöhe euch in China irgendwie präsent machen und so, sondern ihr seid doch, ihr habt doch genug Wohlstand. Da gibt es auch Empfehlungen, Europa jetzt wirklich zu so einem Altenheim zu entwickeln, von dem aber alle profitieren. Also die Szenarien sind wirklich utopisch eigentlich, aber absolut realistisch. Also in der Hinsicht kann man hier auch jetzt so langsam mit Geruhsamkeit herankommen und sagen, lass doch die anderen die Quantencomputer bauen. Aber mal gucken, wie weit sowas trägt. Wir bleiben mal in der Region und wechseln aber das Thema und zwar zu Corona. Denn wir kommen ja jetzt auch in Europa so langsam in diesen Status, wo wir sagen, Corona ist irgendwie vorbei. Für Geimpfte sowieso. Also man ist nicht mehr medizinisch bedroht, auch nicht von Delta, wenn man ordentlich zweifach durchgeimpft ist. Selbst solche Johnson & Johnson-Kandidaten wie ich haben genug Zeit im September, wenn genug da ist, sich nochmal das RNA-Update, den Booster zu holen. Also so zu tun, als hätte man jetzt eine AstraZeneca-Vektor-Impfung und dann holt man sich halt das Update. Und die Studienlage ist ja ganz herausragend für diese Kombi. Und deswegen bedroht uns der Herbst nicht wirklich. Und wir sehen jetzt schon, wie so langsam die Gelassenheit da kommt. Und wir jetzt eigentlich wieder umschwenken können auf so eine Post-Corona-Welt. Dazu gehörte gigantische Wellen, viele Todesfälle, eine Bewusstwertung. Impfung ist irgendwie die Lösung, sich auch wirklich impfen zu lassen. Und dann kommt ein Herbst, wo alle geimpft sind und man auch mit hohen Inzidenzen einfach locker durchkommt, weil man dann wie in England sieht, eine 500er-Inzidenz in Yorkshire oder so bedeutet halt nichts, weil da liegt trotzdem nur zwei Leute auf der Inzidenzstation. Und jetzt gibt es aber Länder, die haben Corona anders bewältigt als wir, beispielsweise Taiwan, darüber reden wir gleich, und Australien. Australien hat sich abgeschottet, Australien ist eine Insel, das war immer ganz wichtig.
Das wird als großes Vorbild ja immer genannt für die Zero-Covid, zum Teil auch für die No-Covid-Fraktion. Die haben, erinnere ich mich noch dran, ich glaube Melanie Brinkmann war es, die dann sagte, ja, da habe ich mal mit australischen Kollegen telefoniert und die haben mir dann genau gesagt, wie sie das gemacht haben. Und dann habe ich immer gedacht, naja, gut, Australien ist jetzt ein bisschen anders gelegen als Deutschland. Das sollte man aber dann nicht sagen, dann bekam man gleich wieder ein, ja, natürlich, also das ist genauso hier auch wirklich. Und ich dachte immer, naja, irgendwie sehe ich da so einen Unterschied. Also ich war in Geografie jetzt nie so wahnsinnig gut, aber so klar war mir das dann doch noch, wieso die Welt aufgeteilt ist. Und dann dachte ich mir, ja, Deutschland ist ein Land, das von sehr vielen Ländern umgeben ist und von diesen auch abhängig ist, beziehungsweise mit diesen kooperiert in Form von Austausch von Arbeitskräften, zum Beispiel oder Import-Export. Ich habe immer gedacht, wie soll das sein? Und dann hat man dann irgendwann mir erklärt, naja, eine europäische Lösung. Also man braucht europäisches No-Covid. Und dann habe ich gedacht, ja, klar, wir haben ja auch sonst immer nur herrliche Kompromisse mit Orban, mit der PiS-Partei in Polen und was weiß ich. Die werden natürlich sofort bereit sein, das so zu machen, wie wir uns das vorstellen.
Beim Thema Flüchtlinge, beim Thema Schulden, war Deutschland ja immer eingebettet in die europäische Strategie und es hat immer super funktioniert, genau. Also es ist, und das sollte man auch nicht zu flapsig sagen, ganz wichtig, dass Australien und Taiwan Inseln sind. Die keine Landgrenzen haben, das heißt, hier in Europa, die deutschen Grenzen stehen nur auf dem Papier. Das haben auch alle mitbekommen, als es hieß, wir machen jetzt mal die Grenze dicht, weil die Polizei zuerst gefragt hat, was heißt denn das, die Grenzen dicht? Sollen wir jetzt hier eine Menschenkette aufmachen mit den Beamten oder wie ist das gemeint? Ja, und in Passau und so, da kam natürlich hier Tirschenreuth, das liegt halt nahe an Tschechien. Und wenn Tschechien die Inzidenz so ist, dann ist sie eben in Tirschenreuth ein bisschen höher als was weiß ich in Schwerin oben, wo es nur Dänemark gibt oder die Ostsee und die Nordsee. Also in der Hinsicht, das ist ganz wichtig, glaube ich, zu verstehen und auch zu akzeptieren, ja, Australien und Taiwan haben es gut gemacht, weil sie eine Insel sind. So, und jetzt gibt es aber mehrere Phasen der Pandemie und irgendwann will man auch mal raus. Und das klappt nun in Australien wirklich schlecht. Wir hören hier mal BBC Nachrichten.
Well, it's been heralded, of course, as something of a Covid success story. But there are now growing concerns about Australia's policies and the trouble it might be storing up for the coming months. But before we look at why, let's see the picture right now.
Es wachsen die Sorgen in Australien, dass man jetzt nicht so gut aus Corona wieder rauskommt. Wir haben ja in Deutschland das damals so gemacht, ja Grenze zu, aber die Lufthansa wurde von der Bundesregierung noch beauftragt, alle Deutschen, die wollen, nach Deutschland zurückzuholen. Und nicht die Grenzen zu und alle bleiben mal, wo sie sind, bloß nichts einliefern, sondern nein, auch Corona-kranke Deutsche wurden nach Deutschland zurückgeholt, wurden dann eben entsprechend betreut, was ja möglich ist per Flugzeug und so weiter. Da hat man ja alles unter Kontrolle, anders als wenn die Menschen irgendwie einfach in ihr Auto steigen und über die Grenze fahren. Stellt sich raus, dass man auch das in Australien ganz hart anders geregelt hat. Sie reden hier mit einer Frau, die nicht zurückgelassen wurde nach Australien. Sie hatte also eine Möglichkeit, mal zu fliegen, für 10.000 Dollar hat sie natürlich nicht gemacht. Also sitzt sie jetzt als Familienangehörige aus Australien außerhalb Australiens und kommt nicht zurück. So und die Impfkampagne in Australien, wenn es in Australien gar kein Corona gibt. So die Impfquote liegt also bei 2, 1 Prozent nur.
Warum sich impfen lassen, wenn es ja gar kein Corona gibt?
Wir haben ja gar kein Corona. Wir kennen auch keine Corona-Toten. Und ich habe auch noch niemanden gesehen, der gemeint hatte, die Lunge wehe, fünf Monate später. So, niemand geimpft. Was will Australien jetzt machen? Sich abschotten für immer? Grenzschließung für immer? Die Frau darf niemals wieder zu ihrer Familie zurück? Wie ist das gemeint? Es ist keine Exit-Strategie.
Hier wird es gelebt. Das ist so verrückt. Aber was ich jetzt auch nicht verstehen kann, ist, warum wir das jetzt hier über BBC durch dich einmal erfahren. Aber das wäre ja ein ganz großes Thema, um das mal deutlich zu machen. Und es war doch auch von Anfang an klar, nur die Impfung ist eine Lösung. Alles andere ist nur zeitlich befristet, in irgendeiner Weise, so, dass es etwas verhindert. Aber es ist nicht, dass man damit leben kann, indem man sagt, ja, ab sofort ist immer alles dicht und ab sofort sehen wir unsere Großeltern nicht mehr, oder was weiß ich. Das heißt, die Impfung war doch von Anfang an klar als die einzige Möglichkeit begriffen. Und das finde ich ja jetzt auch wieder so fatal bei dieser Delta-Diskussion, dass jetzt wieder so getan werden. Ja, ja, bei Impfung, da haben dann manche wieder gesagt, ja, aber die Maske schützt viel besser. Was heißt denn das? Also sollte ich dann jetzt sagen, wir tragen jetzt, weiß ich nicht, wie viele Jahre ich noch lebe, ich will Jahrhundert werden, solange trage ich jetzt Maske immer, oder was?
Und zwar bei allen Gelegenheiten.
Ja, als Armin Laschet meinte, wer macht jetzt einen Brücken-Lockdown, haben alle ein bisschen gelacht, weil sie meinten, der Lockdown ist natürlich nur eine Brücke. Aber das waren alle Lockdowns. Das sind Brücken. Wir haben nicht-pharmazeutische Intervention bis zur pharmazeutischen Intervention. Also Medikamente oder... Wir haben ja den Bill Gates Text gelesen. Da waren noch sehr viel optimistischer, dass es Medikamente gibt. Am Ende sind es dann doch die Impfung geworden. Aber diese pharmazeutischen Interventionen befreien uns von den nicht-pharmazeutischen, die wir alle nicht wollen. Thema Einsamkeit und so, hier alles durchgenudelt. Das ist nicht das, was wir wollen. Na ja, in Australien muss man aber sagen, das ist ja freiwillig so gemacht worden. Die australische Regierung hätte ja Impfstoff kaufen können. Und die Bevölkerung hätte sich ja impfen lassen können. Also da fehlt sozusagen politischer und individueller Wille. Also klemmt man da fest. Jetzt nähern wir uns langsam Taiwan. Da ist es nämlich ein bisschen anders. Wir machen das aber über Umweg Amerika und China. Denn es läuft, das kriegen wir in Deutschland ja auch nicht richtig mit, jetzt wirklich einen Impfkrieg auf der Welt. Es gibt ja mehrere Anbieter. Und alle wollen über Afrika, Südasie, wie auch immer. Wollt ihr euch nicht auch mal impfen lassen? Wir hätten da was im Angebot so ungefähr. Und das ist ausgerechnet China ist und Amerika, die jetzt, klar Deutschland auch, aber wir exportieren nach marktwirtschaftlichen Regeln. Das machen ja die Amerikaner anders. Und die Chinesen auch, die verbinden da so ein bisschen was, sagen es aber nicht richtig. Also hier gucken wir uns mal kurz diesen Impfkrieg an, der hier so läuft. China exportiert mehr Impfungen als der Rest der Welt zusammen bislang.
Am Ende des letzten Monats hat Russland fast 40% der Impfungen, die es produziert hat, aber nicht die Fähigkeit, viel zu machen. Indien exportiert sich auf einen Halt, da die Länder einen großen Verlust in den Taten sahen und die domestikale Nutzung prioritiert haben. Die EU exportiert 28% der Impfungen, die es gemacht hat, aber vielmehr war es die UK und die USA. China hat mehr Dosen als die restlichen Länder, die den Rest der Welt kombiniert haben.
Die Chinesen haben keine besonders guten Impfstoffe. Das weiß man mittlerweile. Die haben auch versucht durch, wir mischen die mal alle. Also wirklich, wir mischen die alle. Wir machen alle in einen Topf und mischen die durch, das zu erhöhen. Hat alles nicht so gut funktioniert. Die Amerikaner haben natürlich mit moderner, spektakulär gute Impfstoffe, halten die aber immer noch zurück. Also wenn das exportiert wird, dann irgendwie so Astralager, die sind da gar nicht zugelassen und die haben trotzdem 30 Millionen im Land. Und das geht dann so ein bisschen nach Mexiko. Und Indien natürlich mit seinem eigenen Problem. Also auf Europa muss man sagen, das ist echt nicht allzu schlechte Bilanz zu sagen, okay, die europäischen Unternehmen unterliegen den Marktkräften, also kauft einfach irgendwer ein. Und am Ende hat halt selbst das Herstellerland zu wenig gekauft und bekommt dann aber auch nichts. Also das ist dann wenigstens mal konsequente Marktwirtschaft. Da hat man sich dann nicht von seiner eigenen Ideologie einlohlen lassen, sondern es hat sich gesagt, okay, dann machen wir das jetzt so, wie es ist, dauert dann halt ein bisschen länger, gut und schön.
Wir sehen aber hier die Verlogenheit sehr schön von Amerika zu sagen, ihr müsst jetzt mal die Patente freigeben, dann können wir 1% exportiert. Und das hat nichts mit Patenten oder so zu tun.
Amerika will selbst nicht verkaufen, aber will, dass Biontech jetzt seine Patente freigibt. Also das ist wirklich, ja, Merkel hat ja wenigstens das erfolgreich zurückgedrängt. Der Covid-Koordinator im Weißen Haus sagt jetzt zum Einen pipapo, Amerika will jetzt auch anfangen zu exportieren und zwar im folgenden Modus. Aber wir verbinden uns natürlich trotzdem mit Interessen, die wir haben. Noch jedenfalls ist der große Wettlauf im Gange. China, die haben beispielsweise Chile und so komplett versorgt, die liegen jetzt hier ganz weit vorn. Ja und es ist völlig klar, dass die Chinesen hier nicht kommen mit langen Verträgen, wo irgendwie drin steht, sondern einfach nur mit wir versorgen euch und später, ihr wisst ja Bescheid, wir haben euch damals unsere Alkohol aus der Patsche geholfen. Also weisen die bei der BBC drauf hin. G7, also die G7 Länder, ihr habt ja noch ein bisschen Zeit, denn 80 Länder, okay, es gibt ja noch ein paar mehr und auch China schafft es noch nicht allzu viel jetzt zu versorgen. So, das ganze Ding ist also, auch wenn die Amerikaner sagen, no strings attached und so, das ist mega politisch aufgeladen.
Natürlich und das weiß doch jeder, der jetzt nicht Korruption begeht, aber der mal Geschenke macht oder sonst irgendwas. Also ich kann dir jetzt auch mal eine Flasche Champagner schenken. Das hat ja gar nichts mit irgendwas zu tun. Also du lasst dich da nicht irgendwie, aber ich freue mich, dass du jetzt beim Fernsehsender arbeitest oder so. Natürlich genau, dass du im entscheidenden Moment an mich denken wirst. Und genau so finden diese Geschenke da statt. Und das ist für die das Allerbeste. Sie werden geradezu dumm. Wenn sie jetzt einen Vertrag oder sowas aufsetzen würden, dann würde man das ja gleich erkennen. Aber jetzt ist das ja viel besser. Und wie auch diese interne Kommunikation dann immer wieder schaffen, welche diplomatischen Verbindungen da geknüpft wurden, sind die man vorher gar nicht knüpfen konnte, die man aber jetzt hat. Jetzt hat man auch mal so einen direkten Draht. Jetzt kriegt man da von der KP auch mal direkt eine an die Strippe. Und jetzt kann man das mal durchsprechen, was es eigentlich da noch gab. Wie war das eigentlich hier mit Internet und so? Könnte uns da auch helfen? Also da passiert jetzt ganz viel. Also da ist diese Idee des vernetzten Chinas, das ist ja neben Belt and Road die andere große Sache, dass man die Welt so als Netz begreift und man wirft dieses Netz von China aus. Das funktioniert jetzt mit diesen Impfungen wirklich grandios.
Ganz genau. Und jetzt gucken wir uns einen Fall an, in dem sind ja Protagonisten Deutschland, China und Taiwan. Und wir können aber nur an der Oberfläche gucken, denn die Interna sind, naja, wie soll es anders sein, geheim. BioNTech kündigt eine Lieferung nach Taiwan an und liefert dann aber doch nicht. Und wir hören hier die Deutsche Welle News Asia. Also das sind Nachrichten, die in Bonn bei der Deutschen Welle hergestellt werden, aber in Asien für ein asiatisches Publikum gemacht sind.
Der Minister für Gesundheit und Gesundheit hat gezeigt, dass zwei Wörter einen Verkauf für Millionen Covid-19-Vaccinen mit der Deutschen BioNTech ausgesprochen haben. Aber eine Woche später hat BioNTech den Verkauf aufgrund der Verwaltung der globalen Impfstoffe und der genannten Zeitlinien aufgeholt. Diese Ausführungen kommen einen Tag nachdem Präsident Tsai Ing-wen China direkt auf die Tatsache, dass Taiwan mit BioNTech verbreitet wird. In der Antwort auf ihr Statement hat BioNTech DW News Asia eine mögliche Distribution unserer Vakzine.
Das ist natürlich ein Hammer irgendwie, ne? Taiwan, anders als Australien, ist motiviert. Das Volk wählt eine Regierung demokratisch, die entscheidet sich, wir kaufen jetzt bei BioNTech, weil das sind diejenigen, die es liefern können. Und dann kommt dieser Deal aber nicht zustande, weil in der Presseerklärung von Our Country gesprochen wird. Und jetzt ist eine Vermutung hier von dem Nachrichtensprecher, ja, da hat sich China eingemischt. Nur, was heißt China hat sich eingemischt? China hat bei der Bundesregierung angerufen, hat gesagt, ihr müsst es verhindern, dass BioNTech da liefert, oder haben die direkt bei BioNTech irgendwie angerufen und gesagt, also dieser Deal findet nicht statt. Er fand dann jedenfalls nicht statt. Also es gab hier offenbar eine Einflussnahme von China auf BioNTech. Obwohl Taiwan nach marktwirtschaftlichen Prinzipien, so wie BioNTech und wir in Europa das eben mit allen Ländern, auch zum Nachteil Deutschlands übrigens, zumindest am Anfang, das waren die Regeln. Und plötzlich kommt hier China und sagt, wir mischen uns hier ein, dieser Vertrag kommt nicht zustande, ihr dürft nicht nach Taiwan liefern. Und da hätte ich auch mal eine Frage irgendwie, wie hat das in Deutschland funktioniert? Also wie konnte sich China hier in Deutschland in der wichtigen Frage so einmischen, dass diese Ich glaube, dass dieser Vertrag da nicht zustande kam.
Denn es kann ja nur über Deutschland gelaufen sein. Also es muss ja nicht sein über Pfizer.
Ne, die Amerikaner hätten das, das hören wir gleich.
Die Amerikaner hätten das ja auch nicht mitgemacht.
Also das muss über die Biontech-Bundesregungsschiene irgendwie gelaufen sein, dass sich China hier so eingemischt hat, dass es diesen Vertrag, der schon unterschrieben war und an der Pressemitteilung ist es dann gescheitert, dass die Lieferung nicht zustande kam. Also in deren Sicht hoch dramatisch, aber Biontech ist ja nicht der einzige RNA-Lieferant, also hat sich Taiwan anders angeguckt. Und wir hören jetzt einen Clip, der wird nicht richtig besprochen. Der geht trotzdem 44 Sekunden. Und wir hören den taiwanesischen Gesundheitsminister in einem völlig übersteuerten Mikrofon. Steht da am Flughafen, während ein Flugzeug aus Amerika landet, das Moderna liefert. Also wir sehen es hier gerade landen, es wurde live übertragen. MSNBC in dem Fall. Das Flugzeug wird entladen. Und jetzt sind wir in die Liebungen da. In dieser Zeit der Pandemie und Bayern, die uns wirklich schwer tritt, sind wir unseren amerikanischen Freunden unendlich dankbar.
Unsere wahren Fühle, die sie heute 2, 5 Millionen Moderna-Dinger geliefert haben.
Ich bin wirklich sehr gerührt. In Amerika wurde groß gefeiert, dass Moderna, also Amerika, jetzt Taiwan mit Impfstoff versorgt.
Und das Ende dieser kurzen Ansprache ist ja, dass er noch sagte, die eine positive Situation für unsere gemeinsame Zukunft oder so. Da wurde immer mal ganz klar jetzt hier gesagt und auf gute Zusammenarbeit in den nächsten zehn, zwanzig Jahren.
Und jetzt haben wir hier noch ein Clip von der South China Morning Post. Die Präsidentin Taiwan bedankt sich noch mal für die Hilfe aus Amerika und Japan. Wir sehen wieder Flugzeug. Also wie in Deutschland ja auch. Jetzt sehen wir hier den Gesundheitsminister mit dem Schild.
Thank you, Amerika.
Und sie hebt noch mal den wahren Wert der Freundschaft aus.
Im Kampf gegen die Pandemie stand man zusammen.
Ja, mit so ein paar Schnittbildern aus Laboren und wie man testet und so weiter. Also hier in Taiwan geht es in Sachen RNA-Technologie und Impfung und so richtig politisch zur Sache. Da hat sich China groß eingemischt, wollte nicht, dass Taiwan versorgt wird. Taiwan hat ja bis jetzt auch mit den letzten kleinen Ausbrüchen ganz gut hingekriegt. Wenn die sich jetzt durchimpfen, haben sie es wirklich gut geschafft. Und da stellt sich China einfach quer, während China gleichzeitig die ganze Welt unter diesen politischen Maßgaben da durchimpfen möchte.
Ich will dir noch zwei Fragen stellen zum Thema Impfung. Und die erste Frage ist, jetzt sehen wir, dass da doch auch für die anderen Länder einiges getan wird, wenngleich auch nicht mit so einem besonders guten Impfstoff aus China. Das wäre besser, das wäre ein anderer. Aber es wäre doch möglich, abseits von all diesen Patentdiskussionen, dass man Milliarden in die Hand nimmt und Produktionsstrecken ausbaut in Afrika und sonst wo. Da wäre ja sicherlich auch noch sehr viel mehr möglich. Das scheitert also auch noch an einer gewissen Zögerlichkeit des Westens dann, beziehungsweise an den Kooperationspartnern, die dann auch nicht richtig das in die Hand nehmen und das schnell machen. Also da sind ja nicht jetzt alle vermutlich so auf Zack wie in Taiwan.
Also die Impfdiplomatie und die Impfpolitik ist wirklich ein bisschen verlogen. Denn wir haben von Amerika, das haben wir das letzte Mal schon behandelt, diesen Patent-Freigabescheiß, der völlig neben der Spur ist. Denn es ist wirklich wahnsinnig kompliziert, sowas herzustellen. Es geht hier nicht darum, dass Coca-Cola in der Marktschließung über das Rezept, wie man Wasser und Zucker miteinander mischt oder so. Sondern hier geht es um Inhaltsstoffe, die, wenn man sie aufwiegt, tausendfach so viel wert sind wie Gold. Diese kleinen Dipide, die der Künstliche angezüchtet und die dann die RNA so einpacken, dass es stabil, aber nicht zu stabil, dass sich nach zwei Tagen das alles schön abbaut und dann auch gut funktioniert. Wir haben jetzt über Cure weggesehen, wie kompliziert das am Ende wirklich ist. Weil der Ingmar Höher saß ja bei Markus Lanz und hat gesagt, wir impfen gar keine Substanzen, wir impfen nur nach Information. Der Körper wird von nichts belastet. Und plötzlich hören wir bei Cure weggen, die mussten mit der Dosierung nach unten gehen, weil es die Körper dann doch reagiert haben auf die Promeimpfung in den Teststudien. Also es geht doch wahrscheinlich noch nicht ganz so auf, dass man wirklich nur die RNA impft, die dann auch den Zellkernen des Patienten umgeht und direkt repliziert und so weiter und das Spike-Protein herstellt. Also es ist eine wahnsinnig komplizierte Technologie. Es gibt einen sehr aufschlussreichen New York Times Text, das kann man gar nicht sagen, sondern es ist eine Fotoshow, wo die 50 Etappen mal richtig durchgegangen werden und nur Menschen in weißen Anzügen und so. Und man einfach hofft, das ist anscheinend so ein bisschen wie bei der Herstellung von Mikrochips, wo ja so Firmen wie Intel und AMD dann auch irgendwann gesagt haben, wir wissen eigentlich gar nicht genau, wie das geht. Wir haben nur so Testfabriken, wo wir Experimente laufen lassen und wenn dann irgendwann genau dieses Mikrochip-Gitter rauskommt, was wir haben wollen, dann lassen wir das einfach genauso, fassen das nie wieder an und produzieren. Sollten wir das Frank Riegerman mal beschrieben, dass sie selber nicht genau wissen, warum ihre Fabrik jetzt so tolle Mikrochips herstellt. Es könnte damit zu tun haben, dass die Wasserleitungen so und so gehen oder dass irgendwo da so eine Temperaturregulierung drin ist. Man kann es nicht genau replizieren und deswegen sind sie heilfroh, wenn sie einmal das Setting haben und dann bauen sie halt Chips in diesem Setting. Und dann kommen aus dieser Fabrik genau diese Chips raus, bis man sie durch den nächsten Entwicklungssprung nicht mehr braucht und dann braucht man eine neue Fabrik und dann geht das alles von vorne los. Und so ist das ja hier auch. Am Anfang hat ja so eine Herstellung von so einer Biontech Charge irgendwie drei Monate gedauert, weil die Stoffe dann doch alle miteinander irgendwie so und so. Und da jetzt auf Patentfreigabe und im Sinne von wir schicken denen eine Anleitung und dann kriegen die das hin in Nigeria, das ist völlig absurd. Also wirklich, man soll sich ja nicht zu kompliziert, aber auch nicht zu einfach machen, diese Argumente, die man da immer hört. Ja, Taiwan und Australien sind eine richtige Insel und deswegen haben die da einen Vorteil. Und dieses Argument muss man jetzt mal akzeptieren, das ist nicht vergleichbar mit Frankreich, Italien oder Deutschland. Selbst Italien hat noch zu viele Nachbarstaaten und zu viel Bewegung. Und so ist das bei diesen RNA-Verpackungen da auch. Das geht einfach nicht so leicht und das müssen diejenigen machen, die es machen. Und die Kritik, und das hast du eben angesprochen, ist, China baut jetzt Biontech, also wir sagen immer Biontech-Pfizer, aber neben Pfizer gibt es noch zehn andere Partner mittlerweile, die auf Augenhöhe mit Pfizer und so weiter an der Produktion drin hängen, die man da genauso nennen könnte, die waren halt nur die ersten damals. Und so baut man jetzt auch in China diese Fabriken auf, die das dann machen können, nicht in China, in Asien irgendwo. Aber das sind halt Prozesse, die von Biontech noch wirklich PWL-mäßig durchkalkuliert werden müssen, anstatt dass man da wirklich einfach sagt, wir G7 finanzieren das jetzt durch und dann kann das ja irgendwann von irgendwem abbezahlt werden, aber erstmal ist es wichtig, die Produktion hochzufahren. Jetzt müssen immer noch die Businesspläne zuerst geschrieben werden und das verstehe ich auch nicht.
Das ist das Verrückte, das ist das, was anzuprangern ist. Das ist exakt das, bei dem man sagen kann, hier wird wieder mit dieser Austeritätspolitik dann im globalen Maße dafür gesorgt, dass diese Pandemie noch lange anhält, dass man immer noch Reisebeschränkungen haben wird, dass viele Leute noch sterben werden, wenn sie dieses Virus bekommen und die sind dann garantiert nicht durchgeimpft, wenn wir in den Winter gehen. Das ist eigentlich der eigentliche Skandal und warum man sich da auf diese Patente konzentriert. Dann lass mich noch eine zweite Frage stellen. Wenn man sich all diese Tabellen, in denen die Impfstoffe miteinander verglichen werden, anseht, wenn man dann auch nochmal schaut, wie die Impfstoffe auf die entsprechenden Varianten anspringen oder nicht anspringen, dann kann man doch im Ganzen sagen, etwas, was wir schon von Anfang an gesagt haben hier, aber man kann es doch im Ganzen nochmal festhalten, dass die beiden mRNA-Impfstoffe die wirksamsten sind. Was nicht heißt, dass Johnson & Johnson und Astra jetzt vollkommen unwirksam sind, aber es sind die wirksamsten. Auch zeigt sich, wenn da die Zweitimpfung ist, wenn da die Delta-Variante kommt, wenn man dann überhaupt noch infiziert wird, was sehr gering ist, dann ist aber auch das, was dann passiert, eben nur ein Schnupfen. Das würde aber doch jetzt mal langsam bedeuten, dass man hier, wo wir jetzt schon so viele Impfstoffe, so viele Dosen haben, jetzt sagt, okay, jetzt ist auch mal gut, die ganze Zeit noch mit Astra und Johnson & Johnson immer noch das Leuten versuchen, schmackhaft zu machen, kann man dann nicht jetzt auch einfach mal sagen, gut, das ist jetzt hier unsere Technologie, mRNA, und wir fangen jetzt nicht noch mal im November an, ob man nochmal mit Astra rumhantelt.
Ja, scheitert an der Kapazität wahrscheinlich.
Aber müsste ja nicht, also das ist ja auch eine Frage von...
Genau, ja, also wie gesagt, man hat halt in Marburg dieses Werk, man hat hier in Frankfurt in Höst noch so eine Bude von Novartis oder so umgemodelt, damit da auch BioNTech hergestellt werden kann. Also ich glaube, das ist schon ziemlich ausgereizt, was hier angeht, also für Europa, wenn man jetzt neue Stätten in Asien aufmacht, ob man das dann macht für den europäischen Markt, wenn nicht ein bisschen übertrieben, weil die brauchen das da ja auch, also dann sollte man es dort lassen und dort verimpfen. Das heißt, in diesem Winter sind wir wahrscheinlich noch nicht so weit, nur also alle RNA geimpft in den Winter zu schicken. Aber spätestens nächstes Jahr, ich erwarte aber auch für die Jahre 2023, 2024, spätestens 2025, dass wir im Herbst eine Kombi-Impfung, Grippe und Corona auf RNA-Basis dann bekommen. Und dass es dann aber Grippe auch wirklich mal der Kampf angesagt wird. Wir haben es ja jetzt mit den nicht pharmazeutischen Interventionen geschafft, die Grippewelle wirklich mal abzubrechen. Da war ja Wieler auch ganz überrascht. Hat aber auch nur in so einer Podiumsdiskussion gesagt. Wir haben die Grippewelle abgebrochen. Das haben wir noch nie geschafft. Das hat er bei so einer Freitags-Req-Pekane nie gesagt. Da hätte man ja auch mal als gute Nachricht irgendwie wirklich mal sagen können, wir haben die Grippe besiegt. Jetzt kommt sie halt neu wieder aus Asien, wie das jedes Jahr ist. Man weiß halt immer nicht, welche setzen sich durch. Aber ich denke auch, spätestens nächstes Jahr muss man mal von dieser Hühnerei-Grippe wie Impfungszüchtung da weg, das wir dann ernamen. Da bin ich eigentlich ganz froh und mutig, dass diese ganzen Kapazitäten, die Biontech da aufbaut, nicht nur für Corona-Impfstoff aufbaut, sondern grundsätzlich um jedes Jahr gegen was auch immer. Also Grippe als nächstes dann und dann mal hier ordentlich. Also ist ja ein echter Sprung, muss man ja sagen. Ist ja ein echter Technologiesprung. Johnson & Johnson hat Kikuli gestern, so einen amerikanischen Verantwortlichen zitiert, Johnson & Johnson hat wohl gegen Delta nur 60% Krankenhauseinweisungen oder so. Also 60% ist immer noch über der Schwelle, die die WHO als das wäre wünschenswert und wirksam herausgegeben hat, aber sind halt trotzdem nur 60%. Das heißt, alle ab 70, die dann doch ein bisschen gefährdeter werden, werden dann vielleicht doch mal ein paar Tage im Krankenhaus liegen und ein bisschen Zusatzsauerstoff benötigen. Aber auch das kann man ja fast schon wieder als milden Verlauf im Vergleich zu Pocken im Mittelalter, wie Drosten das für die über 80-Jährigen klassifiziert hat sehen. In deren Sicht, ja mal gucken, ob das jetzt, klar, RNA ist jetzt Zukunft und das wird auch flächendeckend dann so sein, aber noch nicht diesen Winter, aber danach ganz sicher.
Ja, aber da hat man auch sich wieder lange zu dieser Erkenntnis nicht durchringen können. Also das ist einfach so interessant, also da haben wir ja auch nun hier unsere Wissenschaftserklärer, ich will die Damen nicht alle nennen, wieder gehabt, die dann immer gesagt haben, nee, nee, das ist ein ganz toller Impfstoff, auch mit den Werktoren, das ist alles ganz toll und man kann ja auch einfach sagen, es ist ja ein guter, aber es gibt halt sehr gute, wie das Kikule machte und das wird ja jetzt auch nochmal hier ganz deutlich mit den Varianten, dass es sich nochmal bestätigt hat, weshalb ich das einfach nicht kapieren kann, dass das auch gar nicht so groß politisiert wurde, also dass das, das hätte ich als Partei sofort gemacht, aber da bin ich ja dann auch von Linken ausgeschimpft worden, was ich dann für Luxusvorstellungen hätte und sonst was. Gut, das lasse ich mir gefallen im Zweireiher, aber ich muss da schon mich sehr wundern, weil man sonst immer alles dreimal dreht und wendet und schaut, wo auch ja nicht irgendein böser Giftstoff ist, der Krebs-erregend ist, wenn ich die Tomate esse.
Am Ende ist es, wie es immer ist, wir steigen aus der Kohle aus, wenn schon seit zehn Jahren kein Unternehmen mehr das mit der Kohle machen will. Und wir sagen dann auch irgendwann ganz ehrlich in Deutschland, das mit dem RNA-Zug ist so geil, wir brauchen diese Vektortransportimpfstoffe nicht mehr. Nur Astra hat jetzt schon angesagt, dass sie nie wieder Impfstoff machen werden. In deren Sicht ist der Markt dann schon bereinigt und es macht eh keiner mehr irgendwas mit Vektorimpfstoffen.
Astra hat das schon gesagt.
AstraZeneca hat schon gesagt, um Himmels Gott willen, es gibt ein ganz witziges Zitat, wo die sagen, nie nie nie wieder dieser Stress, den wir hatten mit dem Scheiß, zuerst sind hier alle gegen uns, dann liegen immer zu wenig Daten vor, dann jammern alle und dann ist irgendwas und so. Die haben echt die faxen Ticke. Also AstraZeneca hat ja auch Europa nichts mehr bestellt jetzt. Das trocknet einfach mal marktwirtschaftlich so richtig aus.
Und Johnson und Johnson machen auch lieber ein Haarmittel dann oder so.
Ja, Johnson und Johnson, die sind ja eh interessant, die haben ja auch bei dem Opium, also Opioiden bei diesen Beruhigungsmittel kriegen, die da in Amerika laufen, haben sie jetzt in New York des Eingeständes gemacht. Wir ziehen uns da zurück. Sie sind damit ein Urteil oder so umgangen, haben ein bisschen Strafe gezahlt und haben gesagt, wir ziehen uns aus diesen Betäugungsmittel ohne Rezeptmarkt zurück. Also in der Ansicht sind die Unternehmen eh gerade alles ein bisschen. Aber ja, dem Ernazeug geht jetzt die Zukunft und das ist ja auch gut so, denn wir haben ja schon im Salon gelesen, dass man jetzt auch die Autoimmunkrankheiten, also da wo nicht nur Immunisierung, sondern wirklich die Umprogrammierung des Immunsystems um Sachen, die das Immunsystem vorher gemacht hat, dann nicht mehr um der Funktion rauszunehmen, muss man ja wirklich umprogrammieren. Und das wird jetzt alles angedacht. Malaria, Krebs, Biontech impft ja jetzt wirklich schon die ersten Testimpfungen gegen Krebs. Also das ist ja jetzt ein Sprung gewesen, seit 20 Jahren machen die Krebsforschungen und jetzt sind sie so weit, dass sie das erste Mal auch wirklich Testgruppen aufmachen, um gegen Krebs zu impfen. Na ja, um kurz vorauszuschauen, wie auch die deutsche Diskussion dann, sagen wir mal, in sechs Wochen ungefähr laufen wird. Der Covid-Koordinator des Weißen Hauses in Amerika sieht hier schon, also er nennt nicht allzu gute Zahlen, sagen wir mal so, was die Impfquoten angeht.
Ist es klar genug für alle Amerikaner, wenn die Zeit kommt, für sie zu haben?
Ja, und das ist ganz typisch. Sie fragt noch, werden wir genug haben? Das ist ja in Deutschland auch. Wann haben wir eigentlich genug? Und er ist schon im Kopf ein Stück weiter. 54, also nur 54 Prozent sind wirklich durchge- und das nachdem die jetzt schon seit 6, 7 Wochen oder so alle ein Impfangebot gemacht haben. Da sieht man mal, das ist, also das ist jetzt die Fraktion der Unwilligen, die sich da breit macht. Die Hälfte aller republikanischen Männer, also republikanischen wählenden Männer lässt sich dort nicht impfen und lässt sich auch wirklich nicht impfen. Wir haben hier Zahl von einem Ort aus Amerika.
Region 5, wo Lake Charles ist, ist unterperformiert, wenn es um die Impfung von Menschen geht. 21% der Bevölkerung ist vollversorgbar gegen das Virus, welches die niedrigen Prozent statewide ist.
21% in manchen Orten nur, ne? Also da, wir haben ja in Deutschland gesehen, eine richtige Welle, die das Intensivregister überschwappt, also wirklich an die Grenzen bringt, hast du, wenn hier 1% der Leute gleichzeitig infiziert sind, 1%, und hier hast du in manchen Orten das 80% noch anfällig sind für die Infektion. Und wir wissen, wie die Amerikaner biologisch so drauf sind. Also die sind ja alle, da musst du ja immer auf das echte Alter, das biologische Alter nochmal 20 Jahre drauflegen durch die Fettleibigkeit und so weiter und so fort. Also in deren Sicht dramatisch in Amerika. Und Biden fällt aber nicht, also er kann nichts weiter machen, außer flehen.
Präsident Biden hat heute neue Erkundungen ausgerichtet, um mehr Amerikaner gegen Covid-19 zu werden, sie verbreiten sich von freier Bier zu Geldverkäufe. Der Präsident hat heute versprochen, dass bessere Tage vorliegen, wenn 70% der US-Adulten zumindest einen Schuss im nächsten Monat haben.
Lass uns einen wirklich historischen Independence-Dag feiern.
Juli ist nicht allzu weit weg. Das ist schon in einer Woche. Ja. Und 54 Prozent ist die Impfquote, 70 wollen sie. Das heißt, es sind noch 16 Prozent offen bei 300 Millionen. Das sind wir reden hier über 40 Millionen Amerikaner oder so, die hier noch fehlen. Also das ist beträchtlich.
Was würdest du denn sagen, sind das Impfgegner im Sinne von, da setzen sich Leute richtig mit Impfung auseinander und sagen dann, oh Gott, das macht unsere Gene kaputt. Oder würdest du sagen, es sind zum großen Teil Leute, die einfach lethargisch faul oder ein bisschen dusselig sind?
Beides. Das Verhältnis weiß ich nicht genau. Aber ich finde, wir sind auch jetzt in Deutschland schon in der Lage, wo man sagen kann, also jeder, der wirklich wollte, hat inzwischen mindestens eine Impfung bekommen. Ist so mein Eindruck.
Also bei den Jungen noch nicht ganz.
Also das habe ich so mitbekommen. Wir sind nicht weit entfernt davon. Also ich höre jetzt mittlerweile aus vielen Richtungen, dass es dann doch schon geklappt hat. Und sagen wir mal, die Amerikaner haben so zwei Monate Vorsprung. Jetzt ist Juni, Juli, dann ist August. Immer noch zwei Monate bis zum einschlagenden Herbst. Also in der Ansicht, wir sind eigentlich, was die Möglichkeiten angeht auf der sicheren Seite. Aber ich glaube, wir werden diese Diskussion jetzt auch relativ zügig bekommen.
Was heißt denn das eigentlich dann für uns? Also das heißt ja erstmal für die Geimpften nicht so viel, weil die ja geimpft sind. Besser wäre, es wären noch mehr geimpft. Damit ist sowieso die Ansteckungsgefahr niedriger. Das heißt auch die Impfungen, die dann nicht so wirkt, dass sie nicht so wirksam sind, dass da so ein bisschen was durchkommt und dass man dann doch den Schnupfen hat oder mal drei Tage Fieber, das würde dann auch damit natürlich extrem abgeschwächt werden. Also da ist die gesellschaftliche Verantwortung da. Zum anderen aber ist es natürlich dieses Individuum, das sich sagt, ich will nicht, aber dem kann man ja dann auch sagen, wer nicht hören will, muss fühlen.
Nur begrenzt, also die formale Argumentation in Deutschland war immer, also die formale, auch wenn es sich im Fernsehen ganz anders darstellt, die formale Argumentation war immer, wie von Anfang an gesagt wurde, die Kapazität des Gesundheitssystems. Also die Auslastung der Intensivbetten, die ist am Ende ausschlaggebend. Die bauen hier in Frankfurt gerade die größte Intensivstation Europas auf, weil sie den Braten auch nicht so ganz trauen und erwarten, dass es hier im Herbst wieder richtig zur Sache geht.
Nur haben wir erfahren, dass das mit den Betten nicht alles immer so korrekt weitergegeben wurde. Im Monitor hat er ja einen Beitrag gemacht, wo es hieß, da wurden auch Zahlen ganz schön nach oben.
Ja, aber wenn du jetzt im Intensivregister auf der Webseite nachliest, der Unterschied zwischen 3% aller Patienten liegen deswegen Covid oder 60% ist dann doch klar. Und wir wissen ja, am Ende ist auch nicht die Bettenzahl zu entscheiden, sondern das, was in den Personalregistern steht, an Pflegepersonal und das ist dann doch relativ einfach zu erheben mittlerweile, also wo es gemeldet werden muss. Und die Betrügereien traut man sich auch nicht nochmal zu. Also in der Ansicht wissen wir, im Herbst haben wir da einen ganz guten Überblick. Und wenn es tatsächlich so kommt, dass nicht genug Leute geimpft sind, also die Krankenhäuser wieder so voll laufen, dass die Intensivmediziner warnen, wir können jetzt hier nicht weiter aufnehmen und müssten dann diesen ganzen Triage-Diskussionen usw. wieder anleihen, dann kommt die Politik nicht um Lockdown, also um Kontaktsperren, um nicht pharmazeutische Interventionen herum.
Aber du kannst nicht, dass geimpfte das dann mitmachen.
Das ist dann die Frage, welchen Kampf wir dann ausführen.
Also da kündige ich jetzt hier mit schon mal an, dass das etwas sein wird, was ich nicht mitmache.
Also ich würde es nicht hier im Podcast ankündigen, aber ich habe das privat auch schon allen gesagt. Gut, ich habe nur ein Gespräch mit jemanden, der sich nicht impfen lassen wollte, aber mal eine klare Ansage. Für mich ist die Pandemie vorbei und jetzt ist halt Sommer, das heißt, es fällt nicht so besonders auf, aber spätestens wenn alle ihr Impfangebot hatten, ist für mich die Pandemie vorbei und ich werde dann auch keine weitere Kontaktsperre, wenn mir irgendwer verbietet, hier Samstagabend Gäste zu haben, ignoriere ich das. Die Polizei kommt ja eh nicht zu dir nach Hause und kontrolliert das. Das war ja schon die ganze Zeit eine Diskussion und deswegen würde ich sagen, kann man das auch so öffentlich sagen, das kann man dann durchaus ignorieren, weil ich, also wir haben dann alle den Plan erfüllt.
Da muss es dann einfach eine Allianz der Vernünftigen geben, die dann einfach sagt, wir machen das nicht, wir haben uns jetzt dann alles gehalten, erst an die ganzen Lockdown-Bestimmungen, haben uns dann schleunigst impfen lassen und jetzt ist mal gut.
Ja, es gibt natürlich immer noch eine Schicksalsgemeinschaft von Immunsystemen, Supprimierten, die sich einfach nicht impfen lassen können. Nur da muss man dann auch wirklich gucken, inwieweit man die Risiken verteilt. Für öffentliche Gebäude finde ich sowieso, auch beim Einkaufen. Wenn mir jemand sagt, ich soll bei Rewe eine Maske aufsetzen, mache ich das. Im Sommer, im Winter immer. Also die Viertelstunde, die ich da drin bin oder so, die trage ich auch gerne Maske. Da ist näher mit Menschen, die ich nicht kenne. Warum nicht da schützen? Wir können von mir aus auch nicht wegen Corona, sondern einfach wegen Schnupfen und allgemein schützen.
Nun wird das ja nicht für alle Geschäfte durchhaltbar sein. Also man wird jetzt nicht, ich werde jetzt nicht in Zukunft Anzüge und Schuhe und sonst was kaufen mit Maske.
Das wird nicht sein. Genau, da würde ich wieder sagen, da würde ich es nicht akzeptieren. Aber da kommt man halt auch drum herum, als jemand, der Risikopatient ist. Das ist nun mal das Schicksal derjenigen, die sich da, also die mehr auf sich selber aufpassen müssen, als der normale Mensch, dass die sich dann halt da wirklich schützen müssen und keine Ahnung, ob man dann aufgrund gehäufter Zahl einfach sagt, dann sagt man halt den Läden, alle zwei Wochen muss es einen halben Tag geben, wo einfach dann auch alle Verkäufer mal eine Maske aufsetzen, damit diejenigen da einkaufen gehen können, dass man da so Regeln irgendwie findet. Aber eine allgemeine Verfügung würde ich auch nicht mehr akzeptieren.
Ich glaube auch nicht, dass das durchkommt. Also ich sehe da eigentlich keine große Chance, dass über Leute, die gelb sind.
Ich habe schon beim letzten Winterlockdown gedacht, das schaffen sie nicht noch mal durchzudrücken, aber dann war ja doch eine Gefahr da.
Also da habe ich auch selbst Angst gehabt, dass ich was bekomme. Da haben viele Leute Angst gehabt, dass sie was bekommen. Wenn sie erst einmal geimpft sind, dann ist diese persönliche Betroffenheit nicht mehr da. Und dadurch sieht man das nicht mehr. Man sieht ja auch, wie die Leute sich jetzt gerade verhalten oder was sie dann jetzt auch wieder für möglich erachten. Und deswegen glaube ich, ist das alles sehr gut, auch dass das jetzt mal wieder gelebt wird, diese Form der Freiheit, dass man auch erkennt, was da eigentlich gefehlt hat. Manche hatten es ja fast vergessen, schien mir. Und dass die jetzt nicht, dass sie sich jetzt einfach wieder nehmen lassen, obwohl sie eigentlich nicht mehr betroffen sind. Weil das ist das Erstaunliche. Das hat sich ja schon bei den alten Leuten gezeigt. Die 80-Jährigen sind ja sofort wieder schon in den Flieger gestiegen und sagt, ja, da kann ich ja jetzt wieder. Die machen sofort alles. Deswegen glaube ich, ist das sehr gut, dass das jetzt gerade stattfindet, dass sich dann niemand unterkriegen lässt und am Ende wieder sagt, nee, jetzt müssen wir vernünftig sein. Nee, vernünftig ist es dann, dass die anderen sich impfen. Die andere Alternative dazu ist, oder die einzige Alternative dazu ist, natürlich zu sagen, man führt eine Impfpflicht ein, dann müssen sich alle impfen lassen. Ich weiß halt gar nicht, ob das durchsetzbar wäre, dass man so etwas machen kann.
Das wird aus einem Grund nicht gemacht. Kannst du es nicht durchsetzen? 80 Millionen Menschen, wie willst du das machen? Das ist administrativ nicht zu bewältigen.
Was wir hier haben, ist doch eigentlich, also was man natürlich haben kann, ist, dass man so eine implizite Impfpflicht hat, indem man einfach gewisse Dinge nur machen kann, wenn man diesen Impfausweis vorweisen kann.
Ja, aber die ist wirklich besonders implizit und die wird auch schnell fallen.
Aber die könnte man ja verstärken, wenn man das möchte. Also wenn man diesen Druck aufbauen möchte, kann man ja einfach sagen, ab Oktober kommt niemand in ein Restaurant rein, der nicht diesen Ausweis vorzeigen kann. Und dann hat man die Impfpflicht.
Du kommst im Juli wieder her, wir gehen dann nach Schnitzelessen. Es würde mich wundern, wenn die dort irgendwas sehen wollen, hinsichtlich Immunisierungsstatus. Das ist für mich der Punkt. Du musst den eben die ganze Zeit abfragen. Ansonsten müsstest du ja wirklich rastamäßig die Straßen abfahren und wirklich jede Hausnummer impfen und genau markieren, wen du nicht angetroffen hast. Weil ansonsten bist du halt in der Pflicht, die ganze Zeit den Status zu überprüfen. Also ich glaube, die Impfpflicht ist einfach aus administrativen Gründen nicht praktikabel. Und ehrlich gesagt, warum? Also am Ende ist ja so, in der Hoffnung, dass ich genug impfen, sodass das mit dem Krankenhaussystem funktioniert. Am Ende hat man sich da wirklich für die Infektion entschieden. Also da würde ich auch sagen, da nehmen wir Drosten ganz ernst. Drosten hat das genauso gesagt. Wer sich gegen die Impfung entscheidet, entscheidet sich für die Infektion, Klammer auf, aber später, Klammer zu. Und das fand ich sehr gut, dass man ihm als sehr wichtigen Arzt an der Stelle mal zu hören, denn da ist er auch Arzt. Da ist er nicht nur Labortyp, sondern da ist er einfach Arzt. Und hat das eben genauso gesagt. Und auch dazu gesagt, 2022. Also 2021 impfen, 2022, spätestens ist die Infektion dann da. Und hü oder hot, es ist ein Risiko, das steckt im Wort Entscheidung drin. Man hat sich dann entweder für das eine oder das andere entschieden. Die Infektion kommt dann nicht als Gefahr von außen, sondern für die hat man sich dann entschieden. Wir schließen mal das Corona-Thema ab mit einer kleinen Frage, die wir uns ja alle mal fragen können. Würden wir es akzeptieren, was Greta hier sagt, auf die Frage hin, wer sollte hier eigentlich zuerst geimpft werden und so weiter. Und sie macht so ein richtiges globales Argument, dass wir überlegen, was das eigentlich bedeutet am Ende.
Of course, I understand that many people have very different opinions on this, but myself think that we should in the first hand prioritize people in risk groups and in older age groups before vaccinating healthy young people, no matter where in the world they come from.
Greta wird keinen schwedischen Studenten und keinen deutschen und kein amerikanischen Studenten impfen, bevor nicht jeder über 40 auf der Welt geimpft ist.
Ja, bin ich dagegen. Wir haben ja auch das Buch über Triage im Salon gehabt von Manoni, der auch gesagt hat, das muss auch gar nicht die Argumentation sein. Denn mit dieser Argumentation könnte ich auch ganz viele andere Dinge einfach hier streichen und sagen, also solange nicht in Indien das und das da ist, kann es nicht sein, dass ich mich operieren lassen kann für dies und das und oder mit 90 eine neue Hüfte bekomme oder dass es überhaupt sowas wie Tierärzte gibt, wo man sagen muss, warum muss man Tiere noch bearzten, also das sind alles Sachen, die man dann, wenn man die im globalen Blick betrachtet, einfach streichen kann und da bin ich absolut dagegen, also da ist das große Glück, hier geboren zu sein und das ist ein ungeheures Privileg, unverdienterweise. Aber zu glauben, dass man so eine Gerechtigkeit herstellen kann, wo anfangen, wo aufhören, es muss an uns liegen, dass das sehr schnell weltweit möglich ist, aber wenn wir diese Aufrechnung da jetzt machen, also dann können wir sofort, da können wir auch allen Leuten die Klimaanlagen abnehmen und sagen hier, also da in Afrika, das ist so heiß, also ihr habt hier gar nicht zu klagen bei 35 Grad, also wenn wir in diese Argumentation kommen, dann kann ich schon verstehen, warum Leute auch sehr allergisch auf Kreta reagieren.
Ja, das ist beeindruckend, wie vehement sie dann dieses globale Argument da durchdrückt, auch beim Impfen. Beim Impfen wird es noch ein bisschen klarer, finde ich, als wenn sie über das Klima so spricht, aber am Ende ist ja die Transferleistung nicht schwer, das ist ja angedeutet, das heißt tatsächlich, nee, hier fährt keiner mehr in Deutschland auch nur ein Kilometer mit einem zu schweren, zu viel Sprit verbrauchenden Auto, solange auf anderen Seiten der Welt diese Fahrt irgendwie notwendiger wäre. Wir verschwenden hier keine Kilometer auf der Autobahn durch irgendwelche, aber ich möchte gern das Auto, wo ich aufrecht sitzen kann und so. Also in der In-Sicht wirklich beeindruckend. Wir beschließen diesen Podcast mit dem Thema Vermögenssteuer, denn es war sehr lustig im Bundestag. Wir hören Kanzel Kiziltepe von der SPD, sie eröffnet eine Debatte, zu dem die FDP jetzt im Juni den Antrag gestellt hat, die Vermögenssteuer abzuschaffen. Wir fragen uns, Vermögenssteuer abschaffen, die ist dort eh schon abgeschafft, die wird doch seit 97 mehr erhoben. Ja, aber sie steht halt immer noch im Gesetzesbuch. Und wenn wir ein ordentliches Bemessungs- oder wie es auch immer heißt, Gesetz hätten, könnte man sie auch wieder einfach heranziehen und eintreiben. Aber naja, also hier die SPD eröffnet.
Frau Präsidentin, liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen, heute zeigt die FDP mal wieder ihr wahres Gesicht. Mit dem Gesetzentwurf wird klar, wem sie sich verpflichtet fühlen. Das sind nicht die täglich hart arbeitenden Menschen in unserem Lande, nicht die wahren Leistungsträgerinnen und Leistungsträger. Nein, es sind die Vermögenden, für die die FDP Politik macht.
So, soweit so bekannt. Jetzt allerdings macht sie ein mega Argument, denn die Vermögenssteuer wurde für verfassungswidrig erklärt, weil das, ich vergesse immer wieder, wie dieses Gesetz heißt, das Erhebungsbemessungs, naja, ihr wisst alle, was ich meine.
Das tolle Gesetz, ja.
Das Gesetz, das eben die Datengrundlage schafft, um überhaupt einen Vermögenssteuer anlegen zu können. Das wurde ja für nichtig erklärt, weil es schon 40 Jahre zu alt ist, der Datenbestand und deswegen und so weiter. Wurde allerdings jetzt auch für die Grundsteuer eigentlich aktualisiert, könnte man ja heranziehen. Sie macht jedenfalls den Punkt, die Vermögenssteuer ist gar nicht verfassungswidrig, sondern...
Liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen von der FDP, in Ihrem Antrag schreiben Sie, das Bundesverfassungsgericht hat die Vermögenssteuer 1996 für verfassungswidrig erklärt. Das stimmt so aber nicht. Eine Vermögenssteuer ist sogar explizit in unserem Gesetz, in unserem Grundgesetz vorgesehen. Es liegt viel näher darin, einen Vorstoß gegen unsere Verfassung zu sehen, dass wir seit 1996 keine Vermögenssteuer mehr erheben.
Es ist verfassungswidrig, die Vermögenssteuer nicht aktualisiert zu haben, sondern dass die Bundesregierung einfach sagt, ach so, das Bundesverfassungsgericht hat gesagt, wir sollen das bis nächstes Jahr aktualisieren, naja, machen wir einfach nicht. Also da könnte sozusagen eine Unterlassung, eine verfassungsgemäße, oder die Unterlassung, ein verfassungsgemäßes Gesetz herzustellen, könnte hier in Anklang gebracht werden. Naja, jetzt haben wir ja gehört, viele verabschieden sich, also auch Thomas de Maizière, seine Abschiedsworte haben wir ja gehört, sein Abschiedsthema. Er hat allerdings am Anfang sich nicht nehmen lassen, doch nochmal was zu diesem Antrag der Clownsmannschaft der FDP dort zu sagen.
Ich könnte für den Gesetzentwurf der FDP zumindest auf den ersten Blick durchaus Sympathien entwickeln. Vielleicht verfolgen sie ein richtiges Ziel, aber vielleicht bekommen sie am Ende das, was sie genau nicht möchten.
Hm, könnte es sein, dass die Vermögenssteuer zum Beispiel der konkurrierten Gesetzgebung unterfällt, was wir ja wissen, was das jetzt bedeutet, nämlich wie beim Mieten, wenn der Bund es nicht regelt, haben plötzlich die Länder Zugriff. Also sollte man vielleicht den Zustand aufrechterhalten, dass der Bund zwar eine Vermögenssteuer hat, die aber nicht erhebt, damit die Länder nicht zugreifen können, weil dann immer heißen, aber der Bund hat es ja schon geregelt. Da hat Thomas de Maiziere mal ebenso drauf hingewiesen. Und er fügt noch mal an.
Wenn der Bund das Vermögenssteuergesetz tatsächlich formal aufheben sollte, besteht die Gefahr, dass sich die Einführung von ganz verschiedenen Vermögenssteuerformaten in den Ländern etablieren. Und das ist das krasse Gegenteil von dem, was sie wollen.
Ups, FDP, hat da keiner mal nachgeguckt oder sich informieren, was hier eigentlich die Kräfteverhältnisse sind. Also bisher hat die SPD gesagt, ne, keine Vermögenssteuer.
Aber würde sich das ein Bundesland trauen, das einzuführen?
Also da es Bayern auf jeden Fall nicht mitmachen würde, hättest du wieder so, wie es bei der Grundsteuer auch ist, jetzt so Fluchtbewegungen wahrscheinlich, aber keine Ahnung. Wahrscheinlich könnte man den Sachsen-Anhalt eine Vermögenssteuer einführen, ohne dass der letzte Sachsen-Anhaltiner, der noch nennenswert Vermögen hat, da gehen würde. Also es wäre so ein, müsste man mal gucken. Aber die SPD hat es jetzt darauf hingewiesen, keine Vermögenssteuer zu haben, ist eigentlich verfassungswidrig. Und Thomas de Maizière hat hingewiesen, also wenn sie es hier abschaffen, dann machen es die Länder, und die machen das natürlich dankend gerne. Jetzt kommt die FDP und verteidigt das. Und jetzt wird es auch richtig absurd. Christian Dürr kommt ja mal mit folgendem Argument.
Ich hab grad nen Call gehabt mit Nordmetall, mit einer Kollegin aus ihren eigenen Reihen. Da wurde das große Lied auf den Mittelstand gesungen. Da wurde gesagt, jetzt die mittelständischen Unternehmen, der deutsche Mittelstand, gerade nach der Krise, der muss doch entlastet werden. Nachdem die Hilfen erst nicht angekommen sind, muss doch jetzt wenigstens vernünftig mit dem Mittelstand umgegangen werden. Nachdem erst die Hilfen nicht ankamen über viele Monate, kommt jetzt die Androhung einer neuen Substanzbesteuerung, meine Damen und Herren. Sie fallen dem deutschen Mittelstand in den Rücken mit dem, was sie im Bundestagswahlkampf fordern.
Also seine Argumentation ist, zuerst kamen die Corona-Hilfen nicht an bei den Armen, bei den Künstlern und so weiter.
Bei den armen Mittelständlern.
Genau. Also wir gehen jetzt mal auf die Künstler. Die Künstler, denen wird die Bühne verwehrt, sie kriegen ein Arbeitsverbot, wie das Ansofi Muttern so genannt hat. Zwei Jahre lang wird da quasi nichts möglich sein. Ist ja immer noch nicht. Nach Clubs alles ist zu. Jetzt sagt er, also zuerst verweigern sie den Armen, die Corona-Hilfen, und jetzt nehmen sie auch noch den reichenden Geld weg über eine Substanzbesteuerung. Das ist seine Argumentation. Da fragt man sich so ein bisschen...
Herrlich, aber er hat da noch einen Call.
Also es ist wirklich banane FDP. Hier sein zweiter Anlauf. Und so steht es auch im CDU-Programm. So habe ich es auch im Freitag. Ich muss den ganzen Satz zitieren. Der lautet ungefähr so. Eine Vermögenssteuer wäre auch schlecht für die Mieter. Deswegen sind wir gegen eine Vermögenssteuer, um die Mieter nicht weiter zu belasten. Und so ähnlich klingt es ja auch bei Christian Dürr.
Das ist das Ergebnis eines Gutachtens, den das damals bis 2017 SPD-geführte Bundeswirtschaftsministerium in Auftrag gegeben hat. Ich will zitieren. Das Gesamtsteueraufkommen des Staates fällt in Folge der Einführung einer Vermögenssteuer langfristig geringer aus als ohne Vermögenssteuer. Die langfristigen Folgen sind ein deutlich geringeres Investitions- Produktions- und Beschäftigungsniveau, als dies ohne Vermögenssteuer der Fall wäre. Die klare Botschaft lautet, meine Damen und Herren, sie richten sich nicht nur gegen den Mittelstand, das habe ich jetzt mehrfach wiederholt, sondern in Wahrheit richtet sich diese Steuer gegen die Millionen von Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmern in Deutschland, meine Damen und Herren. Das ist die Politik der Sozialdemokratie im Wahlkampf. Das kann kein Rezept für ein erfolgreiches Deutschland sein. Herzlichen Dank.
Fabelhaft, das ist aber auch diese Argumentation, die gegen den Mindestlohn immer gewesen ist. Eigentlich schadet der Mindestlohn den Leuten, die ihn bekommen sollten, denn die werden dann alle arbeitslos, dann wird das so hochgerechnet, dann gibt es da zwei Prozent mehr, drei Prozent mehr, dann müssen die da Kosten sparen, die werden entlassen und dann haben wir eine Million Arbeitslose wegen des Mindestlohns und deswegen sollte man ihn auf keinen Fall einführen. Und hier ist jetzt die Argumentation, wenn die ja dann auf ihr Vermögen Steuern zahlen müssen, dann müssen die das irgendwo wieder einsparen, dann werden die Mieten erhöht, dann passiert das und das alles, weil die ja unbedingt auch wieder auf diesen hohen Betrag kommen müssen, wo man sagt, nee, dann kommt doch mal mit 20 statt mit 21 Millionen parat. Geht ja vielleicht auch im Jahr. Und dann dekliniert man das so durch und dann kommt das wieder unten an. Man könnte das auch immer wieder so schön umdrehen und könnte eigentlich sagen, Mindestlohn 15 Euro, Hartz IV auf 800 Euro, denn das ist gut für die reichen Leute. Die konsumieren und die konsumieren bei der Familie Schwarz, bei Lidl, Aldi und sonst wo. Das kommt dann alles wieder nach oben an. Könnte man genauso umdrehen.
Stimmt, man kann es auch, ja, das ist ein sehr gutes Argument, kann man genauso gut sagen. Jetzt gib doch mal den Leuten richtig Geld in die Tasche, damit die Lidl-Eigentümer und die Rewe-Eigentümer noch reicher werden. Es kann doch nicht sein, dass wir nur 3000 Mercedes S-Klasse pro Quartal verkaufen, es müssten 4000 sein.
Genau.
Ist auch gut für Mercedes. Also in deren Sicht, ja, die FDP ist einfach völlig neben der Spur und kommt hier tatsächlich mit solchen Argumenten. Ich fand es überraschend, dass sie überhaupt die Vermögensteuer, ich hab mich schon gewundert, das steht ja auf der Bundestagsseite immer nur am Topic Vermögensteuer. Und ich so, äh, sind das ne halbe Stunde, guck ich mir das mal an. Und komm aus dem Staunen nicht raus, ja. Also in deren Sicht, Bananen-FDP, wer die wählt, der hat ja wohl den Schuss nicht gehört. Na ja, damit haben wir den Juni soweit verhandelt. Nicht verhandelt haben wir natürlich die Wahlen in Frankreich zum Beispiel, da waren Regionalwahlen. Alle zwölf, wie man es auch immer nennt, Departements oder so haben einfach nur ihre Regierung, die sie schon haben, bestätigt. Mit einer Wahlbeteiligung von 30% bei bis den 30-Jährigen ungefähr 20%. Also ist niemand mehr wählen gegangen. Vier von fünf jungen Menschen sind überhaupt nicht hingegangen. Le Pen und Macron abgeschlagen, aber die hatten eh nie dort. Macron hat nicht drauf gehofft, dass es mal irgendwo eine Regierung für ihn abfällt, für seinen Marsch durch die Institution. Aber Le Pen hat doch gehofft, dass sie mal eine, einen Sieg zumindest einfährt. Denn bislang hat ja Le Pen nie irgendwas gewonnen. Das war ja immer durch dieses Wahlsystem, da rutscht man ja nicht mit einer Stimme dann noch rein und macht so ein Petri-Style, ich bin hier meine eigene Fraktion und so, sondern bisher immer verloren. Und ist ganz interessant, in welche Wahlkampfzeit wir jetzt starten, denn Orban macht ja auch Wahlkampf gerade. Also sich Le Pen und PiS und so allem anzugucken, wird bestimmt Juli oder August hier mal Thema. Also in der Sicht, das ist auf dem Schirm. Und es ist auch wirklich interessant, denn in Frankreich ist einiges los. Also da rennen ja wirklich die Jugendlichen über die Straße, werden von der Polizei gejagt. Und mal gucken, was in NRW demnächst passiert, wenn da zum einen der Unterricht so umgebaut werden soll, dass da kein Wirtschafts- und Sozialkundeunterricht mehr stattfindet.
Sondern nur noch ein Fitmachen für die Wirtschaft.
Genau, das ist ja groß Anliegen der FDP und der CDU-Regierung dort. Und außerdem ein neues Versammlungsrecht. Man darf jetzt sich nicht mehr vermummeln, wo man sich fragt, da ist Corona. Klar, muss man sich vermummeln, ja, aber nicht mit schwarzen Masken und so. Also, die gehen ja jetzt echt ins Detail, um da irgendwie, naja.
Toilets for Future und alles Mögliche aufzuhalten.
Zu unterdrücken, genau.
Wie gesagt, da muss man an die Frankfurter Schule denken. Eine Demonstration, die zugelassen ist, ist vielleicht doch gar nicht wert, dass man demonstrieren geht. Also da durchaus ein bisschen mehr Mut mitbringen und ein bisschen mehr Widerstand. Und damit würde ich überleiten zum Salon, weil ich darüber nachgedacht habe, doch mal einen Roman noch mal zur Hand zu nehmen, der hin und wieder zitiert wird, aber vielleicht nur so halb richtig zitiert wird, und zwar Der Untertan von Heinrich Mann. Heinrich Mann wäre 150 geworden und aus diesem Anlass heraus haben Verlage sich entschieden, das nochmal neu aufzulegen. Fischer hat eine ganz wunderschöne Ausgabe rausgegeben. Und ich hab mir gedacht, ich greife nochmal zu diesem Roman. Wie viel Untertanengeist steckt denn eigentlich so in den Deutschen, dass sie das so alles mit sich machen lassen und dann noch sagen, ach so, dann ist das jetzt das neue Gesetz mit Vermungensgebote, halten wir uns dran. Oder dann vielleicht irgendwelche neuen Lockdown-Maßnahmen im Herbst selbst für Geimpfte. Und ich bin darauf gekommen, weil auch Restle, das so ein paar Mal in Tweets hatte, dass er sagte, ja, das ist so Untertanengeist. Und dann wurde er gleich so angegangen, was, das ist ja Sprache von Querdenkern oder so. Nee, überhaupt nicht. Das ist sehr gute republikanische Sprache. Und das ist also ein Roman, den man vielleicht unter diesem Gesichtspunkt nochmal neu lesen sollte. Und dann, wie angekündigt, das Buch über Indien, das ich sehr empfehlen kann. Und dann noch drei kleinere Dinge. Und dann werden wir ja gemeinsam Move, das Zeitalter der Migration, von Parag Kenna besprechen, das uns einen sehr, sehr globalen, demografischen Blick gibt auf die Welt.
Das liegt ja auch schon seit einer Weile. Ich hab da für so eine kleine Liste, da ist schon seit einer Weile drauf. Ich hab, es gibt ja noch so andere, von so Miller-Typen, der sich auch mal Afrika genauer angeschaut hat. Also während die Welt schrumpft, verdoppelt sich Afrika nochmal in den nächsten 30 Jahren. Und das führt ja auch zu erheblichem Migrationsdruck, dem dann die Europäer auch nicht mehr nachgeben können, weil, wer soll uns pflegen? Also ist ja eine ganz materielle Frage irgendwie. Wer soll's machen? Wir wollen ja nicht, dass unsere Kinder uns pflegen. Unsere Kinder sollen ja Software entwickeln und Chips und irgendwas mit RNA machen und so. Also da gibt's ja so einen, wie soll man sagen, so einen Unterschichten-Arbeitsmarkt, der auch bespielt werden muss. Also irgendwer muss die Bratwurst verkaufen. Aber mal gucken, ob ich noch ein ganzes Buch dazu lese. Ansonsten weiß ich noch nicht genau. Ich lass mich mal nächste Woche überraschen, dann mach ich jetzt eine kleine Lesewoche.
Du überraschst uns also nicht mit dem Baerbock Buch.
Hab ich nicht vor.
Ich dachte, du setzt jetzt die Reihe vor. Kann ich das machen? Ich weiß nicht, ich will dir jetzt auch nicht, also ich möchte es nicht lesen.
Ah, wenn du so anfragst meistens.
Aber ich bin ja Politiker-Bücher. Aber du hast ja doch einige Politiker-Bücher gelesen.
Das stimmt, könnte jetzt auch auf die Deutschen umschwenken.
Vielleicht gibt es irgendwas her. Vielleicht auch eine neue Sicht von dir auf Baerbock. Das wäre natürlich das Überraschendste überhaupt.
Also, ich werde mir Baerbock mal besorgen. Das sind ja Bücher, die sich dann doch relativ frühzeitig ergeben, was Inhalt, Überblick und so weiter auf den frühen Seiten angeht. Ansonsten... Ja, ich habe hier noch so ein anderes aus dieser Reihe, von der du das Triagebuch gelesen hast. Gibt es noch die Epistemisierung des Politischen von Alexander... Das haben wir im Salon besprochen. Das ist aber auch sehr gut. Ja, dann habe ich es mir auf die Liste gesetzt, weil ich es noch lesen wollte. Denn ich habe es hier auch bei mir. Denn es fiel mir auf, reklame ich jetzt diese Striche da. Weil der Untertitel, wie die Macht es wissen sieht, Demokratie gefährdet. Nee, dann haben wir das leider schon besprochen. Schade, sonst hätte ich mich da nochmal mit dem ganzen Text... Tja. Ansonsten bin ich tatsächlich, ich bin jetzt im Juni nicht sehr lesewütig gewesen, auch weil mich vieles enttäuscht. Also diese Dietmar Daert, ja, ich kaufe ich mir dann so ein Buch, weil Dietmar Daert auf dem Titel steht, dann ist es aber so ein niedergeschriebener Dialog. Ist ein bisschen traurig. Ich will es dann doch eher als Monolog sozusagen durchformuliert einfach haben. Naja, wir lassen uns einfach mal überraschen. Es ist ja noch ein bisschen Zeit.
Jedenfalls, Parakena bringt sehr viel mit und da können wir viel diskutieren, auch mit Blick auf Indien. Und auch, was ist eigentlich denn so das, was wir die Menschen nennen? Also das ist ganz interessant, dass wir, wenn wir in Statistik oder so von den Menschen reden, also die Mehrheit der Menschen meinen, dann sehen wir immer so Leute, die in einer Vorstadt leben und dort ein Reihenhaus vielleicht haben, zwei Kinder haben und sonst was. Und dann sagt Parakena, ne, wenn wir global von den Menschen reden, damit meinen wir jemand prekär in einer Großstadt lebend, am Existenzminimum knappernd und rackernd. Das ist eigentlich so der Durchschnittsmensch, den wir uns vorstellen müssen. Es sind einfach sehr, sehr viele neue Perspektiven, die da eröffnet werden, was ich erstmal großartig finde, dass das geschieht.
Ansonsten, ich lese ja immer noch selber so Bücher, wie zum Beispiel Anne Fleck, Energy. Die hat ein Buch, Energy, geschrieben. Das ist so ganz populärwissenschaftlich. Was ist, wenn dich Müdigkeit plagt? Woran könnte es liegen? Hessen, Schlafen, Sport, Bewegung, keine Ahnung. Das sind so Bücher, da traue ich mich nicht immer. Das ist nicht ganz so ein hochklassisches Salon. Die Tür war trotzdem interessant.
Ich würde ja immer sagen, zu wenig Cola Light getrunken.
Da muss man es dann mit solchem Humor irgendwie aushalten. Ansonsten, für schon mal Juli, August. Ich finde ja, wir sollten auch nochmal Stephanie Kelton oder so zusammenlesen. Ja. Also eigentlich Sachen kennt man schon und so, aber dass man doch den Defizit Mythos oder so... Gucken, dass man nochmal eine echte Grundlage legt, auch für den...
Das kommt, für September kommt ja auch das neue Buch von Adam Toos raus.
Ja, das ist ja so gut gebucht.
Da geht es um Wirtschaft und Corona. Allerdings wird das jetzt nicht so ein Corona-Buch werden.
Das wird schon weitergehen. Also wenn Adam Toos schreibt, dann ist es ihr Gebuch.
Und wir sollten dann im Juli auch über Wolfgang Streeck sprechen, der ja noch mal die große Frage stellt, ja was denn nun jetzt? Nationalstaaten oder Globalismus dann wirklich machen? Bei Suhrkamp, das wird ja schon lange erwartet und ist schon heiß diskutiert, weil es schon so ein paar Veröffentlichungen gibt. Das ist auf jeden Fall was, was man, glaube ich, ganz gut auch als Anschlussbuch an Parakena lesen kann, der einfach sagt, ne, es ist global, da brauchen wir gar nicht mehr viel drüber reden. Bei Streeck sieht das ein bisschen anders aus.
Ja, ich mein, Wagenknecht hat ja auch viel dazu geschrieben. Ja, Streeck sowieso auch gebucht. Ja, im August kommt auf jeden Fall noch Naturerleben von Manfred Spitzer. Da bin ich ja sehr gespannt. Er ist ja gelobter und gescholtener, was weiß ich. Und jetzt hat er sich mal nicht das Smartphone genommen und nicht die digitale Demenz und nicht die Einsamkeit, sondern die Natur. Und da bei uns gerade der Stadtwald stirbt, wird das auch... Warum stirbt der bei euch? In Frankfurt ist es so, dass man ermessen hat, trotz sehr regenreichen Frühjahrs hat sich die Quote der kranken Bäume, die auch wirklich sterben und dann rausgenommen werden müssen, noch mal von 97, 2 auf 99, 4 Prozent oder sowas erhöht. Also quasi alle. Nun ist aber der Stadtwald, der über das Blätterdach und das Wurzelzeug, das Grundwasser eigentlich gut hält, 30 Prozent des Frankfurter Grundwasserreservoirs. Fällt also perspektivisch aus, weshalb man gerade überlegt, ob man mein Wasser aufbereitet, um es dann wieder versickern zu lassen, da es zu schmutzig ist. Also man kann es nicht einfach rauspumpen, sondern es muss mal aufbereitet werden. Dafür braucht man Kläranlagen, gesamt kosten mehrere Milliarden. Weshalb die Stadt jetzt schon überlegt, den Wasserzehnt einzuführen. Also eine Sonderabgabe nur für dieses Problem, damit sich keiner fragt, warum ist hier irgendwie was uns so teurer? Wir zahlen jetzt alle einen Wasserzehnt, also eine Abgabe nur zur Aufbreitung des Wassers, um das Grundwasser dann wieder aufzufüllen, um überhaupt wieder Wasser zu haben für den täglichen Bedarf. Das finde ich ist ein crazy Beispiel, weil die CDU schreibt ja in ihrem Programm zum Beispiel auch zum Thema Wasser, aber nur so floskelhaft, weil sie ja immer diese Maxime hochhalten wollen. Also wenn hier irgendwas mit Klima ist, dann wollen uns ja die Grünen irgendwas verbieten. Jetzt sind wir aber in Frankfurt hier soweit, dass wir einsehen, uns verbieten hier nicht die Grünen, Wasser aus dem Wasserhahn zu nehmen, sondern es ist einfach keins da. Und wir brauchen jetzt darauf mal eine Antwort. Und damit läuft so eine ganze Argumentation einfach leer, wenn nämlich wirklich dann die materiellen Zwänge einfach mal klar werden, also wirklich ersichtlich. Und das ist ganz interessant, allerdings auch wirklich dramatischer, weil du hast jetzt auch Stadtparks, wo dann wirklich die Maxime ist. Das Grünflächenamt ist jetzt, man hat jetzt Abgeordnete dafür, dass sie einfach die Bäume da erhalten. Also da gibt es einfach Mitarbeiter, die sind zuständig, Bäume am Leben zu erhalten. Und die sorgen sich dann darum, dass da so Wassersäcke aufgestellt werden und die ordentlich gegossen werden. Und dass man den Wetterbericht genau im Auge behält, um dann zu sehen, aha, jetzt stehen vier Tage 35 Grad ohne Niederschlag an. Also müssen wir da jetzt mal 500 Liter pro Baum einplanen und so weiter. Also mittlerweile sind wir in einer Realität angekommen, wo wir echt viel machen müssen. Und es nicht die Grünen sind, die uns irgendwas verbieten, sondern wo einfach wirklich Grundlagen fehlen, die jetzt künstlich nachgebaut werden müssen.
Und die Bäume scheren sich dann auch nicht nach einem CDU-Programm. Die interessiert nicht, ob Laschet Kanzler wird oder nicht. Die sind dann einfach nicht mehr da. Oder überleben es dann vielleicht noch gerade so, man weiß es nicht. Das ist sehr, sehr dramatisch eigentlich, wenn man das sieht. Wir haben ja jetzt auch wieder so ganz, ganz heiße Tage erlebt. Und das ist dann eben nicht mehr alles nur Wetter, sondern das ist dann irgendwann Klima. Und man kann das sehr deutlich beobachten. Und wir sind immer noch nicht in diesem Modus eigentlich angekommen, dass wir das als Krise jetzt begreifen. Sondern immer noch sagen, ja, was machen wir dann, wenn die Krise kommt? Dabei ist die Krise jetzt tatsächlich da. Spürbar, man schwitzt mehr, es ist zu heiß, es ist zu trocken. Und wir sehen aber auch nach wie vor die Leute, die ihren saftig grünen Rasen vor der Haustür haben, weil sie den ganzen Tag den Rasensprenger aufgestellt haben, der, da weiß ich nicht, wie viele Hektoliter, den ganzen Tag besprüht für nichts und wieder nichts. Also wo ich auch denke, das kann doch gar nicht sein, dass man da auch ein Interesse, also welche Freude man da muss, muss man auch wohl haben mit diesem grünen Rasen, dass man da sagt, gut, da verschwende ich jetzt so viel Geld und Wasser, das eigentlich gebraucht wird, nur um diesen Rasengrün zu haben. Also mir ist diese Ideologie gar nicht klar. Dann denke ich, wenn du Geld ausgeben willst, kauf dir ein Bild, hängst an die Wand.
Ja, das sind vor allem Leute, die keine Ahnung haben davon, was jetzt gut wäre für ihren Rasen. Die gießen halt einfach, weil sie denken, ich hab's im Gefühl, ich soll dir jetzt mal da 100 Liter Wasser drauf geben. Dann machen sie es halt irgendwie. Ja, das ist alles total Banane. Und vielleicht hat auch der eine oder andere, weil es gibt ja, hast du TikTok mittlerweile auf deinem Smartphone installiert? Also auf TikTok gibts ganz interessante Videos von diesem Tornado, der da über Tschechien hinweggezogen ist, der wahrscheinlich auch sehr viel mit Klimaveränderungen zu tun hat. Und das will man echt nicht haben. Also das ist wie ein Twister, wie in diesem Film. Da ist einfach so ein gigantischer Tornado, der einfach die ganze, also du stehst am Fenster, guckst über die Straße und ein Haus nach dem anderen, von rechts nach links, Leute einfach verschwindet kurz in so einem Dunst und dann pfff, liegt alles brach. Also es ist wirklich erschreckend, das mittlerweile zu sehen. Vorhin ja schon gesagt, selbst für Kanada, British Columbia oder so heißt die Region da oben, es sind jetzt 50 Grad angesagt. Ich bin mal gespannt, ob wir noch vor der Bundestagswahl in Deutschland dann mal die 45 Grad sehen. Gab es noch nie, aber die Chancen stehen ja echt nicht schlecht, dass wir hier dann auch wirklich mal Hitze bekommen. Und wir wissen, Hitze hat Augenhöhe, was Todesursache mit Corona angeht. Also da sind wir schon seit einigen Jahren hier im Wettlauf und da ist Corona nicht Nummer eins.
Dann sehen wir uns im kühlen Salon nächste Woche wieder, würde ich sagen.
Richtig, genau, nächste Woche Salon. Und dann im Juli machen wir hier wieder vor Ort. Ist ja für den Hörer egal. Aber dann sitzen wir hier wieder beisammen, dann ist Corona vorbei.
So machen wir es.
Wir machen hier Independence Day. Sehr gut Leute, haut rein, bis dahin.
Bis dahin, tschüss.